SENATE NATURAL RESOURCES AND
WATER COMMITTEE WILL COME TO
ORDER, GOOD MORNING OR GOOD
AFTERNOON. IF THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE COULD COME TO ROOM
1200, WE CAN THEN ESTABLISH
QUORUM FOR OUR HEARING. WE HAVE
16 BILLS ON TODAY'S AGENDA, AND
FOUR ARE PROPOSED FOR CONSENT.
BILLS WILL BE GENERALLY HEARD.
AND FILE ITEM FILE ITEM ORDER.
ALTHOUGH I THINK WE'RE GOING TO
BE MAKING AN EXCEPTION FOR FILE
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GIBSON WHENEVER
HE GETS HERE, WE DON'T HAVE A
QUORUM YET, SO WE'RE GOING TO
PROCEED IN SUBCOMMITTEE AT THIS
POINT IN TIME, AND WE'LL
ESTABLISH A QUORUM WHEN
SUFFICIENT MEMBERS ARE PRESENT,
WE'LL HEAR FROM OUR FIRST
AUTHOR. I SEE NO OTHER AUTHORS
OTHER THAN SENATOR LACKEY IN THE
ROOM. SO WE'LL PROCEED WITH FILE
ITEM NUMBER 14, AB 3182,
ASSEMBLYMAN, YOU CAN PROCEED
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE.
OH, THERE'S A SEMINAR ON GIBSON.
OKAY YOU WANT TO PRESENT? YOU
CAN PRESENT THERE, OR YOU CAN
PRESENT AT THE STAND WHATEVER
YOU'D LIKE TO DO. ASSEMBLYMAN
I'LL MAKE AN OFFICIAL. ALL
RIGHT. WELL, THANK YOU. MR.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS, FOR ALLOWING
ME TO PRESENT THIS BILL 3001 82.
IN 1988, VOTERS APPROVED
PROPOSITION 70, WHICH WAS A
MONUMENTAL PARK BOND THAT
ALLOWED $20 MILLION TO DEVELOP
CONSERVATION LANDS IN SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTY AND ALLOWED
THEM TO ACQUIRE 366.55. WRITE
THAT DOWN 366.55 ACRES IN THE
CHINO AGRICULTURAL PRESERVE.
ROUGHLY TWO DECADES LATER, SB
1124 ALLOWED SOME OF THE PROP 70
PROVISIONS, AND SOUGHT TO
CLARIFY THEM. THE BILL GRANTED
THE COUNTY THE AUTHORITY TO SELL
OR EXCHANGE THE PROPERTIES IF
THEY WOULD BE USED FOR WILDLIFE
HABITAT, CONSERVATION AND OPEN
SPACE, OR PRESERVING THE
REGION'S AGRICULTURAL HERITAGE.
HOWEVER WHILE WELL-INTENTIONED,
THE BILL WAS AMBIGUOUS REGARDING
THE ALLOWED USE OF THE PROCEEDS
FROM LAND SALES. AB 3182 WILL
PROVIDE CLARITY AND ALLOW SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTY TO INVEST
THESE FUNDS INTO PARKS,
RECREATIONAL FACILITIES AND
CULTURAL VENUES TO ENHANCE
ACCESS AND AMENITIES WITHIN THE
CHINO AGRICULTURAL PRESERVE,
WHILE ADHERING TO THE INTENT OF
PROP 70. AND I WOULD LIKE TO
INTRODUCE MY WITNESS, BRAD
JENSEN, FROM THE SAN BERNARDINO
COUNTY'S LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS
DIRECTOR. THANK YOU. IS THIS
YOUR ONLY WITNESS? IT IS ALL
RIGHT. YOU HAVE UP TO FOUR
MINUTES, IF YOU'D LIKE. OH.
THANK YOU. WELL THANK YOU
EVERYONE. I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY HERE
TODAY ABOUT AB 3182, AS THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SAID, I'M BRAD
JENSEN. I'M THE LEGISLATIVE
AFFAIRS DIRECTOR FOR SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTY. THIS BILL IS
A DISTRICT BILL, AND IT
ADDRESSES THE 35 YEAR OLD
PROBLEM FOR OUR COUNTY, AS THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MENTIONED IN
1988, WE RECEIVED $20 MILLION AS
PART OF PROP 70, A VERY
IMPORTANT AND LANDMARK STATE
PARK BOND, AND WE WERE ABLE TO
PURCHASE NINE DAIRY PROPERTIES
IN CHINO. IF YOU'VE SEEN THE
MOVIE BACK TO THE FUTURE, WHEN
MARTY MCFLY GOES BACK IN TIME
AND HE VISITS HIS NEIGHBORHOOD,
IT'S ALL FARMLAND THAT WAS
FILMED IN CHINO, AND TODAY IT
DOES NO LONGER LOOKS LIKE THAT.
BUT WE DO OWN THESE PROPERTIES,
AND UNFORTUNATELY, THESE
PROPERTIES WERE NOT CONTIGUOUS.
THEY WERE NOT ADJACENT TO EACH
OTHER, SO WE WERE NEVER ABLE TO
REALLY PUT THEM TOGETHER AND
CREATE A FUNCTIONING PARK. SO 35
YEARS LATER, HERE WE ARE. WE
HAVE THESE PROPERTIES THAT WERE
NOT ENTIRELY CERTAIN WHAT TO DO.
THERE WAS A BILL PASSED 15 YEARS
AGO, SB 1124, THAT WE ARE
SEEKING TO CHANGE. AND WHAT IT
DOES IS IT ALLOWS US TO SELL OUR
PROPERTY. BUT WHAT WE WOULD LIKE
TO DO IS BECAUSE THE LAND HAS
APPRECIATED. WE'D LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO SELL OUR OUR LANDS,
PURCHASE, REPLACEMENT,
CONSERVATION PROPERTY NEXT TO
ONE OF OUR LARGE REGIONAL PARKS,
THAT PARK IS 2200 ACRES OF OPEN
SPACE AND IF WE'RE ABLE TO
PURCHASE ADDITIONAL LANDS NEXT
TO IT, WE EXPECT IT WILL BE
ABOUT 3000 ACRES. IT'S MUCH MORE
VALUABLE FOR ENVIRONMENTAL
PURPOSES, BETTER HABITAT, BETTER
CONSERVATION LAND. AND WHAT WE'D
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO DO IS TO TAKE
OUR LAND SALE PROCEEDS AND BE
ABLE TO INVEST IT IN ADDITIONAL
RECREATIONAL FACILITIES AT THIS
LARGE PARK, WE FEEL LIKE IT'S A
VERY IMPORTANT BILL. IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR US. IT'S A VERY
GOOD INVESTMENT IN THE LONG TERM
FUTURE FOR RECREATION IN THE
INLAND EMPIRE, AND WOULD
APPRECIATE YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN THE ROOM WHO WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY WITH ME TO
TESTIMONY, LIMIT YOUR COMMENTS
TO YOUR NAME, AFFILIATION, AND I
POSITION ON THE MEASURE. NICOLE
WATERMAN, ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
OF ONTARIO AND ORANGE COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS CHAIRMAN
DON WAGNER IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
. GOOD AFTERNOON, JOSH
GALLAGHER, ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY OF RIVERSIDE.
IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR
AND MEMBERS, JONATHAN MUNOZ ON
BEHALF OF INLAND EMPIRE HEALTH
PLAN IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
SEEING NO OTHER WITNESSES
APPROACHING THE MIC, WE'LL MOVE
IT ON TO OPPOSITION. DO WE HAVE
ANY WITNESSES? LEAD WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. SEEING NONE. ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION,
SEEING NONE. WE'LL BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS. ANY
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM
MEMBERS? OKAY. I'LL JUST STATE
BRIEFLY, I WANT YOU TO THANK YOU
FOR PRESENTING THIS BILL TODAY.
ASSEMBLYMAN I THINK THIS BILL
RAISES TOUGH QUESTIONS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE WILL NEED TO
CONSIDER GOING FORWARD ON HOW WE
PROTECT AND ENSURE THE LONG TERM
BENEFITS OF OUR BOND INVESTMENTS
IN A CHANGING WORLD. THIS IS NOT
THE FIRST BILL TO COME BEFORE
THIS COMMITTEE TO TRY TO ADDRESS
HOW WE THINK ABOUT PROP 70
PURPOSES AND BENEFITS AND I
APPRECIATE THE TOUGH SITUATION
YOUR COUNTY IS IN TO TRY TO MAKE
THE BEST USE OF PROP 70
INVESTMENTS WHEN THERE ARE NOT A
LOT OF OPPORTUNITIES FOR THE
ORIGINAL PURPOSE OF AGRICULTURE
IN WHAT IS BECOMING A MORE
URBANIZED AREA. I ALSO
APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT YOUR
COUNTY HAS BEEN RESPONSIBLE IN
ACQUIRING MORE LAND THAN WAS
REQUIRED OF IT BY PRIOR
LEGISLATION, SO WE ARE
RECOMMENDING AN EYE ON THIS
BILL. WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE?
JUST ENCOURAGE YOUR YOUR. AYE
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. I
DON'T THINK WE HAVE A QUORUM
JUST YET. WE NEED ONE MORE
MEMBER. SO WHEN WE HAVE THAT
WE'LL TAKE UP YOUR BILL. BUT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
ASSEMBLYMAN. THANK YOU SIR. I
WILL NOW LOOK MOVE TO OUR NEXT
BILL. WE'RE MAKING ONE EXCEPTION
TO FILE ITEM ORDER HERE. AND
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE UP
ASSEMBLYMAN GIBSON'S BILL. FILE
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT, AB 2465. YOU
CAN PRESENT WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY, SIR. OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, MR. CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS.
AND ALSO, THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR ALLOWING ME JUST TO MOVE IN
FRONT. AGAIN, THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT THIS BILL
ASSEMBLY BILL 2465. THIS BILL
AIMS TO PRIORITIZE LIES AND
PROVIDE FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE TO,
SOCIALLY DISADVANTAGED GROUPS BY
INCENTIVIZING EXISTING
ORGANIZATIONS TO DIVERSIFY THEIR
GOVERNING BODY BY EMPOWERING A
DIVERSE LED ORGANIZATIONS. AB
2465 AIM TO INTEGRATE THEM INTO
CALIFORNIA'S CLIMATE AND GREEN
INFRASTRUCTURE. WORKFORCE FORCE.
THERE ARE EVIDENCE FUNDING
DISPARITIES BETWEEN DIVERSE LED
ORGANIZATIONS AND THOSE THAT ARE
NOT CURRENTLY THERE ARE
SIGNIFICANT FUNDING DISPARITIES
BETWEEN DIVERSE LED
ORGANIZATIONS AND OTHERS. FOR
INSTANCE, BLACKS AND LATINOS.
NONPROFIT LEADERS RECEIVE ONLY
4% OF THE PHILANTHROPIC FUNDING
IN THE UNITED STATES, DESPITE
COMPRISING APPROXIMATELY 10% OF
NONPROFIT LEADERSHIP NATIONWIDE,
ACCORDING TO THE BRIDGE SPANNED
AND THIS, THE UNRESTRICTED NET
ASSETS OF BLACK LED
ORGANIZATIONS ARE 7,076% SMALLER
THAN THOSE THEIR COUNTERPARTS
AND THEIR AVERAGE PERCENTAGE OF
REVENUES WAS LESS THAN HALF.
THIS INEQUITIES IN ASSETS IS
CONCERNING AS FUNDING OFTEN
CORRELATES TO TRUST. DIVERSE LED
ORGANIZATIONS FACE CHALLENGES
SUCH AS FEWER STAFF, SMALLER
BUDGETS, AND LESS FUNDING,
LEADING TO THEM BEING REDLINED.
Ã TERM INDICATED TO SEVERE,
UNDERFUNDED LACK OF COMMUNITIES
OR LACK OF SUPPORTS IN
COMMUNITIES. ASSEMBLY BILL 2465
PROPOSED THREE POLICY CHANGES TO
ENHANCE EQUITY IN STATE'S
GOVERNMENTAL GRANT MAKING FOR
THE PROGRAMS INVOLVING
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE,
AGRICULTURE, URBAN FORESTRY,
LAND ACQUISITIONS AND
WATERSHEDS. IMPROVING AND
IMPROVEMENTS WITH A SUNSET DATE
OF JANUARY THE 1ST, 2031, FIRST
STATE AGENCIES WILL BE MANDATED
TO AWARD PREFERENCE POINTS TO
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS WITH THE
MAJORITY OF THEIR BOARD MEMBERS
COMING FROM DISADVANTAGED
GROUPS. SECONDLY, STATE AGENCIES
WOULD BE BARRED FROM PENALIZING
SOCIALLY DISADVANTAGED,
ORGANIZED ACTIONS THAT LACK
MATCHING FUNDS FOR GRANT
REQUESTS, THIRDLY AND LASTLY,
SOCIALLY DISADVANTAGED
ORGANIZATIONS, HISTORICALLY
UNDERREPRESENTED, AS CERTAIN AND
CERTAIN INDUSTRIES WOULD NOT BE
REQUIRED TO DEMONSTRATE
COMPETITIVE, COMPETITION.
COMPARABLE PROGRAMS OR PROJECTS.
EXCUSE ME, BY STATE AGENCIES AND
WITH ME TO PROVIDE SUPPORTING
TESTIMONY IS MR. CHARLES THOMAS,
THE CHIEF EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF
OUTWARD BOUND, ADVENTURES. AND
ALSO MR. DARRYL LU█N, EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
AFRICAN AMERICAN WATER EDUCATION
, FUND. THANK YOU. YOU HAVE TWO
WITNESSES. YOU EACH HAVE TWO
MINUTES, UP TO TWO MINUTES TO
TESTIFY, CAN APPROACH THE MIC
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. THANK
YOU. CHAIR AND MEMBERS. DARRYL
LUCIAN HERE, REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA AFRICAN AMERICAN
WATER EDUCATION FOUNDATION AND,
40 ACRE CONSERVATION LEAGUE.
PLEASED TO BE HERE AND PRESENT
THIS BILL TO YOU, THIS BILL
BASICALLY ATTEMPTED TO TAKE A
COMPILATION OF EXISTING, STATE
REGULATIONS AND GRANT GUIDELINES
AND TO KIND OF PACKAGE THEM
TOGETHER IN WHAT WE THINK WOULD
BE A BEST PRACTICES APPROACH
FOR, EQUITY. AND SO, AS A MATTER
OF WHAT, AS FAR AS WHAT'S IN THE
BILL, THERE'S NOT REALLY
ANYTHING NEW. WHAT WE FOUND IS
THAT STATE AGENCIES THAT HAVE
SUBSTANTIALLY SIMILAR PROGRAMS
HAVE VERY DIFFERENT GRANT
GUIDELINES. AND SO YOU CAN GO TO
ONE STATE AGENCY AND HAVE TO
SUBMIT A COMPLETELY DIFFERENT
SET OF PAPERWORK. THEY HAVE
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT SET OF
PRIORITIES AND OR REQUIREMENTS.
AND SO WHAT WE ATTEMPTED TO DO
WAS WORK WITHIN THESE EXISTING
PROGRAMS BECAUSE IT IS IMPORTANT
THAT AS WE THINK ABOUT 30, 30,
30 BY 30, WE THINK ABOUT THE
FUTURE OF AGRICULTURE. WE THINK
ABOUT THE FUTURE OF FORESTRY IN
THIS STATE. SO, THAT IS IT IS
SUFFICIENTLY INCLUSIVE OF, AND
THAT WE ARE ALL REPRESENTED IN
THESE EFFORTS AS WE ADDRESS
CLIMATE CHANGE, AS WE ADDRESS
WILDFIRE CHALLENGES AND THE
LIKE. I'M ALSO HERE TO ANSWER
ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS THAT YOU
ALL MAY HAVE. APPRECIATE YOUR
CONSIDERATION. AND LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUING TO DO THE GOOD
WORK THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE IN
RURAL CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU SO
MUCH, NEXT WITNESS. THANK YOU.
I'M CHARLES THOMAS, EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF OUTWARD BOUND
ADVENTURES, AND I'M HERE
OBVIOUSLY IN SUPPORT OF AB 2465
AND 1959 FOR PEOPLE SET AROUND,
A DINNER TABLE AND THEY SET DOWN
TO DISCUSS HOW TO BETTER ENGAGE
STUDENTS THAT WERE, SEEM TO BE
DISCONNECTED FROM THE
EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM. THOSE FOUR
PEOPLE WERE A SCIENCE TEACHER
FROM JACKIE ROBINSON'S HOME
SCHOOL, A SCHOOL COUNSELOR, A
FORMER TUSKEGEE AIRMAN, AND THE
FIRST AFRICAN AMERICAN
MOUNTAINEER IN THE SIERRA CLUB.
OBA THE OUTWARD BOUND ADVENTURES
WAS BORN, NOW 95,000 YOUTH
LATER, AND WE ARE THE OLDEST
NONPROFIT IN THE UNITED STATES
THAT'S DEDICATED EXCLUSIVELY TO
CONNECTING YOUTH AND COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR TO THE OUTDOORS AND
NATURE BASED EDUCATION AND
CAREERS AND CONSERVATION. WE
OPERATE THROUGHOUT THE GREATER
L.A. AREA, BUT WE ALSO OPERATE
IN MANY AREAS IN THE STATE FOR
DIFFERENT PROJECTS, A LOT OF OUR
WORK IS DONE IN SOUTH LOS
ANGELES, OBEYS PROGRAMS, PROVIDE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR ALL AGES TO
ENGAGE IN MEANINGFUL, NATURE
BASED EDUCATION AND LEADERSHIP,
AS WELL AS TRAINING. WE HAVE
THREE APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS
THAT PROVIDE PATHWAYS TO
SUCCESSFUL CAREERS IN
CONSERVATION A SECTOR OF WORK
SECTOR OF UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR HAVE
HISTORICALLY BEEN ABSENT FROM.
BUT I DON'T HAVE TO TELL YOU
IT'S IMPOSSIBLE TO HAVE A
PRESENCE WHEN NOBODY SEES YOU,
AS A PERSON OF COLOR WHO'S BEEN
RUNNING AN ORGANIZATION OF COLOR
FOR THE LAST 25 YEARS AND DOING
THIS WORK FOR 45 YEARS, I NEED
TO SHARE WITH YOU THAT WE PEOPLE
OF COLOR HAVE GROWN TIRED OF
ENDORSING A SYSTEM WHERE WE PLAY
A SMALL ROLE THAT KEEPS US
POWERLESS. AB 2465 WILL BE AN
INSTRUMENT OF EQUITY, A TOOL
THAT WILL PROMOTE A PRESENCE FOR
US AND FRANCHISES INTO A SYSTEM
AND A STRUCTURE THAT WAS NOT
BUILT FOR US OR BY US. 2465 WILL
MAKE IT POSSIBLE FOR THE UNSEEN
TO BECOME MORE VISIBLE, AND THE
UNHEARD VOICE TO BE HEARD. I
WANT TO EXTEND MY DEEPEST
APPRECIATION TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GIBSON FOR HIS LEADERSHIP AND
HIS FORESIGHT, AND AUTHORING
2465. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND I
AND THOUSANDS OF OTHERS WILL
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR I VOTE
ON THAT. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
DEEPLY APPRECIATE YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY, DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN THE ROOM WHO WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY AS ME TO SUPPORT
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL? JUST
LIMIT YOUR TESTIMONY TO YOUR
NAME, AFFILIATION AND SUPPORT OF
THE MEASURE. THANK YOU. MY NAME
IS AMOS WHITE. I'M WITH 100 K
TREES FOR HUMANITY. WE'RE AN
URBAN REFORESTATION NONPROFIT
BASED IN THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY
AREA. WE PLANT TREES FOR
CLIMATE, FOR EQUITY, AND FOR
PUBLIC HEALTH, SPEAKING ON
BEHALF AND SUPPORT OF THE, THANK
YOU LEGISLATION. THANK YOU.
APPRECIATE IT, ANY OTHER ME TWOS
IN THE ROOM? GOOD AFTERNOON, BEN
MCHUGH. OUTDOOR OUTREACH. AND
WE'RE IN SUPPORT OF THIS AS
WELL. THANK YOU. I SEE NO OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. WE'LL MOVE
TO OPPOSITION. DO WE HAVE ANY
LEAD WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION?
SEEING NO ONE APPROACH THE MIC,
DO WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION? ALL RIGHT, WE'LL
BRING IT BACK TO THE DAIS. ANY
MEMBERS HERE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS ON THIS BILL, SEEING
NO ONE. THANK YOU. AND, WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE ZIMMERMAN?
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MR.
CHAIRMAN. AND MEMBERS, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
ON 2465. AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU. ASSEMBLYMAN, WE
NOW HAVE A QUORUM. I BELIEVE IN
THE ROOM. SO WE'LL ESTABLISH
QUORUM ASSISTANT, IF YOU COULD
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL SENATORS.
MINH. AYE MINH IS HERE. CERO A
CERO HERE. ALAN DALLI. DALLI
HERE. EGGMAN EGGMAN. HERE.
GROVE. GROVE HERE. HURTADO.
LAIRD. LIMÓN PADILLA. STERN
STERN. HERE WE HAVE QUORUM.
OKAY. DO WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE
BILL, FOLLOWING EIGHT AB 2465.
SO MOVED. OKAY, WE HAVE A MOTION
FROM SENATOR STERN. THE MOTION
IS DUE PASSED. APPROPRIATIONS
ASSISTANT, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATORS MINH I MEAN, I SARDO.
NO, SATO. NO ALAN DALI, NO DALI,
NO EGGMAN. EGGMAN I GROVE.
HURTADO. LAIRD. LEMON PADILLA.
STERN. STERN I32. AND THE VOTE
ON THAT IS THREE TWO WILL LEAVE
IT ON CALL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
ASSEMBLYMAN, BEFORE WE PROCEED
TO OUR NEXT BILL, WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE TO THE CONSENT CALENDAR. WE
HAVE FOUR BILLS ON PROPOSED
CONSENT FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE,
SCR 15 BY SENATOR BRADFORD, FILE
ITEM NUMBER NINE, AB 2610 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA. FILE
ITEM NUMBER TEN, AB 2643 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOOD FILE ITEM
NUMBER 12, AB 3023 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PAPAN, SINCE WE HAVE
ESTABLISHED QUORUM, WE'LL VOTE
ON THESE ITEMS. ASSISTANT,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR.
MEN I MIN I SALADO HIGH SIERRA I
ALLEN. DALLI. DALLI I EGGMAN.
EGGMAN I GROVE. GROVE I HURTADO.
LAIRD LIMÓN. PADILLA. STERN.
STERN I OKAY SIX ONE, THE VOTE
ON THAT IS SIX ZERO WILL LEAVE
IT ON CALL AND WE'LL MOVE BACK
TO FILE ITEM NUMBER 14 AB 3182
BY ASSEMBLYMAN LACKEY, DO WE
HAVE A MOTION ON THAT BILL, WE
HAVE A MOTION FROM ASSEMBLYMAN,
FROM SENATOR SATO. A MOTION IS
Dð PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
ASSISTANT, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR MINH. MINH I SATO. SATO
I ALLEN. DALLI. DALLI I EGGMAN.
EGGMAN I. GROVE. GROVE I
HURTADO. LAIRD. LIMÓN. PADILLA
STERN A. STERN I SIX, THAT VOTE
IS SIX ZERO. WE'LL LEAVE IT ON
CALL. AND WITH THAT, WE'LL MOVE
ON TO OUR NEXT BILL. FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO, AB 1992 BY
ASSEMBLYWOMAN BONNER. CAN
PROCEED WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
GOOD AFTERNOON, MR. CHAIR, AND
SENATORS. AB 1992 WOULD
AUTHORIZE THE CALIFORNIA COASTAL
COMMISSION TO ADD BLUE CARBON
DEMONSTRATION PROJECTS TO THE
SUITE OF FACTORS IT CONSIDERS
FOR POTENTIAL MITIGATION WHEN
APPROVING COASTAL DEVELOPMENT
PERMITS, WHERE FEASIBLE.
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT BLUE CARBON
ECOSYSTEMS, SUCH AS SEA GRASSES
AND SALT MARSHES ARE MORE
EFFICIENT IN CAPTURING AND
STORING ATMOSPHERIC CARBON THAN
MOST TERRESTRIAL FORESTS. SADLY
CALIFORNIA HAS LOST OVER 90% OF
ITS HISTORICAL WETLANDS, AND THE
ASSOCIATED BENEFITS THEY
PROVIDE, SUCH AS PROTECTING
COASTAL COMMUNITIES FROM THE
HARMFUL IMPACTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE, SUCH AS SEA LEVEL RISE
AND FLOODING. THIS BILL IDEA IS
A RESULT OF A TRANSPORTATION
PROJECT IN NORTH COUNTY, SAN
DIEGO, WHERE WIDENING OF THE I-5
FREEWAY LANES ADDRESSED A NUMBER
OF ENVIRONMENTAL CONCERNS
EXPRESSED BY RESIDENTS IN REGARD
TO THE IMPACTS TO WILDLIFE
LIVING IN SIX COASTAL LAGOONS,
32 ACRES OF WETLANDS, AND 74
ACRES OF COASTAL SAGE. DURING
THE COASTAL PERMIT PROCESS, THE
COASTAL COMMISSION APPROVED THE
PROJECT WITH IMPROVEMENTS
RELATED TO ENHANCING MARINE
ENVIRONMENTALLY SENSITIVE
HABITAT AREAS, AND IT HAD TO DO
WITH THE ADVOCACY OF ONE OF OUR
ORGANIZATIONS TO INCLUDE LOTS OF
SEAGRASS AND LOTS OF SALT
MARSHES. IN THIS INNOVATION. AND
THIS INNOVATION APPROACH SHOULD
REALLY BE THE BEST PRACTICE IN
MITIGATING IMPACTS OF NATURAL
RESOURCES. AND THAT CAN BE
REPLICATED TO BUILD AND RESTORE
BLUE CARBON SINKS. WE TOOK AN
AMENDMENT AND ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS WHICH REMOVED ANY
OPPOSITION. AND THIS BILL WAS
AMENDED TO APPLY TO
NONRESIDENTIAL PROJECTS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. AND WITH ME HERE I HAVE
ANGELA KEMSLEY WITH WILDCOAST IN
SAN DIEGO, THE SPONSORS OF THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. YOU HAVE UP TO
FOUR MINUTES IF YOU'D LIKE TO
TAKE THAT. ALL RIGHT. GOOD
AFTERNOON. THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK. MY NAME IS
ANGELA KEMSLEY. I'M THE DIRECTOR
OF CONSERVATION IMPACT AT WILD
COAST. I'M HERE TODAY TO PROVIDE
STRONG SUPPORT FOR AB 1992,
WHICH WILL PROTECT AND CONSERVE
BLUE CARBON ECOSYSTEMS IN THE
COASTAL PERMITTING PROCESS.
CALIFORNIA IS FACING ONE OF OUR
BIGGEST CHALLENGES YET CLIMATE
CHANGE. LUCKILLY CALIFORNIA IS A
GLOBAL BIODIVERSITY HOTSPOT WITH
MANY ECOSYSTEM RAIMES NATURALLY
ABLE TO SEQUESTER AND STORE
CARBON OF SPECIAL NOTE, OUR BLUE
CARBON ECOSYSTEMS, BLUE CARBON
IS CARBON REMOVED FROM THE
ATMOSPHERE BY PLANTS IN COASTAL
AND MARINE ECOSYSTEMS, SUCH AS
MANGROVE FORESTS AND THE SALT
MARSHES AND SEAGRASS BEDS THAT
ARE PRESENT ALONG THE COAST OF
CALIFORNIA. THROUGH
PHOTOSYNTHESIS, PLANTS PULL
CARBON OUT OF THE ATMOSPHERE,
AND SOME OF THAT CARBON IS
STORED IN THE PLANTS WOODY
TISSUE. AND THEN IN BLUE CARBON
ECOSYSTEMS, MUCH OF THE CARBON
IS ACTUALLY THEN BURIED IN THE
SOIL, SINCE THE SOIL AND BLUE
CARBON ECOSYSTEMS IS ALMOST
CONTINUALLY WET, THERE'S A
SLOWER RATE OF DECOMPOSITION, SO
LESS CARBON IS RELEASED BACK
INTO THE ATMOSPHERE WHEN THE
PLANTS DIE. ADDITIONALLY THE
CARBON STORED IN THE SOIL OF
BLUE CARBON ECOSYSTEMS, IF LEFT
UNDISTURBED, CAN BE STORED FOR
THOUSANDS OF YEARS. PRELIMINARY
DATA FROM RESEARCH THAT
WILDCOAST IS CONDUCTING WITH THE
SCRIPPS INSTITUTION OF
OCEANOGRAPHY SUGGESTS THAT THESE
BLUE CARBON ECOSYSTEMS IN SAN
DIEGO ARE ACTUALLY STORING UP TO
4.8 TIMES MORE CARBON THAN THEIR
TERRESTRIAL COUNTERPARTS, SUCH
AS THE GRASSLANDS THAT WE HAVE.
UNFORTUNATELY, IT'S ESTIMATED
THAT ONLY 10% OF CALIFORNIA'S
HISTORIC WETLANDS REMAIN, SO NOW
IS THE TIME TO TAKE ACTION. AB
1992 WILL ENSURE THAT BLUE
CARBON ECOSYSTEMS ARE PRESERVED
BY ALLOWING THE CALIFORNIA
COASTAL COMMISSION TO REQUIRE
DEMONSTRATION PROJECTS TO OBTAIN
CERTAIN PERMITS, AND WILL ADD TO
THE RAPIDLY GROWING RESEARCH IN
THE FIELD OF BLUE CARBON. BY
REQUIRING MONITORING OF
PERMITTED PROJECTS, ADDING
REFERENCES TO BLUE CARBON
PROJECTS AND GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS REDUCTION IN THE
COASTAL ACT IS CONSISTENT WITH
THE LEGISLATURE'S PRIORITY TO
ENSURE ALL STATE AGENCIES ARE
PROACTIVE PARTNERS IN THE FIGHT
AGAINST CLIMATE CHANGE, AND
CONTINUES THE LEGISLATURE'S
IMPORTANT EFFORTS TO MODERNIZE
THE COASTAL ACT THROUGH BILLS
THAT HAVE ADDED SEA LEVEL RISE,
CIVIL RIGHTS AND ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE TO THE STATUTE. WE
ENCOURAGE YOU TO SUPPORT AB 1992
BECAUSE IT ENSURES THAT COASTAL
WETLANDS WILL CONTINUE TO BE A
NATURAL SOLUTION TO CLIMATE
CHANGE FOR YEARS TO COME. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH. DO WE
HAVE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN THE
ROOM IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL WITH
ME? TWO TESTIMONY. PLEASE LIMIT
YOUR TESTIMONY TO YOUR NAME,
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
MEASURE. VIÆT MIKE WALLACE WITH
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL VOTERS
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. BEN
MCHUGH, OUTDOOR OUTREACH AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON. MOIRA TOPP, ON BEHALF
OF THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO IN
SUPPORT. GABRIELLA FAZIO WITH
SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. ALEX LIMA FOR AUDUBON
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. KATIE
MCCAMMON WITH 350. SACRAMENTO IN
SUPPORT. RUTH MCDONALD FOR
CLIMATE REALITY PROJECT
CALIFORNIA COALITION IN SUPPORT.
ALL RIGHT. IF THERE'S NOBODY
ELSE IN SUPPORT, DO WE HAVE ANY
LEAD WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS PROJECT OR THIS BILL AT
THIS TIME? NOT. DO WE HAVE
ANYBODY IN THE AUDIENCE THAT
WANTS TO DO A ME TOO OPPOSITION?
IF NOT, WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO
THE DAIS. ANYBODY HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS? CONCERNS. WE HAVE A
MOTION TO MOVE THE BILL. WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE. ALL RIGHT. SO WE CAN GO
AHEAD AND CALL ROLL. THIS IS FOR
AB 1992. THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATOR MINH, SENATOR CIARDO.
NO. CERRADO. NO. ALLEN. DALY NO.
DALY. NO. EGGMAN. EGGMAN AYE.
GROVE. GROVE. NO. HURTADO LAIRD.
LIMÓN. PADILLA PADILLA. AYE.
STERN. A STERN. AYE THREE THREE
MCCOLLUM. SO WE'LL GET THAT.
THAT MEASURE IS AT THREE THREE,
AND WE'RE GOING TO LEAVE IT ON
CALL. THANK YOU, THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT. LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE MISS
ERWIN, WHO WAS FIRST. OH OKAY.
YEAH. PELLERIN SO WE'RE KIND OF
GOING IN FILE ORDER. AND
ACCORDING TO WHO'S HERE. AND SO,
MISS PELLERIN, SINCE YOU ARE,
HERE. OH, MISS QUIRK-SILVA VÀ.
SHE'S HERE. OH, SHE IS HERE.
SHE'S JUST HIDING IN THE BACK.
MISS PELLERIN, YOU'RE WELCOME TO
SIT BACK DOWN. EVER PRETTY WELL,
THOUGH. SO THIS THIS BRINGS US
TO FILE ITEM THREE, WHICH IS AB
2038, ASSEMBLY MEMBER
QUIRK-SILVA. YOU MAY BEGIN WHEN
YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR. AND SENATORS, I WANTED TO
GIVE A LITTLE BACKGROUND ON THIS
BILL. I WAS A MEMBER OF THE
SELECT COMMITTEE ON STATE PARKS,
AND THIS LEGISLATION IDEA
ACTUALLY CAME OUT OF SITTING ON
THAT SELECT COMMITTEE. AND I'M
HAPPY TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL
2038. THIS BILL WOULD ENSURE
THAT ELIGIBLE COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS RECOGNIZED NATIVE
AMERICAN TRIBES AND CERTIFIED
COMMUNITY CONSERVATION CORPS WHO
PROVIDE NON COMMERCIAL ACCESS.
OUTDOOR PROGRAMS WILL HAVE THE
SAME ABILITY TO ENTER STATE
LANDS AND WATERS AS THE GENERAL
PUBLIC, BUT WITHOUT ADDITIONAL
RESTRICTION FEES OR PERMIT
REQUIREMENTS IMPOSED ON THEM.
SPECIAL EVENTS, PERMITS AND FEES
MAY STILL BE REQUIRED.
FORTUNATELY, CALIFORNIA IS KNOWN
FOR SOME OF THE MOST BEAUTIFUL
AND ICONIC OUTDOOR PLACES OUR
WORLD HAS TO OFFER. FROM OUR
GIANT SEQUOIA TREES TO AMAZING
DESERT LANDSCAPE SCAPES AND
UNIQUE WEST COAST NATURAL
BEACHES, OUTDOOR ACCESS IS
LINKED TO COUNTLESS BENEFITS AND
PERHAPS MOST IMPORTANTLY, HEALTH
BENEFITS FOR ALL AGES. DESPITE
RECENT SIGNIFICANT STRIDES TO
PRIORITIZE EQUITABLE OUTDOOR
ACCESS BARRIERS CONTINUE TO
PERSIST FOR MANY CALIFORNIANS,
PREVENTING THEM FROM ACCESSING
THE OUTDOORS. BARRIERS LIKE
TRANSPORTING COSTS AND EQUIPMENT
EXPENSES CONTINUE TO HINDER THE
ENJOYMENT OF OUR PUBLIC SPACES.
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
AND TRIBAL OUTDOOR EQUITY
PROGRAMS HELP FURTHER THE
STATE'S GOALS BY SERVING AS
TRUSTED GUIDES FOR GROUPS FROM
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES TO
EXPERIENCE THE OUTDOORS.
REGRETTABLY, THEY OFTEN FACE
REGULATORY BARRIERS NOT IMPOSED
ON THE GENERAL PUBLIC, INCLUDING
HIGH FEES AND LIMITS ON
ACTIVITIES SUCH AS TIMES, DATES,
LOCATIONS AND FREQUENCIES. THIS
BILL WILL EASE BURDENS FOR
ELIGIBLE ENTITIES AND STREAMLINE
REGULATORY MANAGEMENT OF SMALL,
NONCOMMERCIAL, OUTDOOR EQUITY
ACTIVITIES, INCREASE RESOURCE
EFFICIENCY, AND LESSEN THE
ADMINISTRATIVE BURDEN ON STATE
LAND MANAGERS AND ELIGIBLE
ENTITIES. PARTNERS WITH ME TODAY
TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY AND ANSWER
ANY QUESTION IS BEN MCCUE, WHO
IS THE DIRECTOR AND EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF OUTDOOR OUTREACH.
THANK YOU, MR. MCHUGH. YOU HAVE
TWO MINUTES, PLEASE. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. VICE CHAIR SATO AND
SENATORS, GOOD AFTERNOON.
OUTDOOR OUTREACH IS A SAN DIEGO
BASED NONPROFIT WORKING TO
CONNECT YOUTH TO THE
TRANSFORMATIVE POWER OF THE
OUTDOORS. OUR PROGRAMS ADDRESS
BARRIERS TO ACCESS BY PROVIDING
EQUIPMENT, TRANSPORTATION,
INSTRUCTION, AND MEALS AT NO
COST TO PARTICIPANTS AND THEIR
FAMILIES. FOR MANY, OUR PROGRAMS
PROVIDE PARK AND BEACH ACCESS
THAT WOULD OTHERWISE OTHERWISE
BE OUT OF REACH. PARTICIPANTS
HAVE SHARED HOW THE CONNECTIONS
THEY'VE MADE THROUGH OUR
PROGRAMS TO THE OUTDOORS AND
SUPPORTIVE PEERS AND MENTORS
HAVE HELPED THEM OVERCOME
SIGNIFICANT ADVERSITY IN THEIR
LIVES, IMPROVE MENTAL AND
PHYSICAL HEALTH, STRENGTHEN
THEIR CONNECTION TO FAMILY AND
FRIENDS, AND INCREASE THEIR
SENSE OF BELONGING AND A LOVE
FOR NATURE IN RECENT YEARS,
NONPROFITS INCLUDING OURS HAVE
PARTNERED WITH THE STATE TO
FURTHER PARK AND COASTAL ACCESS
THROUGH SCHOOL WEEKEND AND
SUMMER ACTIVITIES. DESPITE THIS
SUPPORT, WE'RE CONFRONTED WITH
ACCESS CHALLENGES TO STATE LANDS
AND WATERS THAT ARE NOT FACED BY
THE GENERAL PUBLIC, AND THESE
INCLUDE EXCLUSIONS, CAPS ON
ACTIVITY FREQUENCY AND
BURDENSOME AND EXPENSIVE
PERMITTING REQUIREMENTS. THIS IS
BASICALLY CREATED A DOUBLE
STANDARD ACROSS THE STATE, AND
WHO GETS TO ENJOY ACCESS AND
BENEFIT FROM OUR PARKS AND
BEACHES? IF YOU'RE A KID WHOSE
FAMILY HAS A CAR, PARENTS WITH
THE FREE TIME AND MONEY TO PAY
ENTRANCE FEES, THE APPROPRIATE
EQUIPMENT, AND THE RIGHT
INFORMATION, YOU'RE BASICALLY
FREE TO ENJOY ANY STATE PARK OR
BEACH ANYTIME IT'S OPEN TO THE
PUBLIC. BUT IF YOU'RE A KID WHO
RELIES ON ONE OF OUR
ORGANIZATIONS TO GET YOU OUT TO
THE PARKS OR BEACHES, BASICALLY
YOUR VISITS CAN BE LIMITED TO
CERTAIN DAYS OF THE YEAR,
CERTAIN PARK UNITS, AND
OFTENTIMES THE FREQUENCY OF
TIMES THAT YOU CAN VISIT. IF
YOU'RE A CALIFORNIA KID IN THE
SECOND GROUP, YOU'RE MUCH MORE
LIKELY TO BE LOW INCOME, A
PERSON OF COLOR IMPACTED BY
HEALTH AND EDUCATIONAL
DISPARITIES, AND FROM AN
ENVIRONMENTAL, JUSTICE AND
CLIMATE VULNERABLE COMMUNITY.
THE LACK OF A STATEWIDE STANDARD
FOR PARK ACCESS HAS IMPACTED THE
STATE'S OUTDOORS FOR ALL EFFORTS
AND UNDERMINE THE ACCESS
PROVISIONS OF THE COASTAL ACT
AND THE PUBLIC TRUST DOCTRINE.
COUNTLESS STAFF TIME FOR
COMMUNITY GROUPS, AS WELL AS
STATE PARKS, IS SPENT PROCESSING
SPECIAL EVENT PERMITS FOR
ACTIVITIES THAT HAVE ALREADY
BEEN APPROVED FOR THE GENERAL
PUBLIC, FREE OF RESTRICTIONS.
YOU CAN WRAP UP, PLEASE. THANK
YOU SO MUCH, AND FOR THIS, WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. DID ANYBODY LEAD ANY OTHER
LEAD WITNESSES. IF THERE ARE
NONE, ANYBODY IN SUPPORT OF THE
MEASURE MAY COME FORWARD AND
STATE. SO JUST STATE YOUR NAME,
THE ORGANIZATION YOU REPRESENT
AND YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE MEASURE
. GOOD AFTERNOON, SARAH NOCITO,
ON BEHALF OF THE NATIONAL MARINE
MANUFACTURERS ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT. HIGH. KRISTIN GOREE, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
CONSERVATION CORPS IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON. MY NAME IS DAN
JACOBSON. ENVIRONMENT CALIFORNIA
SUPPORT. VERY GOOD. THANK YOU,
DO WE HAVE ANYBODY IN THE ROOM
THAT WISHES TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL, IF NOT
ANY METOOS THAT JUST WANT TO
COME UP AND SAY OPPOSE AND THEN
GO SIT DOWN? NO. OKAY. WE'RE
GOING TO BRING IT BACK TO THE
DAIS. ANYBODY UP HERE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS, SENATOR EGGMAN. THANK
YOU. I WOULD JUST LIKE TO MOVE
THE BILL AND SAY IT'S ALWAYS
NICE TO SEE THAT GOOD POLICY
PROVIDING ACCESS TO OUR OUTDOORS
AND STATE PARKS COMES FROM A
SELECT COMMITTEE THAT SOME
PEOPLE THINK NOTHING COMES FROM
A SELECT COMMITTEE. SO THANKS
FOR TAKING RECOMMENDATIONS AND
PUTTING IT INTO ACTION. SO I'D
MOVE THE BILL. ALL RIGHT.
SENATOR DULL, I ALSO AM GOING TO
SUPPORT THE BILL. BUT I DO HAVE
A QUESTION, SO WE IN 2022, WE
DID, $57 MILLION IN GRANT
FUNDING TO 125 COMMUNITIES AND
THEN ANOTHER 50 MILLION IN THE
SECOND ROUND OF FUNDING IN
DECEMBER OF 2023. AND THEN SOME
MORE OUT OF PROPOSITION 64 WAS
18 MILLION. AND THEN ON TOP OF
THAT, WE ALSO PASSED SOME
LEGISLATION A YEAR AGO THAT I
THINK WAS A YEAR AGO, MAYBE TWO
YEARS AGO, THAT ALLOWED YOU TO
GET GO TO THE LIBRARY, CHECK OUT
A LIBRARY CARD, AND GO TO A
STATE PARK FOR FREE. SO I WANTED
TO. THE QUESTION I HAVE IS,
FUNDING FOR THIS, IS IT COMING
OUT OF THOSE FUNDS THAT WE
ALREADY HAVE ALLOCATED, OR IS
THERE GOING, IS THIS GOING TO BE
A DIFFERENT POT OF RESOURCES?
YEAH. SO THIS BILL ACTUALLY ASKS
STATE PARK TO DO LESS, SO
HOPEFULLY IT WILL IT WILL
ADDRESS IT WILL DECREASE THE
ADMINISTRATIVE BURDEN, CURRENTLY
WE RECEIVE SOME OF THOSE OUTDOOR
EQUITY GRANT PROGRAM FUNDS, AND
WE'RE ACTUALLY HAVING TO INVOICE
BACK THE STATE FOR OUR STAFF
TIME TRYING TO GET PERMITS TO
ACCESS STATE LANDS AND WATERS.
SO YOU'RE STREAMLINING THE
PROCESS SO THAT YOU'RE GOING TO
SAY THESE THINGS ARE OPEN TO
THESE COMMUNITIES. YOU CAN JUST
GO WITHOUT HAVING TO GET A
PERMIT. CORRECT. AS AS LONG AS
YOU MEET CERTAIN REQUIREMENTS
AROUND NONPROFIT OR TRIBAL THANK
YOU PROGRAMS. AND I WOULD JUST
ADD TO THAT, ONE OF THE THINGS
FROM THE SELECT COMMITTEE WAS
NOT THAT THEY WEREN'T APPLYING
FOR PERMITS, BUT IT MIGHT BE A
GROUP THAT IS TAKING ONE GROUP
OF JUST, SAY, STUDENTS ONE WEEK
FOR AN OUTING AND THEN THE NEXT
WEEK OR MONTH LATER THEY WANT TO
TAKE ANOTHER GROUP. THEY'D HAVE
TO REAPPLY FOR A WHOLE NOTHER
PERMIT EVERY SINGLE TIME THEY
WERE GOING OUT FOR THE SAME
ACTIVITY. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
WE HAVE A Dð PASS, MOTION, TO
APPROPRIATIONS. AND AT THIS
TIME, YOU CAN GO AHEAD AND
CLOSE, RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE, VOTE. ALL RIGHT. GO AHEAD
AND TAKE ROLL. ALL RIGHT.
SENATOR. MEN. SENATOR SARDO, I
SARDO I ALLEN DALLI DALLI I
EGGMAN EGGMAN I GROVE. GROVE I
HURTADO. LAIRD. LAIRD I LIMON
PADILLA PADILLA I STERN, STERN I
. 567, SEVEN. THAT HAS SEVEN
VOTES. WE'RE GOING TO LEAVE IT
OPEN FOR OTHER MEMBERS TO ADD ON
TO. SO THAT BRINGS US TO ANOTHER
ITEM OF YOURS. IT'S, ITEM AB
3150, SAME AUTHOR. GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS, FIRST I WOULD LIKE TO
BEGIN BY THANKING THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR WORKING WITH ME ON
THIS BILL. AND I DO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS. ASSEMBLY
BILL 3150 STRENGTHENS THE
ACCURACY OF CALIFORNIA'S FIRE
HAZARD SEVERITY ZONE MAPS BY
ALLOWING THE STATE FIRE MARSHAL
TO CONSIDER MAP REVISIONS
THROUGH A PETITION PROCESS.
THESE MAPS EVALUATE HAZARD BASED
ON THE PHYSICAL CONDITIONS THAT
CREATE A LIKELIHOOD AND EXPECTED
FIRE BEHAVIOR OVER A 30 TO 50
YEAR PERIOD, WITHOUT CONSIDERING
MITIGATION MEASURES SUCH AS HOME
HARDENING, DEFENSIBLE SPACE,
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT, OR FUEL
REDUCTION EFFORTS. AMENDMENTS
TAKEN TODAY ALLOW FOR A PUBLIC
PROCESS AROUND THE LOCAL
RESPONSIBILITY AREA. MAPS SHIFT
SOME REGULATORY AUTHORITY FROM
THE BOARD OF FORESTRY TO THE
STATE FIRE MARSHAL TO ELIMINATE
REDUNDANCY AND CREATE
EFFICIENCIES, AND REVISE THE
PRELIMINARY PETITION PROCESS
THAT STILL ALLOWS FOR THE
CONSERVATION CONVERSATION TO
OCCUR WITH THE STATE FIRE
MARSHAL. AB 3150 IS A GOOD
GOVERNMENT MEASURE THAT
ESTABLISHES A MECHANISM TO
UPDATE THE FIRE HAZARD SEVERITY
ZONE MAPS FOR 50 ACRES OR MORE
SIMILAR TO THE PROCESS USED FOR
FLOOD MAP REVISIONS, WITH ME
TODAY TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY TO
TESTIMONY AND SUPPORT IS MR.
SILVIO FERRARI WITH THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION. ALL RIGHT, MR.
FERRARI, YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES,
PLEASE. YES. GOOD AFTERNOON, MR.
CHAIR. MEMBERS. SILVIO FERRARI,
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION,
PROUD TO BE THE SPONSORS OF THIS
BILL. AND BIG THANK YOU. I CAN'T
SAY THANK YOU ENOUGH TO THE
COMMITTEE AND THE GOOD WORK, THE
COMMITTEE CONSULTANT FOR GETTING
INTO THIS THING, WILDFIRE ISSUES
ARE ALWAYS VERY, VERY DIFFICULT.
THERE'S A NUMBER OF BUILDING,
MOVING AND ALWAYS TO KNOW WHAT
IS GOING ON IN THESE THINGS IS
DIFFICULT TO DO. AND I THINK
ROLLING OUR SLEEVES UP, STILL
PRODUCED A VERY GOOD PRODUCT
THAT KEPT THE SPIRIT OF WHAT WE
WERE TRYING TO ACHIEVE. SO TWO
REALLY IMPORTANT AMENDMENTS AND
AS THE AUTHOR SAID, WE'RE
ACCEPTING ALL OF THE AMENDMENTS
AND HAPPY TO DO THAT. BUT ONE OF
THOSE AMENDMENTS ENSURES THAT
THE MAPS ARE UPDATED AT LEAST
EVERY FIVE YEARS. I MEAN,
EVERYONE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA BENEFITS FROM UPDATED
MAPS THAT ARE ACCURATE AND HAVE
THE BEST DATA AND SCIENCE
UNDERPINNING THEM AT THAT MOMENT
IN TIME. AND THEN THE OTHER
REALLY IMPORTANT AMENDMENT FOR
US THAT KEEPS, AGAIN, KIND OF
THE SPIRIT OF THIS ALIVE IS
ACTUALLY THAT PRELIMINARY
DETERMINATION IS COMING OUT
BASED ON THE AMENDMENTS. AND
WHAT IS GOING IN. IS THIS WHAT'S
CALLED KIND OF WE'RE REFERRING
TO AS SORT OF A MEET AND CONFER
PROCESS, ANY ENTITY. SO WHETHER
IT'S A BUILDER OR DEVELOPER OR
WHETHER IT'S AN NGO OR AN
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUP OR A STATE
AGENCY OR WHOEVER IT IS CAN GO
TO THE STATE FIRE MARSHAL, WHO
IS OUR PRE, THE FOREMOST EXPERT
IN FIRE, HOW IT'S GOING TO
BEHAVE, HOW WE SHOULD BE
ADDRESSING IT. THEY ARE THE
EXPERTS. IT WILL ALLOW A MEET
AND CONFER PROCESS TO COME TO
THEM AND SAY, HEY, I'M THINKING
ABOUT DOING THIS SUITE OF
MITIGATION THINGS. HOW WILL THAT
IMPROVE MY PROJECT? HOW WILL
THAT IMPROVE MY LAND? THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT HAS LONG BEEN
MISSING. AND IF YOU PAID
ATTENTION TO THE LAST TWO AND A
HALF YEARS OF THE UPDATE OF THE
SRA MAPS, THAT PROCESS WAS
HUGELY BENEFICIAL, THAT OPEN
PUBLIC PROCESS. BUT IT'S ONLY
DURING THE UPDATE AND IT NEEDS
TO BE ABLE TO OCCUR AND WE'RE
GOING TO PAY FOR IT AS THE
CONFEREE. SO WE'RE TAKING CARE
OF THE COST. SO WE JUST WANT
INFORMATION. THAT'S WHAT THIS IS
REALLY ALL ABOUT. SO WOULD
STRONGLY ENCOURAGE YOUR AYE VOTE
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH, AT THIS
TIME WE'LL TAKE THE METOOS, IN
FAVOR OF THIS PROPOSAL. SO COME
TO THE MIC, STATE YOUR NAME,
ORGANIZATION, REPRESENT YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THE BILL. MR.
CHAIRMAN. MEMBERS MOIRA TOPP ON
BEHALF OF ORANGE COUNTY BUSINESS
COUNCIL AND SUPPORT. PAUL SHAFER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU, CLIFTON
WILSON, ON BEHALF OF THE KERN
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS, IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
AT THIS TIME, IT LOOKS LIKE
THERE'S NO MORE SUPPORT. SO WE
WILL TAKE ANY PEOPLE IN
OPPOSITION. IF YOU WANT TO BE
THE LEAD OPPOSITION PERSON, YOU
HAVE TWO MINUTES. GOOD
AFTERNOON, VICE CHAIR. MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE, ALEX WIENER,
ON BEHALF OF OUR FERGUSON FOREST
LEGACY, FIRST, LET ME THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR AN EXCELLENT
ANALYSIS ON THE ISSUES RAISED IN
THIS BILL, AND LET ME THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS, WHICH DO
ADDRESS SOME OF OUR CONCERNS.
HOWEVER, SIERRA FOREST LEGACY
MUST REMAIN IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL BECAUSE OF THE
AMENDMENTS NOT ADDRESSING ONE OF
OUR KEY ISSUES. THE SHIFT IN
CRITICAL RESPONSIBILITIES FROM
THE BOARD OF FORESTRY TO THE
STATE FIRE MARSHAL, FIRE MARSHAL
. CURRENTLY, THE BOARD IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR ADOPTING
DEFENSIBLE SPACE REGULATIONS AND
DEVELOPING RELATED GUIDANCE ON
FUELS MANAGEMENT FOR DEFENSIBLE
SPACE, ADOPTING MINIMUM FIRE
SAFETY STANDARDS AND DEVELOPING
CRITERIA FOR AND MAINTAINING
FIRE RISK REDUCTION. COMMUNITY
LISTS. AS THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS
POINTS OUT, THE AUTHOR AND
SPONSORS DO NOT PROVIDE MUCH
JUSTIFICATION FOR THIS SHIFT IN
AUTHORITY. THE SHIFT IN
RESPONSIBILITIES RAISES ISSUES
REGARDING ACCOUNTABILITY AND
TRANSPARENCY. THE BOARD HAS NINE
MEMBERS INSTEAD OF ONE. THE FIRE
MARSHAL THAT PROVIDES AND
THEREFORE PROVIDES A BETTER
CHECK AGAINST POLITICAL
INFLUENCE. THE BOARD MUST
DELIBERATE IN PUBLIC VIA PUBLIC
HEARINGS AND THE FIRE MARSHAL
DOES NOT. THE BOARD FOLLOWS A
MORE RIGOROUS AND OPEN PROCESS
FOR RECEIVING PUBLIC COMMENT.
THE BOARD HAS DEVELOPED
EXPERTISE OVER THE YEARS,
INCLUDING EXPERTISE IN
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT. THE FIRE
MARSHAL DOES NOT HAVE THIS
EXPERTISE. FINALLY THE SHIFT IN
RESPONSIBILITIES TO THE FIRE
MARSHAL ALSO RAISES CONCERNS
AROUND THE ORDERLY TRANSITION OF
WORK, PROBLEMS WITH ENSURING THE
FIRE MARSHAL HAS THE EXPERTISE
AND CAPACITY TO DO EVERYTHING.
BEING ASKED OF IT, AND ISSUES
AROUND HOW TO DEAL WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WHO ARE YEARS INTO
THE PROCESS OF THE BOARD
REVIEWING THEIR GENERAL PLANS.
SINCE NONE OF THESE ISSUES HAVE
BEEN ADDRESSED IN THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS. SIERRA FOREST LEGACY
REMAINS IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. IS
THERE ANYBODY ELSE IN OPPOSITION
TO BILL THAT WOULD LIKE TO JUST
COME AND ADD ON AS A ME TO, GOOD
AFTERNOON, SENATORS MATTHEW
BAKER, POLICY DIRECTOR FOR
PLANNING AND CONSERVATION
LEAGUE, ALSO APPRECIATE THE
AMENDMENTS AND THE ANALYSIS, BUT
UNFORTUNATELY, MAINTAINING OUR
OPPOSITION AND ALIGNMENT WITH
THE CONCERNS EXPRESSED BY SIERRA
FOREST LEGACY. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU SIR. NEXT GOOD
AFTERNOON. CHRISTINA SCARINGE
WITH THE CENTER FOR BIOLOGICAL
DIVERSITY. I'LL JUST ECHO THE
PRIOR COMMENTS. WE REMAIN IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. NATALIE
BROWN, ON BEHALF OF THE
ENDANGERED HABITATS LEAGUE, ALSO
REMAINING IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. ABIGAIL SMITH, ON BEHALF OF
MIDPENINSULA REGIONAL OPEN SPACE
DISTRICT, ECHOING THE SAME
COMMENTS, ALSO IN OPPOSITION,
THANK GOD. ALL RIGHT. IF THERE'S
NOBODY ELSE COMING TO THE MIC,
THEN WE WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE DAIS FOR DISCUSSION.
QUESTIONS AS THE AUTHOR, SENATOR
STERN. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR, AND
THANK YOU. I KNOW YOU'VE BEEN
WORKING ON THIS FOR MANY YEARS,
AND FIRE'S A BIG DEAL IN YOUR
BACKYARD, AS IS HOUSING, AND I
DO RESPECT THE PUSH FROM THE
BUILDING INDUSTRY TO WANT TO
BUILD MORE, I'VE HAD A LONG AND
TOUGH HISTORY, THOUGH, ON THESE
ISSUES WHERE, I THINK THERE MAY
JUST BE SOME FUNDAMENTAL
DISAGREEMENTS ABOUT WHERE WE
SHOULD BE BUILDING, AND WHAT I
WORRY ABOUT WITH THE MEASURE,
EVEN THOUGH IT'S, I THINK IT'S
MUCH IMPROVED. I MEAN, I WAS I
HAD SOME GRAVE CONCERNS WHEN IT
WAS COMING TO THE COMMITTEE,
BUT, YOU KNOW, THE BOARD OF
FORESTRY PROCESS, THE BUILDING
INDUSTRY TRIED TO COME TO THE
BOARD OF FORESTRY OVER THE LAST
TWO YEARS, AND BASICALLY GET IT
A BUNCH OF DEAD END STREETS ALL
IN THE FIRE ZONES AND BE ABLE TO
EXTEND THOSE AND TREAT FIRE
ROADS LIKE THEY WERE ANY OTHER
ROAD, AND EXPAND DEVELOPMENT
OPPORTUNITIES ON THOSE ROADS AT
THE BOARD OF FORESTRY. LUCKILY,
IT WAS A PUBLIC PROCESS AND
EVERYONE FOUND OUT ABOUT IT, AND
PEOPLE STARTED ASKING QUESTIONS
AND SAYING, HOW ARE YOU GOING TO
EVACUATE A SINGLE LANE ROAD DEEP
INTO A CANYON? IF YOU'RE GOING
TO GO BUILD 40 MCMANSIONS AT THE
END OF THAT DEAD END ROAD? AS I
KNOW THERE'S COVETED LAND ON THE
END OF THESE ROADS. AND IN THESE
FIRE ZONES, THIS IS VERY HIGH
VALUE LAND, AND THERE'S A LOT OF
DEVELOPMENTS STUCK IN THE
PROCESS THAT WOULD LOVE NOTHING
ELSE THAN TO STREAMLINE AND
EXPEDITE THAT. AND IN FACT,
THERE'S NEW LEGISLATION GUTTING
AMEND, SB 650 THAT JUST GOT
PUSHED OUT THERE TO COMPLETELY
UNDERCUT FIRE MAPPING IN GENERAL
AT THE BUILDING INDUSTRY IS ALSO
PUSHING, SO I IT'S NOT SO MUCH
IF YOUR BILL IF THIS IS JUST THE
BILL IN ISOLATION, I THINK I
WOULD BE OKAY WITH IT. IT'S THE
CONTEXT OF THIS THAT THAT CAUSES
ME STILL TO HAVE CONCERNS AND,
AND THE, THE OPPOSITION'S KEY
ARGUMENT THAT THE STATE FIRE
MARSHAL'S PROCESS ISN'T THERE'S
A MEET AND CONFER, WHICH IS SORT
OF INFORMAL, BUT THE BOARD OF
FORESTRY PROCESS WAS PUBLIC. SO
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS COULD FIND OUT
ABOUT IT. NEIGHBORHOOD COUNCILS
COULD FIND OUT. AND YOU DIDN'T
SORT OF HAVE TO FIGURE OUT WHO
HAD THE RIGHT LOBBYIST AND ALL
THE SORT OF BEHIND THE SCENES
STUFF. I THINK THIS WORK IS DONE
BEST IN THE PUBLIC EYE. AND SO,
I DON'T HAVE AN ISSUE WITH THE
FIRE MAPPING UPDATES. I'M JUST
WONDERING IF YOU CAN COMMENT AND
IF I GET THAT MAYBE THIS IS YOUR
FIRST SHOT AT THE MOVE IT FROM
BOARD TO THE STATE FIRE MARSHAL.
MEET AND CONFER. HAVE YOU
THOUGHT ANY FURTHER OR MAYBE
YOUR SPONSORS THOUGHT FURTHER
ABOUT WHAT MORE YOU CAN DO TO
SORT OF PROVIDE SOME
REASSURANCES ABOUT HOW PUBLIC
THAT WOULD BE? SO THAT WE DON'T
END UP IN THE SAME KIND OF
SITUATION WHERE IT JUST FEELS
LIKE, OKAY, BOARD OF FORESTRY
DIDN'T GIVE US THE ANSWER WE
WANTED ON THESE DEAD END ROADS.
WE'RE GOING TO END AROUND THEM,
GO TO THE FIRE MARSHAL AND JUST
BUILD THE DEVELOPMENTS THAT WE
WANTED ANYWAYS. LIKE I'M THAT
ANGSTY PERSON WHO'S, YOU KNOW,
HAD PEOPLE GET KILLED IN FIRE
ZONES DURING FIRES AND WE GOT
ONE GOING RIGHT NOW, SO I DON'T
KNOW, I'M EXTRA SENSITIVE MAYBE
ABOUT IT AND MAYBE I'M READING
TOO MUCH INTO IT, BUT MAYBE YOU
GUYS CAN JUST HELP EXPLAIN THAT.
WHAT MORE COULD WE DO BEYOND
THAT? MEET AND CONFER. IF IT IS
GOING TO BE STATE FIRE MARSHAL,
IS IT IN CONSULTATION WITH BOARD
OF FORESTRY? JUST CREATIVITY ON
THAT FRONT WOULD BE APPRECIATED.
SO I THINK I'LL LET THE SPONSOR
SPEAK AND THEN I'LL ADD SOME
COMMENTS AS WELL, IF THAT'S OKAY
WITH THE CHAIR. YEAH, I'D BE I'D
BE HAPPY TO RESPOND. THERE WAS
CERTAINLY A WHOLE LOT IN THAT,
SENATOR STERN, SO I'LL AT LEAST
BASED ON THE KIND OF ONE THING I
DO WANT TO COMMENT ON, SEE, BY
THE CALIFORNIA INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION DID NOT KNOW
ANYTHING ABOUT THE BILL THAT WAS
GOTTEN AMENDED, UNTIL LAST
THURSDAY, WHEN I THINK THE REST
EVERYONE ELSE DID. OKAY, I WANT
TO CLEAR THAT UP. SO, THAT'S
WHEN WE FOUND OUT, NUMBER TWO ON
THE MEET AND CONFER, WE BELIEVE
THAT IF YOU HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO GO TO THESE STATES FOREMOST
AUTHORITY AND SAY, WE HAVE A
PROJECT OR OR THERE'S A
MULTIFAMILY HOUSING PROJECT OR
THERE'S AN HOA, AND WE ARE
THINKING ABOUT DOING THESE
THINGS TO BETTER PROTECT ONE OUR
DEVELOPMENT TO OUR COMMUNITY AT
LARGE WILL THESE THINGS MATTER?
WILL THESE THINGS MAKE A
DIFFERENCE? AND IF THEY WILL,
THEN THAT INCENTIVIZES GOOD
ACTION. IT INCENTIVIZES PEOPLE
MAKING THE RIGHT CALL TO MOVE
FORWARD. SO WE DON'T HAVE THAT
RIGHT NOW. I MEAN, RIGHT NOW WE
ARE GUESSING RIGHT NOW WE HAVE A
HISTORY OF DEFENSIBLE SPACE OR
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT. THOSE
THINGS IN CERTAIN AREAS ON
CERTAIN DAYS WHEN THE WIND IS IN
THE RIGHT LIGHT, THAT'S WHAT WE
HAVE NOW. THE STATE FIRE MARSHAL
DOES THIS FOR A LIVING. THEY ARE
THE EXPERT, AND I KNOW THAT
THERE IS A, SOME CONCERN ABOUT
BOARD OF FORESTRY AND STATE FIRE
MARSHAL. WELL, NO ONE IN BETWEEN
BOTH THOSE AGENCIES. NO ONE HAS
THE, CONCERN AND THE
FIREFIGHTERS MORE IN THEIR MIND
THAN THE STATE FIRE MARSHAL,
THAT IS, THEIR PEOPLE AND WE
BELIEVE NO MATTER WHAT THEY ARE
GOING TO DO, THEY'RE GOING TO
PUT THAT GROUP OF PEOPLE AS
PRIORITY. HOW DO WE GET IN? HOW
DO WE CARE FOR THESE FOLKS? HOW
DO WE MAKE SURE THEY ARE IN AND
OUT SAFELY? THAT IS THEIR NUMBER
ONE MISSION. AND THE REASON FOR
THE SHIFTING? THERE IS A HECK OF
A LOT OF REDUNDANCY AT BOTH
THESE AGENCIES AND WHETHER IT'S
INGRESS, EGRESS, EVACUATION, IF
YOU GO DOWN THE LIST OF THINGS
THAT THEY ARE BOTH REQUIRED TO
DO, THEY ARE DOING REDUNDANCY
AND IT IS HAPPENING AND IT DOES
CREATE PROBLEMS. SO WE ARE
TRYING TO CLEAN IT UP. I WE HAVE
GONE THROUGH MULTIPLE COMMITTEES
NOW AND NO ONE HAS BEEN ABLE TO
CATCH. THERE'S BEEN NO GOTCHA
LIKE YOU'RE TRYING TO GET OUT OF
SOMETHING. EVERYONE UNDERSTANDS.
WE ARE NOT TRYING TO REMOVE A
SINGLE REGULATION. THERE IS NO
CHANGE TO SEQUA. THERE IS NO
CHANGE TO A BUILDING STANDARDS.
THERE IS NO CHANGE TO CHAPTER
49. THERE IS NO CHANGE TO
CHAPTER SEVEN A NOTHING'S
CHANGING. IT'S GOING FROM ONE
PLACE TO ANOTHER TO ELIMINATE
REDUNDANCY AND HOPEFULLY GET
PROJECTS BETTER PROTECTED.
THAT'S WHAT THIS IS ABOUT.
UNDERSTOOD. I MEAN, IF THIS BILL
PASSED IN ISOLATION, IF IT
PASSED ALONG WITH SB 650, THEN
ALL THAT WOULD BE GONE. THEN
YOU'D HAVE A STREAMLINED PROCESS
THAT FIRE MARSHAL AND EVERYTHING
WOULD FLY THROUGH AND YOU
WOULDN'T HAVE TO CONSIDER THOSE
KINDS OF ISSUES. SO I THINK,
AGAIN, CONTEXT IS EVERYTHING I
GET THAT IT'S NOT YOUR BILL, BUT
IF WE'RE GOING TO BE
STREAMLINING THE PROCESS AND
PUSHING FOR MORE DEVELOPMENT,
WHICH IS I MEAN, YOU SAY CLEAN
UP, THERE'S A LOT OF REASONS,
INCLUDING AN INSURANCE CRISIS,
THAT WE SHOULDN'T BE WANTING TO
DO MORE DEVELOPMENT IN THESE
AREAS, PERIOD. I GET THAT SOME
FOLKS HAVE DEVELOPMENTS THEY
WANT TO PURSUE, BUT, BUT I THINK
THAT'S THAT'S WHY THERE ARE ALL
THESE STAGE GATES AND YOU MIGHT
CALL THEM REDUNDANCIES. I WOULD
CALL REDUNDANCIES A GOOD THING
WHEN IT COMES TO THINGS THAT ARE
A MATTER OF LIFE AND PROPERTY.
SO ANYWAY, I, I'M, I DIDN'T HEAR
FROM YOU THOUGH IN TERMS OF
STATE FIRE MARSHAL PROCESS AND
JUST THOUGHTS ABOUT MAKING THAT
MORE PUBLIC, SUBJECTING IT, SAY,
TO THE APA, OTHER THINGS THAT
CAN SORT OF REASSURE FOLKS WHO
MIGHT HAVE THE SAME ANXIETIES
THAT I DO, THAT IT'S NOT GOING
TO BE LIKE THE BOARD OF
FORESTRY. THAT'S NOT THERE'S NO
PUBLIC APPOINTMENTS. YEAH. I
MEAN, THE PART THAT WAS COMING
OUT, THE PRELIMINARY
DETERMINATION THAT WOULD HAVE, I
THINK, HAD A LITTLE BIT MORE OF
THAT THE MEET AND CONFER. SO IT
DOES ALLOW FOR THE STATE FIRE
MARSHAL TO PROVIDE A RESPONSE. I
MEAN, IF THAT WAS THE KIND OF
THING THAT WE WANTED TO POST AND
MAKE PUBLICLY AVAILABLE, LIKE
THAT'S ALWAYS SOMETHING, YOU
KNOW, UP FOR, FOR DISCUSSION. I
MEAN, WE DID THE BEST WE COULD
TO NEGOTIATE THE BEST PRODUCT WE
COULD. YEAH. SENATOR DOLLY. DID
YOU WANT TO RESPOND TO THE
SENATOR BEFORE I GO? NO. GO
AHEAD. SO I JUST WANT TO WEIGH
IN A LITTLE BIT HERE, TOO. I
THINK THAT, I'M GOING TO SUPPORT
YOUR BILL, BUT I WANT TO JUST.
WHO? SOMEBODY WHO'S BEEN IN
FRONT OF THE BOARD OF FORESTRY A
LOT OF TIMES AND DONE A LOT OF
LEGISLATION IN THAT SPACE TO AND
ALSO VERY FRUSTRATED AT THE SAME
TIME WITH THE MAPPING THAT WE
HAVE AVAILABLE TO US TO DO
INSURANCE QUOTES IS LIKE, I
TRIED TO DO SOME WORK IN THAT
SPACE WHICH DIDN'T GET OFF THE
GROUND ANYWAY. WE DON'T HAVE
ANYBODY TO HOLD ACCOUNTABLE OR
TO ACTUALLY GET ADVICE FROM WHEN
WE ARE TRYING TO DO THE RIGHT
THING BY FIRE RISING OUR
COMMUNITIES, DOING THE RIGHT
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT, HOME
HARDENING. THERE'S NOBODY THAT
GIVES YOU A CERTIFICATE THAT
SAYS, HEY, YOU DID ALL THESE
THINGS AND YOU ACTUALLY DRIVE
YOUR RATE DOWN. I'M HOPING THAT
THE MAPPING PART OF THIS WILL
START THAT CONVERSATION SO WE
CAN THEN AND IT'S REGULATED
EVERY FIVE YEARS SO WE CAN COME
IN THERE AND SAY, HEY, LOOK. AND
THERE ARE PLACES WE SHOULDN'T
BUILD. ABSOLUTELY. AND I LIKE TO
HAVE THOSE CONVERSATIONS BECAUSE
A LOT OF PEOPLE DON'T THINK WE
SHOULD BUILD. IN MY DISTRICT,
WHERE WE HAVE FORESTED AREAS, I
THINK WE SHOULD MAYBE NOT BUILD
ON THE COAST WHERE WE HAVE
FLOODS AND LANDSLIDES. THAT'S
FOR A DIFFERENT CONVERSATION
THEN, OBVIOUSLY WE'RE ALL TRYING
TO PROTECT OUR OWN COMMUNITIES,
BUT I THINK THIS IS A GOOD START
TO, HAVE THE CONVERSATION ABOUT
WHAT IS IT GOING TO LOOK LIKE
WHERE WE GO OUT THERE TO DO
THESE PROJECTS OR NOT DO THOSE
PROJECTS FOR, QUITE FRANKLY,
THAT'S ANOTHER GOOD OPPORTUNITY
DURING THIS PROCESS. SO I'LL BE
SUPPORTING YOUR BILL. I'M
HOPEFUL THAT MAYBE WE CAN LOOK
AT THESE MAPS AND THEN START
HAVING A DISCUSSION ABOUT TRYING
TO DRIVE DOWN INSURANCE RATES,
WHICH IS REALLY DIFFICULT IN
CALIFORNIA RIGHT NOW. SENATOR
LAIRD, THANK YOU. AND I JUST
DISCOVERED THAT THIS WEEKEND
THAT SOMEBODY THAT WENT TO HIGH
SCHOOL WITH SENATOR DOLLY'S IN
CHARGE OF THE FLOODS AND
MUDSLIDES ON THE COAST. SO I CAN
HARDLY WAIT TO WE'RE TRYING TO
PLAN THEM DOWN THERE. YOUR OF
YOUR COMMENTS, I HAVE A UNIQUE
THING. I HAVE A QUESTION OF ONE
OF OUR COLLEAGUES, AND THAT IS
TO SENATOR STERN, YOU JUST
DISCUSSED SB 650 AND A GUT AND
AMEND AS IF WE ALL KNOW WHAT IT
IS. I DON'T KNOW WHAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT, AND YOU ARE
IMPLYING THAT IT RELATES TO THIS
DISCUSSION IN THIS BILL. COULD
YOU TELL US WHAT THAT BILL IS
AND WHY YOU'RE INFERRING THAT?
YOU JUST TELL US SUMMARY LIKE
WHAT IT DOES. HOW DOES IT FIT?
YEAH. OKAY 610. THAT'S WHY WE
COULDN'T FIND IT. YEAH. MY BAD
SB 610, IT'S SB 610, BUT IT
WOULD, ELIMINATE THE VERY HIGH
FIRE SEVERITY ZONE AREAS FROM
OUR MAPPING PROCESS, AND
ESSENTIALLY ELIMINATE THE STATE
FIRE MARSHAL'S AUTHORITY OVER,
THAT IDENTIFICATION PROCESS. AND
THEREFORE, IF THAT BILL WERE
PASSED, IT WOULD HAVE AN IMPACT
ON THIS BILL. THEN THERE WOULD
BE NO FIVE YEAR MAPPING PROCESS
BECAUSE THE STATE FIRE MARSHAL
WOULD NO LONGER BE DOING THAT
MAPPING IN THE FIRST PLACE. SO
THERE'S SOME SOME
RECONCILIATION. IF HE DOES NO
MAPPING UNLESS IT'S HIGH FIRE
ZONE, HIGH AND VERY HIGH,
ACTUALLY MODERATE AS WELL. I
THINK IT'S MODERATE HIGH AND
VERY HIGH. YEAH. I'M SORRY.
WE'RE WE'RE JUST WAITING INTO
WHAT? WE DON'T KNOW IF I MIGHT
JUST. BUT I WANTED TO. I MIGHT
TAKE THE CHAIR'S PREROGATIVE.
NOW THAT I'M BACK, MAYBE WE CAN
REVIEW THAT BILL WHEN IT COMES
BEFORE US. SINCE WE DON'T
ACTUALLY KNOW THE CONTENTS. AND
IT'S GOT A. WELL, NO, THAT WOULD
MAKE TOTAL SENSE. EXCEPT WE'RE
VOTING ON THIS BILL TODAY, AND
IT MIGHT INFLUENCE THAT. AND
THEN IF WE DISCOVERED THAT, IT
WOULD HAVE INFLUENCED THAT, WE
WERE VERY CAREFULLY WOULD HAVE
PASSED IT AND BEEN GONE. I'M
TOLD THAT THE CONTENTS OF THE
BILL OF 610 ARE STILL BEING
DISCUSSED, BUT THAT SOME OF THE
DESCRIPTIONS WERE NOT ACCURATE.
THE BILL IS IN PRINT RIGHT NOW.
OKAY. YOU GUYS CAN ALL LOOK IT
UP. THANK YOU, THANK YOU, THANK
YOU. ANY OTHER. SORRY, SENATOR
VICE CHAIR SEYARTO. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, SO I DO
HAVE A LITTLE BIT OF EXPERIENCE
IN THIS AREA, IN MY DISTRICT,
AND, I THINK ONE OF THE PROBLEMS
IS THAT THESE THE DIFFERENCE IN
FIRE ZONES REQUIRES DIFFERENT
BUILDING MATERIALS BE USED. AND
IN SOME CASES, THE AREA THAT WAS
PREVIOUSLY MAPPED AS A HIGH FIRE
HAZARD AREA, IS ACTUALLY THE
AREA THAT GETS LEVELED AND BUILT
UPON. AND SO THE HIGH FIRE
HAZARD PART IS GONE AND THEY
NEED TO REMAP SO THEY CAN
ACTUALLY GET INSURANCE AND, AND,
AND THERE IS A CERTAIN AMOUNT OF
, OF DEFENSIBLE SPACE THAT IS
BUILT AROUND THESE. BUT IF YOU
DON'T HAVE A WAY OF, OF RE
DETERMINING THAT MAP IN A,
EXPEDIENT, A MORE EXPEDIENT WAY,
IT IS GOING TO IT IS GOING TO
WIND UP COSTING BUILD DÍAS PER
HOUSE, 40, 60, $100,000 MORE PER
HOUSE TO PUT IN ALL THESE
MITIGATION MEASURES THAT ARE
ACTUALLY AREN'T NEEDED BECAUSE
THE TERRAIN HAS BEEN CHANGED. SO
THE MAPS DO NEED TO GET CHANGED.
THERE NEEDS TO BE A FLUID WAY OF
DOING THAT. AND THE STATE FIRE
MARSHAL, WHO IS ACTUALLY THERE,
AN EXPERT, I WENT OUT TO ONE OF
THESE THESE, SUBDIVISIONS AND
WAS ABLE. I'M JUST LOOKING AT IT
AND BASED ON THE TYPE OF BRUSH,
THE TYPE OF BRUSH THAT GROWS
THERE, THE PREVAILING WINDS, THE
TERRAIN AND ALL OF THAT, IT DID
NOT MATCH WHAT THE MAP WAS
SAYING. AND NOW THESE PEOPLE
WERE BEING REQUIRED TO RETROFIT
$50,000 EACH HOUSE WORTH OF
STUFF. AND SO IN THIS, IN THIS
WORLD WHERE WE'RE TRYING TO
TRYING TO BUILD MORE HOUSES THAT
PEOPLE CAN ACTUALLY AFFORD THIS
TYPE OF STUFF AND THE INABILITY
TO GO AHEAD AND ADDRESS A MAP
WHERE THE CIRCUMSTANCES HAVE
CHANGED. THAT'S WHAT IS DRIVING
SOME OF THOSE COSTS. AND I THINK
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL WILL
ENABLE US TO DO A LITTLE BIT
BETTER IS TO HAVE A PERSON THAT
IS AN EXPERT IN FIRE, IN FIRE
BURNING, AND HOW WE ATTACK FIRES
TO DO THAT AND BE ABLE TO MOVE
THESE PROJECTS THAT ARE ALREADY
APPROVED, THAT ARE IN AREAS THAT
HAVE ALTERED THE LANDSCAPE AND
GET THOSE DONE SO PEOPLE CAN BUY
THEIR HOMES AND MOVE INTO THEM.
AND SO I'M GOING TO BE
SUPPORTING YOUR BILL TODAY
BECAUSE I THINK IT TAKES SOME
STEPS GOING TO IT DOESN'T MEAN I
DON'T HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT THE
ABILITY OF THEM TO PROCESS THIS,
BUT I WOULD IMAGINE THAT'S UP TO
THEM TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
BRING THEIR ORGANIZATIONS UP TO
THE SPEED SO THAT THEY CAN GET
THESE THINGS DONE. AND SO, I'LL
BE SUPPORTING THE BILL AND WITH
THAT, I'M GOING TO MAKE A MOTION
TO APPROVE THE BILL. ALL RIGHT,
SENATOR GROVE, THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR. I'M THE VICE CHAIR OF
RULES, AND WE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CONFIRM, FIRE
MARSHAL BERLANT JUST A COUPLE OF
WEEKS AGO. AND THE EXTENSIVE
QUESTIONS THAT WE WERE ABLE TO
ASK AS MEMBERS OF THE RULES
COMMITTEE. I MEAN, HIS NUMBER
ONE PRIORITY IS THE SAFETY AND
PROTECTION OF CITIZENS AND THEIR
PROPERTY. AND HIS FIREFIGHTERS.
RIGHT. THOSE ARE HIS TOP THREE.
AND I THINK THEY'RE EQUAL ACROSS
THE BOARD. HE'S NOT GOING TO
BASED ON WHAT I GATHERED FROM
HIM AND HE'S A GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTEE. BUT THIS INDIVIDUAL
IS VERY WELL QUALIFIED. HE IS
THE FOREMOST AUTHORITY. WHEN YOU
LOOK AT FIRE PREVENTION AREAS.
WE HAD A LENGTHY DISCUSSION
ABOUT A DISCUSSION ABOUT THE
MAPS AND WHAT HOW HE WAS WORKING
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE
TO USE HOME HARDENING, FIRE
MITIGATION STUFF, VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT IN ORDER TO REDUCE
THE COST FOR, INSURANCE, WHICH
IS ALMOST, UNSUSTAINABLE OR YOU
CAN'T EVEN ACHIEVE GETTING
INSURANCE IN SOME OF OUR RURAL
COMMUNITIES, LIKE MY COLLEAGUE
FROM BIEBER SAID, YOU KNOW, WE
HAVE TO BE ABLE TO SOMEBODY
NEEDS TO HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO
GO, YES, YOU'VE DONE THIS. SO
THEREFORE YOUR HOUSE HAS LESS
MITIGATION OR LESS, LESS ABILITY
TO CATCH ON FIRE BECAUSE YOU'VE
GOT IT SURROUNDED WITH THE
MITIGATION STANDARDS THAT, YOU
KNOW, ARE SUGGESTED BY THE STATE
FIRE MARSHAL AND THE INSURANCE
COMPANIES, TO ADDRESS THESE MAPS
EVERY FIVE YEARS AND HAVE
UPDATED MAPS AND INFORMATION IS
VITALLY IMPORTANT, WHICH I LOVE
ABOUT THE BILL. AND LIKE I SAID,
I JUST THINK THAT THE FOREMOST
AUTHORITY WOULD BE THE STATE
FIRE MARSHAL. I THINK I'VE BEEN
ON RULES FOR, 3 OR 4 YEARS NOW.
THREE YEARS NOW. AND, THIS IS
OUR THIRD, I BELIEVE, SECOND OR
THIRD STATE FIRE MARSHAL. ALL OF
THEM HAVE THE MOST UTMOST
RESPECT FOR THE INDIVIDUAL'S
LIFE OFF THEIR PROPERTY AND
THEIR EMPLOYEES THAT NAVIGATE
THESE FIRES WHEN THEY TAKE
PLACE. THERE'S NO WAY THE STATE
FIRE MARSHAL OR ANY STATE FIRE
MARSHAL WOULD EVER JEOPARDIZE
THEIR EMPLOYEES GOING IN AND OUT
OF IN DEAD END ROADS THAT YOU
HAVE NO ACCESS TO. BECAUSE IF
YOU'VE NEVER FOLLOWED OR WATCHED
A VIEW OF A GOPRO ON
FIREFIGHTERS THAT ARE GOING IN
THESE FIRE PRONE AREAS LIKE MY
AREA, WHEN WE HAD THE CREEK FIRE
UP IN THE MOUNTAINS, IT'S LIKE A
TUNNEL OF FLAMES, AND THERE'S NO
WAY THAT HE WOULD DO ANYTHING,
OR ANY FIRE MARSHAL WOULD EVER
DO ANYTHING TO PUT ANY OF THOSE
PEOPLE IN JEOPARDY. AND, SO I AM
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY AND
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING IT FORTH,
BECAUSE WE DO HAVE A PROBLEM IN
MAKING SURE THAT THESE MAPS ARE
WHERE THEY NEED TO BE, WHEN THEY
NEED TO BE. AND THE PEOPLE OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA ARE
ENTITLED TO UPDATED INFORMATION.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. SENATOR
GROVE, I APPRECIATE THE ROBUST
DISCUSSION ON TODAY'S BILL,
WHICH I JUST CAUGHT PART OF. AND
YOUR BILL CLEARLY RAISES A LOT
OF QUESTIONS AND DEBATE, CLEARLY
ALSO TRYING TO ADDRESS AN
IMPORTANT ISSUE, FINDING THE
RIGHT BALANCE BETWEEN BUILDING
HOUSING, WHICH I THINK IS FAIR
TO SAY WE'RE IN A CRISIS ON
HOUSING AND HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY IN THE STATE.
WHILE ADDRESSING REAL CONCERNS
ABOUT WILDFIRE RISK. I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR WORKING WITH MY
STAFF TO ADDRESS CONCERNS THAT
WE HAD ABOUT THE PRELIMINARY
DETERMINATION AND PETITION
PROCESSES, AND FOR ACCEPTING AN
ALTERNATIVE PROCESS TO
INCENTIVIZE NEIGHBORHOODS AND
COMMUNITIES TO TAKE ACTION TO
REDUCE WILDFIRE RISK ON THEIR
DEVELOPMENTS. I'VE BEEN TALKING
WITH STAFF. JUST WANTED TO
CLARIFY THAT UNDER SB 610 AND
YOUR BILL WAS SUCH A POSITIVE
DEVELOPMENT THAT APPARENTLY ONE
OF OUR COLLEAGUES IN THE
ADMINISTRATION FELT THE NEED TO
ADOPT A SIMILAR APPROACH. BUT
UNDER 610, THE STATE FIRE
MARSHAL WOULD ADOPT WILDFIRE
MITIGATION AREA MAPS TO REPLACE
FIRE HAZARD SEVERITY ZONE MAPS.
THE INTENT OF THE TWO APPROACHES
ARE VERY, VERY SIMILAR, AND
PLACING THAT AUTHORITY WITH THE
STATE FIRE MARSHAL, BUT I WILL
JUST SAY THIS. WE DON'T KNOW YET
WHAT THE OUTCOME OF THAT BILL IS
GOING TO BE. WE HAVE NOT HAD A
CHANCE TO ANALYZE THE PROS AND
CONS IN THIS COMMITTEE. WE HAVE
VETTED YOUR BILL. AND SO WITH
THAT, THAT WE ARE GOING TO
RECOMMEND AN AYE VOTE, AND SO WE
DO HAVE A MOTION ON THIS BILL
YET. YES I DO I'M SORRY, A
MOTION FROM SENATOR SUGIARTO AND
THE MOTION IS Dð PASS AS
AMENDED. THE GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATIONS. WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE? I WOULD, BUT AGAIN,
FORGIVE ME, BUT I DON'T KNOW
THAT THE OPPOSITION GOT TO SPEAK
. DID THEY DID THEY GET TO COME
UP? OKAY NOT THAT I'M WANTING TO
WORK AGAINST MY BILL, BUT I JUST
WANTED TO MAKE. OKAY. ALL RIGHT.
I GOT A LITTLE DISTRACTED
BECAUSE THERE WERE SO MANY
THINGS GOING ON HERE. BUT I
REALLY APPRECIATE COMING TO THE
SENATE BECAUSE THIS IS WHAT YOU
GUYS DO. WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
CRITICAL ISSUES IN CALIFORNIA,
ALL WITHIN THIS BILL, HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY, OUR INSURANCE
ISSUES OF COURSE, SAVING LIVES
AND FIRE HAZARDS. SO ALL IN THIS
BILL. BUT I DO DEFINITELY TAKE,
SINCERELY, ARE SOME SENATORS
CONCERNS. I DEFINITELY, IT'S
KIND OF A CROSSROADS WHEN YOU
BRING A PHÐ A BILL FORWARD,
BECAUSE THERE ARE PEOPLE LINING
UP ON BOTH SIDES, SOME THAT
WOULD NEVER ACCEPT ANY MAP, AND
NO GROWTH. AND THAT IS PART OF
THE BIG DIALOG, WHICH IS FROM
THE ENVIRONMENTAL LISTS TO
PEOPLE WHO WANT TO SEE
CALIFORNIANS HOUSED. AND
SOMETIMES THERE'S NEVER A BRIDGE
THERE, BUT WITH THIS BILL, IT'S
SIMPLY IN ITS SIMPLEST FORM, A
WAY TO UPDATE MAPS EVERY FIVE
YEARS AND SEVERE FIRE, HAZARD
AREAS TAKING IN CONSIDERATION
THÀNH SOME OF THE THINGS THAT WE
HAVE LEARNED OVER THE YEARS,
WHICH IS HOME HARDENING,
DEFENSIBLE SPACE, VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT AND FUEL REDUCTION
EFFORTS. AND I THINK AS WE PUT
THAT TOGETHER, THERE IS A SPACE
FOR THIS TYPE OF BILL. AND
TAKING IT TO ONE ENTITY. BUT I
HEAR THE IDEA OF THE BOARD OF
FORESTRY VERSUS THE FIRE
MARSHAL. I THINK THE FIRE
MARSHAL DOES COME WITH EXPERTISE
AND CREDENTIALS AND WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION AS WE MOVE FORWARD.
SO I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLYWOMAN, WE HAVE A MOTION.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS, AS
AMENDED, TO GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATIONS FROM SENATOR SATO,
ASSISTANT, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR MINH. I MEAN, I SAY I
SAY AYE, ALAN DALLI. DALLI I
EGGMAN. EGGMAN. AYE. GROVE.
GROVE AYE. HURTADO. LAIRD.
LAIRD. AYE LIMÓN. PADILLA.
PADILLA. AYE. STERN. SEVEN.
SEVEN. THE VOTE IS SEVEN ZERO.
WE'LL LEAVE THAT ON CALL. THANK
YOU. MEMBERS. ALL RIGHT, OUR
NEXT BILL IS, FILE ITEM NUMBER
FIVE, AB 2103 BY ASSEMBLYWOMAN
PELLERIN, YOU CAN PRESENT
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
SO THANK YOU, CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
I ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE'S
AMENDMENTS, WHICH ADD PUBLIC
HEARING PROVISIONS FOR THE
BILL'S LAND ACQUISITION PROCESS.
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF STATE
PARKS AND THE COMMITTEE TO
FURTHER REVIEW THIS PROVISION.
FOLLOWING THE DEVASTATING 2020
CCU LIGHTNING COMPLEX WILDFIRE
IN MY DISTRICT, WHICH BURNED
ACROSS THE ENTIRETY OF BIG BASIN
REDWOODS STATE PARK AND PORTIONS
OF SURROUNDING PARKS, THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PARKS
AND RECREATION INITIATED A
PLANNING PROCESS TO REIMAGINE
BIG BASIN REDWOODS CONSERVATION.
NONPROFITS THAT PARTNER WITH
STATE PARKS OFTEN PURCHASE
PROPERTIES WITH THE INTENTION
AND SHARED GOAL WITH STATE PARKS
TO ULTIMATELY TRANSFER OWNERSHIP
OF LAND PARCELS TO THE
DEPARTMENT FOR LONG TERM
PROTECTION. THE CURRENT PROCESS
OF LAND ACQUISITION, WHICH
REQUIRES APPROVAL OF THE PUBLIC
WORKS BOARD AND DEPARTMENT OF
GENERAL SERVICES, IS OFTEN
DELAYED WHEN CONSERVATION
ORGANIZATIONS END UP HAVING TO
WAIT MANY MONTHS OR YEARS TO
TRANSFER PROPERTY TO THE
DEPARTMENT, IT CREATES
UNCERTAINTY FOR CONSERVATION
PARTNER ENTITIES REGARDING
WHETHER THE LAND THEY PURCHASED
WILL BE BOUGHT OR ACCEPTED BY
THE DEPARTMENT IN A TIMELY
MANNER. THIS UNCERTAINTY AND
UNTIMELINESS WILL OFTEN LEAVE
ORGANIZATIONS IN A VULNERABLE
POSITION, AS THEY MUST CONTINUE
TO OWN AND MANAGE HIGH
CONSERVATION VALUE LANDS FOR
LONG PERIODS OF TIME. AB 2103
WILL HELP PROVIDE CERTAINTY TO
ACQUISITION PARTNERS BY ADDING
PROPERTY ACQUIRED FOR BIG BASIN
REDWOODS, ANO NUEVO AND BUTANO
STATE PARKS TO THE LIST OF
EXEMPTIONS FROM THE PUBLIC WORKS
BOARD. PROCESS THIS BY SPEEDING
UP THE LAND ACQUISITION PROCESS.
THIS BILL WILL SERVE AS A MODEL
FOR PERMANENTLY PROTECTING LANDS
FOR CONSERVATION, CULTURAL AND
RECREATION PURPOSES, AS WELL AS
HELPING US MEET OUR CLIMATE
GOALS WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT IS RACHEL DAN,
REPRESENTING THE SEMPERVIRENS
FUND. THANK YOU FOR JUST ONE
WITNESS. ASSEMBLYWOMAN, I HAVE I
HAVE ONE AMAZING, ONE AMAZING
WITNESS AS UP TO FOUR MINUTES TO
SPEAK. THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND
GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. MY NAME IS RACHEL DAN.
I'M THE DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS AT SEMPERVIRENS FUND.
SEMPERVIRENS FUND IS
CALIFORNIA'S FIRST AND OLDEST
LAND TRUST AND THE PROUD SPONSOR
OF THIS BILL. FOR OVER 100
YEARS, WE HAVE BEEN A COMMITTED
PARTNER WITH STATE PARKS TO
PROTECT AND CONNECT THE REDWOOD
FORESTS OF THE SANTA CRUZ
MOUNTAINS. AS YOU ALL MAY KNOW,
IN 2020, THE CCU LIGHTNING
COMPLEX FIRE BURNED OVER THE
ENTIRETY OF BIG BASIN REDWOODS
STATE PARK, AS WELL AS PORTIONS
OF BUTANO EN NUEVO STATE PARKS
AS WELL. IN THE WAKE OF THIS
CATASTROPHIC FIRE, STATE PARKS
INITIATED A PLANNING PROCESS TO
REIMAGINE THE FUTURE OF BIG
BASIN. THE RESULTING VISION
DESCRIBES THE NEED TO ACQUIRE
ADDITIONAL LAND TO SUPPORT THE
RELOCATION OF VISITOR SERVING
FACILITIES PREVIOUSLY LOCATED
WITHIN SOME OF THE MOST
ECOLOGICALLY SENSITIVE AREAS OF
THE PARK, AS WELL AS THE NEED TO
STRENGTHEN LANDSCAPE
CONNECTIVITY, IMPROVE FOREST
HEALTH, AND ENHANCE CLIMATE
RESILIENCY WITHIN BIG BASIN,
BUTANO AND ANA NUEVO ALL OF
WHICH WILL REQUIRE NEW LAND
ACQUISITIONS TO ACHIEVE. TO HELP
FULFILL THE REIMAGINING OF BIG
BASIN, THE DEPARTMENT PARTNERED
WITH CONSERVATION ORGANIZATIONS
IN THE SANTA CRUZ MOUNTAINS
REGION, INCLUDING SEMPERVIRENS
FUND, TO DEVELOP A TOOL FOR
IDENTIFYING LAND PARCELS
ADJACENT TO, WITHIN OR NEAR THE
CURRENT BOUNDARIES, THAT ARE
ESSENTIAL TO REALIZING THE
DEPARTMENT'S VISION.
CONSERVATION ORGANIZATIONS LIKE
OURS ARE KEY PARTNERS IN
ACQUIRING THESE LANDS. WE OFTEN
NEED TO MOVE QUICKLY TO PURCHASE
AND PROTECT PARCELS, WHICH WE
THEN TRANSFER TO THE DEPARTMENT.
UNFORTUNATELY, THE CURRENT
CURRENT PROCESS FOR TRANSFERRING
LAND TO STATE PARKS IS DRAWN OUT
AND CAN TAKE YEARS. IN THE
MEANTIME, PARTNERS LIKE US ARE
LIMITED IN OUR ABILITY TO MANAGE
ADDITIONAL Kò PARCELS. AB AB
2103 WILL PILOT A STREAMLINED
PROCESS FOR TRANSFERRING LANDS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE REBUILDING
OF BIG BASIN AND SURROUNDING
PARKS TO THE DEPARTMENT BY
ALLOWING THE DEPARTMENT TO
ACQUIRE PROPERTY ON ITS OWN
BEHALF, MUCH LIKE THE WILDLIFE
CONSERVATION BOARD, DEPARTMENT
OF FISH AND WILDLIFE AND A
NUMBER OF OTHER KEY AGENCIES
ALREADY DO. AB 2103 IS A CRUCIAL
STEP IN REBUILDING THE PARKS
THAT HAVE BEEN DECIMATED BY
CATASTROPHIC CLIMATE EVENTS IN
RECENT YEARS, AND FULFILLING THE
VISION OF A CONNECTED CLIMATE
RESILIENT AND ACCESSIBLE STATE
PARK SYSTEM IN THE SANTA CRUZ
MOUNTAINS. WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS
MEASURE TODAY. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SO MUCH, DO WE HAVE ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL? ME TWO TESTIMONY. GO
AHEAD. HELLO. ABIGAIL SCHMIDT,
ON BEHALF OF SAVE THE REDWOODS
LEAGUE, THE CALIFORNIA STATE
PARKS FOUNDATION AND
MIDPENINSULA REGIONAL OPEN SPACE
DISTRICT. ALL IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. JOSH, ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY OF SANTA CRUZ IN SUPPORT,
THANK YOU. OKAY. DO WE HAVE ANY
SEEING NO OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT? DO WE HAVE ANY LEAD
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION? ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION? OKAY.
WE'LL BRING THE DISCUSSION BACK
TO THE MEMBERS. SENATOR LAIRD,
THANK YOU, EVEN THOUGH WE WERE
TALKING AND, YOU KNOW, SINCE,
THIS LAST SATURDAY NIGHT, I WAS
AT OUR ANNUAL FARM BUREAU
DINNER, AND IT WAS UP RIGHT BY
THIS FIRE IN A LITTLE DRAWER
THAT WAS THE ONLY PLACE THAT
DIDN'T BURN. WE WERE IN THIS
BEAUTIFUL MEADOW WITH, BURNT
REDWOOD TREES ALL AROUND US. AND
AND THAT IS THE AREA THAT WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT. BUT WHAT WE'RE
REALLY TALKING ABOUT HERE IS A
PROCESS THAT IS BROKEN. AND THE
PUBLIC WORKS BOARD PROCESS
REQUIRES THAT IF WE HAVE NATURAL
RESOURCES AS LANDS TO ACQUIRE,
WE DELEGATE IT TO CALTRANS, THE
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES,
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
WHEN I WAS IN THE ASSEMBLY, I
DID A BILL THAT SAID, WOULD YOU
PLEASE, ADMINISTRATION PROPOSE
AN ALTERNATIVE WAY OF
STRUCTURING THE PUBLIC WORKS
BOARD? AND THEY DID IT. THEY
GAVE ME THREE OPTIONS. THEY SAID
THEY COULD LIVE WITH. I AMENDED
ONE INTO A BILL, AND THEN THEY
DIDN'T LIKE IT. THEIR
ADMINISTRATION HAD SUGGESTED IT.
IT TOOK US UNTIL, 2018, WHEN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN DID A
BILL AT THE REQUEST OF THE
ADMINISTRATION TO ADD THE
NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY TO THE
PUBLIC WORKS BOARD FOR
CONSIDERATION OF ANY LAND
INVOLVING AN AGENCY IN THE
NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY. SO WE
FINALLY COULD HAVE SOMEBODY FROM
PARKS OR FISH AND WILDLIFE OR
OTHERS IF THE LAND WAS ACTUALLY
BEING ACQUIRED, TO MAKE SURE
THERE'S THAT PERSPECTIVE.
INTERESTINGLY A KEY CABINET
MEMBER THAT I WON'T NAME AT THE
TIME THAT WAS OVER ONE OF THESE
AGENCIES SAYS WE SHOULD ABOLISH
THE WHOLE PUBLIC WORKS BOARD.
THE CABINET MEMBER, OVER IT,
BECAUSE THEY SAID THIS, WE
APPROPRIATE THE MONEY IN THE
BUDGET. WE DIRECT THE
DEPARTMENT, EVERYBODY ELSE GOES
OFF AND ACTS WHEN THAT HAPPENS.
IN THIS CASE, WE SET UP AN
ADDITIONAL BARRIER THAT TAKES
MONTHS AND MONTHS AND DELAYS
EVERYTHING. AND YET AT THE TIME,
THAT WAS NOT IN THE CARDS. IT
WAS THE BEST WE COULD DO TO
BRING THE RESOURCES, PEOPLE AT
THE TABLE. WHAT THIS BILL DOES
IS BASICALLY SAYS WE'LL LET THE
DEPARTMENTS AND RESOURCES FOR
THESE LANDS IN THIS AREA DECIDE
WITHOUT THAT ADDITIONAL BARRIER,
HOW TO DEAL WITH THEM. AND WHEN
IT COMES TO FIRE REBUILDING AND
OTHER THINGS, TIMELINESS IS VERY
IMPORTANT. AND THIS IS A ROLE
REVERSAL BECAUSE I WAS IN FRONT
OF A, THE CHAIR OF THE ELECTIONS
COMMITTEE IN AN ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE DOING A REDISTRICTING
BILL FOR SAN LUIS OBISPO. AND
SHE SAYS, I WANT IT FOR THE
WHOLE STATE. OKAY. WE'LL DO
THIS, BUT I WANT TO I WANT THIS
FOR THE WHOLE STATE. I'LL DO
THIS, BILL, BUT I WANT THIS FOR
THE WHOLE STATE, BECAUSE THAT IS
AN ADDED BARRIER THAT DOESN'T
HELP US IN ANY WAY. AND THERE
WAS EVEN A TIME WHEN I COULDN'T
FIGURE OUT WHO WAS THERE. THESE
NAMELESS PEOPLE THAT WOULDN'T
SIGN LETTERS WOULD BLOCK THINGS,
AND YOU COULDN'T TELL WHO THEY
WERE. WHEN WE WERE TRYING TO GET
THINGS DONE BEFORE THE
OPPORTUNITIES WAS LOST OR LOST.
AND SO, AS MUCH AS I WISH THIS
WAS A STATEWIDE BILL, THIS IS
THE RIGHT DIRECTION. AND IF YOU
ACCEPT THE MOTION NOW, I WOULD
MOVE THE BILL. THANK YOU. WE
HAVE A MOTION FROM SENATOR
LAIRD, SENATOR SERRANO. THANK
YOU, ONE OF MY CONCERNS WITH
THIS BILL, AND THERE'S A FEW
OTHERS LIKE IT, IS WE KEEP
TALKING ABOUT ACQUIRING AND
ACQUIRING AND ACQUIRING LAND. WE
HAVE A BUNCH OF HABITAT AGENCIES
OUT THERE. CONSERVATIONS
AGENCIES THAT ARE TRYING TO
ACQUIRE LAND AND HAVING THE
STATE, YOU KNOW, THE STATES
ACTUALLY PULLING BACK FUNDS TO
DO THAT. AND, AND THEY'RE ALSO
NOT DOING A GREAT JOB AT TAKING
CARE OF THE LANDS THAT WE HAVE,
AND ONE OF THE REASONS THAT WE
HAVE THESE CATASTROPHIC FIRES
THAT WIPE OUT ALL OF THESE AREAS
IS BECAUSE WE'RE NOT TAKING CARE
OF THEM CORRECTLY. SO HOW DOES
THIS BILL HELP IN THAT EFFORT?
SO THAT, YOU KNOW, THE FIRES
THAT YOU HAD TALKED ABOUT, SANTA
CRUZ MOUNTAINS, DON'T CONTINUE
TO REOCCUR BECAUSE WE ACTUALLY
START DOING SOMETHING POSITIVE
IN THOSE AREAS, TO ENSURE THAT
WE ARE GOOD STEWARDS OF TAKING
CARE OF SOME OF THE THINGS THAT
MOTHER NATURE DOESN'T DO
ANYMORE, BECAUSE WE HAVE
INTERVENED TOO MUCH. AND ALSO
SUPPORTING THE EFFORTS THAT ARE
ALREADY OUT THERE, AND THESE ARE
LONG, LONG, 30 YEARS IN THE
MAKING EFFORTS. AND THEY'RE
STILL NOT DONE. AND WE'RE
TALKING 600,000 ACRES AND WE
ALREADY HAD 400,000, AND WE
STILL CAN'T GET IT DONE, I FEEL
LIKE THE STATE NEEDS TO TAKE
CARE OF WHAT IT HAS FIRST BEFORE
IT KEEPS ADDING ON TO, WITHOUT A
PLAN FOR TAKING CARE OF THESE
AREAS. SO HOW DOES DOES THIS
HAVE ANY WAY OF MAKING THAT
BETTER? BECAUSE WE HAVE A $1.2
BILLION BACKLOG IN MAINTENANCE.
NO, NO. SO WELL, I'LL ATTEMPT TO
ANSWER IT. AND THEN I'LL ASK MY,
WITNESS TO ALSO. BUT THESE THESE
LANDS PROVIDE CONNECTION BETWEEN
OTHER PARCELS OWNED BY THE
STATE. AND IT'S GOING TO
ACTUALLY HELP THEM IN THEIR FIRE
MANAGEMENT AND MITIGATION
EFFORTS. SO IT'S GOING TO CREATE
A MORE CONNECTED LANDSCAPE SO
THEY CAN GET FROM ONE PLACE TO
ANOTHER IF NEEDED. BUT I'LL LET
OUR SENATOR. WOULD YOU LIKE THE
WITNESS TO RESPOND? YES. OKAY.
GO AHEAD. YES. THANK YOU
SENATOR, YEAH. IN ADDITION TO
WHAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER PELLERIN
JUST SAID, I WOULD JUST ADD THAT
IN THIS PARTICULAR CASE, THIS
DISTRICT BILL, IS REALLY ABOUT
REBUILDING THE STATE PARKS AFTER
THE FIRE, FOR INSTANCE, WHERE
THE VISITOR CENTER IS AND WAS IN
BIG BASIN IS RIGHT AT THE CENTER
OF WHERE THE OLD GROWTH REDWOODS
ARE. AND WHAT THE PARK WANTS TO
DO IS TO MOVE THE VISITOR CENTER
AWAY FROM THOSE OLD GROWTH
REDWOODS, AND, AND PART OF THAT
PROCESS IS FINDING ADJACENT
PROPERTY TO PUT THE NEW VISITOR
CENTER ON. AND MY ORGANIZATION
HAS IDENTIFIED THOSE PROPERTIES,
AND THEY'RE NOT LARGE PROPERTIES
, TO, TO THEN, YOU KNOW,
TRANSFER TO STATE PARKS. SO THEN
THEY CAN BUILD THE NEW VISITOR
CENTER THERE AND HAVE A SHUTTLE
SYSTEM TO TAKE THE FOLKS INTO
THAT AREA OF THE PARK. SO IT'S
NOT ABOUT, IN THIS CASE, AT
LEAST ACQUIRING LARGE TRACTS OF
LAND TO THEN TRANSFER AND MAKE A
NEW PARK. BUT REALLY, ABOUT
REVISIONING WHAT THESE THREE
PARKS, CAN BE FOR THE FUTURE.
AND SO THIS IS JUST SPECIFICALLY
THESE THREE PARKS. EXACTLY. YES,
YES, YES. BUT AT THE SAME TIME,
IT'S GOING TO TAKE MORE
RESOURCES AWAY FROM AN EFFORT
THAT WE'RE NOT REALLY GOOD AT
ACCOMPLISHING ALREADY. AND
THAT'S MY CONCERN WITH IT. I
THINK IT'S GOING TO ENHANCE THE
ABILITY FOR THE STATE PARKS TO
MANAGE THE LAND THAT THEY HAVE.
AND BUILDING IT OUT AS THEY
REIMAGINE IT. CONNECTIVITY WAS
ACTUALLY MORE DESIGNED FOR,
ANIMAL MOVEMENT. YEAH. AND
HABITAT MOVEMENT. AND THOSE ARE
BUILT INTO EXISTING HABITAT
PLANS THAT ARE BEING, YOU KNOW,
LIKE I SAID, PUT ON THE BACK
BURNER. WE'RE NOT GETTING THEM
DONE. AND IF WE WOULD JUST DO
THAT AND THEN AND THEN TALK
ABOUT ADDING ON TO OTHER
RESPONSIBILITIES, I'D BE A LOT
MORE COMFORTABLE WITH BILLS LIKE
THIS. THANK YOU, THANK YOU,
THANK YOU, SENATOR SATO. SENATOR
DELI, I JUST I WANT TO JUST
FOLLOW UP ON MAYBE I DON'T KNOW,
THIS IS A DISTRICT BILL AND I
HAVE NOT SEEN A PARK. I DON'T
LIKE, BUT UNFORTUNATELY, IN MY
DISTRICT, I HAVE THE MOST
VISITED PARK IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA, WHICH IS BURNEY
FALLS. IT'S BEAUTIFUL. IT'S
RIGHT DOWN THE ROAD FROM MY
HOUSE. I LOVE IT, BUT WE'RE
TRYING TO WE'RE DOING SOME
MAINTENANCE ON IT RIGHT NOW, AND
BUT THE PARK SERVICE HAS BEEN
NOT VERY GOOD AT BEING ABLE TO
MANAGE AND DO THE MAINTENANCE
THAT WE NEED. I MEAN, BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS AND NOT AND WE FOUND
MONEY WHEN I FIRST CAME IN 2000,
12, WE FOUND THERE WAS $50
MILLION. THAT WAS FOUND. IT WAS
A PROBLEM. SO I'M GOING TO
SUPPORT YOUR BILL. BUT I WANT TO
SAY, YOU KNOW, TO THE TO THE
FOLKS THAT GO OUT AND BUY THESE
LANDS, THE THIRD PARTIES THAT
PUT THEM TOGETHER, YOU'RE
RISKING SOMETHING WHEN YOU DO
THAT, AND YOU'RE RISKING THE
PROCESS OF GETTING PAID BACK IN
A TIMELY MANNER. AND WE'RE GOING
INTO A BUDGET, THAT IS GOING TO
BE RUGGED, I THINK. AND EVEN
THOSE OF US ON BOTH SIDES OF THE
AISLE, THAT THAT WANTED TO SEE
THE WCB MONEY RESTORED IN THE
BUDGET, IT STILL HASN'T BEEN, I
DON'T KNOW, MAYBE IT'S COMING.
THE GOVERNOR'S COMING WITH IT.
BUT, YOU KNOW, THOSE ARE THE
MONIES THAT HELP PROTECT THIS
LANDS. SO I JUST WANT TO LET I
JUST WANT TO PUT IT OUT THERE. I
WON'T BE AROUND, BUT I LOVE
PARKS, BUT WE DON'T DO A VERY
GOOD JOB OF MAINTENANCE AND
TAKING CARE OF THEM. AFTER WE
BUY THEM. AND THAT'S UNFORTUNATE
BECAUSE, WE SEE THESE FIRES AND
WE SEE LOTS OF NON MANAGEMENT
OUT THERE. SO I JUST WANT FOR
THE RECORD TO SHOW SOMEBODY WHO
LOVES PARKS AND WAS ON THE
SIERRA NEVADA CONSERVANCY FOR
SEVEN YEARS DOING A LOT OF GOOD
CONSERVATION. WE DON'T DO A VERY
GOOD JOB OF FOLLOWING THROUGH
WITH THE MONEY. AFTER WE ACQUIRE
THESE PROJECTS, AND THAT'S
UNFORTUNATE. SO I WILL BE
SUPPORTING YOUR BILL TODAY. BUT
I JUST WANT, FOR THE RECORD TO
KNOW THAT. THANK YOU FOR THAT.
SENATOR DALY, SEEING NO OTHER
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM DÍAS,
WE HAVE A MOTION, WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE? I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR. AYE, VOTE. ALL RIGHT. THE
MOTION AND I JUST. I SHOULD
CLARIFY, YOU ARE ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS. YES, I AM OKAY.
FANTASTIC. THE MOTION IS Dð
PASS, AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS ASSISTANT, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. SORRY OKAY. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS, AS AMENDED,
TO APPROPRIATIONS. SENATOR MEAN.
I MEAN, I SEE NO SENATOR ALLEN
DALY VALLEY I EGGMAN GROVE.
GROVE I HURTADO. LAIRD LAIRD I
LEMON I LEMON I PADILLA I
PADILLA I STERN I STERN I. SEVEN
ZERO. THE COUNT IS SEVEN ZERO.
WE'LL LEAVE THAT BILL ON CALL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
ASSEMBLYWOMAN. ALL RIGHT. WE'LL
MOVE ON TO OUR NEXT BILL. I
THINK WE HAVE ASSEMBLYWOMAN
REYES IN THE ROOM, THAT FILE
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN, AB 2440.
ASSEMBLYWOMAN, YOU CAN PROCEED
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS, TODAY I PRESENT TO YOU
AB 2440. I'M LOOKING FOR MY
WITNESS. WHICH WILL INCORPORATE
THE STATE PARKS DEPARTMENT AND
OTHER AGENCIES MANAGING STATE
OWNED LANDS INTO THE STATE'S
GOALS TO CONSERVE 30% OF LANDS
AND COASTAL WATERS BY 2030. THE
BILL WOULD ENSURE EQUITABLE
ACCESS TO THE OUTDOORS FOR ALL
AND SPECIFY REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS AROUND THE 30 BY 30
GOAL COMPRISE 1.6 MILLION ACRES
OF PROTECTED LAND, INCLUDING
ALMOST ONE QUARTER OF
CALIFORNIA'S COASTLINE, AND
PRESERVING A WIDE RANGE OF
ECOSYSTEMS, FROM COASTAL
WETLANDS TO INLAND DESERT TO
EVERY MAJOR FOREST ECOSYSTEM IN
THE STATE. CALIFORNIA STATE
PARKS ARE AN INVALUABLE ASSET IN
CONSERVATION AND PROVIDING
PUBLIC ACCESS TO CALIFORNIA'S
INCREDIBLE LANDSCAPES. GIVEN THE
UNIQUE ROLE AND SIZE OF OUR
STATE PARKS, IT IS CRITICAL THAT
THE STATE PROMOTE AND SUPPORT
THE ACQUISITION AND STEWARDSHIP
OF STATE LANDS AND STRIVE TO
CREATE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
EQUITABLE ACCESS TO THE OUTDOORS
WHILE FULFILLING THE 30 BY 30
GOALS. AS THE CHAIR OF THE
SELECT COMMITTEE ON STATE PARKS,
EQUITABLE ACCESS TO THE OUTDOORS
HAS BEEN MY NUMBER ONE PRIORITY.
OUR HEARING LAST YEAR WAS
FOCUSED ON ACHIEVING OUTDOOR
EQUITY, AND THIS BILL WILL ALSO
REQUIRE THAT THE LEGISLATURE
RECEIVE AN ANNUAL UPDATE ON
PROGRESS TOWARDS EXPANDING
ACCESS TO NATURE FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS. I'M HERE TO
TESTIFY IN, SUPPORT AND ANSWER
ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS, IS
RACHEL NORTON, EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
PARKS FOUNDATION, AND RACHEL
DAN, DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENTAL
RELATIONS AT SEMPERVIRENS FUND.
WE GOT THE TWO RATIOS. OKAY. YOU
HAVE TWO MINUTES EACH. RACHEL'S
IN SUPPORT OF PARKS. GOOD
AFTERNOON, CHAIR AND MEMBERS. I
AM INDEED RACHEL NORTON,
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF CALIFORNIA
STATE PARKS FOUNDATION. WE ARE A
MEMBER SUPPORTED NONPROFIT
DEDICATED TO PROTECTING AND
PRESERVING THE CALIFORNIA STATE
PARKS SYSTEM FOR THE BENEFIT OF
ALL AND THE PROUD SPONSORS OF 24
AB 2440. AS YOU WELL KNOW,
CLIMATE CHANGE AND LOSS OF
BIODIVERSITY POSE AN EXISTENTIAL
THREAT TO CALIFORNIA'S
ECOSYSTEMS AND WILDLIFE. THE
EVIDENCE IS CLEAR CLIMATE CHANGE
IS HAVING DETRIMENTAL IMPACTS ON
CALIFORNIA'S PEOPLE AND PLACES.
IT IS CRITICAL THAT WE ACT
QUICKLY TO FULFILL THE STATE'S
30 BY 30 GOALS OF PROTECTING AND
RESTORING BIODIVERSITY,
EXPANDING ACCESS TO NATURE, AND
BUILDING RESILIENCE TO CLIMATE
CHANGE. CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS
SYSTEM HAS A CRITICAL ROLE TO
PLAY IN REACHING THESE GOALS,
INCLUDING 1.6 MILLION ACRES OF
PROTECTED LAND AND ALMOST A
QUARTER OF CALIFORNIA'S
COASTLINE. CALIFORNIA STATE
PARKS ARE AN INVALUABLE ASSET IN
CONSERVATION, HISTORICAL
PRESERVATION, AND PROVIDING
PUBLIC ACCESS TO CALIFORNIA'S
INCREDIBLE LANDSCAPES.
UNFORTUNATELY, THE STATE'S
MASSIVE INVESTMENTS IN 30 BY 30
OVER THE PAST THREE YEARS HAVE
LARGELY OVERLOOKED STATE PARKS.
SINCE 2021, CALIFORNIA HAS
INVESTED OVER $1 BILLION FROM
THE GENERAL FUND TO FULFILL OUR
30 BY 30 GOALS AND SUPPORT
NATURE BASED CLIMATE SOLUTIONS,
BUT ONLY A TINY FRACTION OF THIS
NATURE BASED SOLUTIONS. FUNDING
WAS DIRECTED TO STATE PARKS.
THAT TINY FRACTION WAS $11.5
MILLION FOR SEA LEVEL RISE
ADAPTATION IN STATE PARKS. BUT
NOW MORE THAN HALF OF THOSE
FUNDS HAVE BEEN CLAWED BACK DUE
TO THE CURRENT BUDGET CRISIS. IN
ADDITION TO THE STATE SUPPORTING
THE CONSERVATION OF NATURAL
LANDS BY PRIVATE PARTNERS, WE
MUST ALSO PRIORITIZE AND SUPPORT
THE RESPONSIBLE STEWARDSHIP OF
STATE HELD LANDS IN THE PURSUIT
OF PROTECTING CALIFORNIA'S RICH
BIODIVERSITY. AB 2440 WILL
CLEARLY RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANT
ROLE THAT STATE PARKS AND OTHER
STATE LAND MANAGERS PLAY IN
ACHIEVING 30 BY 30, AND WILL
INCREASE TRANSPARENCY IN THE
STATE'S PROGRESS TOWARDS
FULFILLING THIS GOAL. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SO MUCH, NEXT
WITNESS. GOOD AFTERNOON. MY NAME
IS ALSO RACHEL RACHEL DANCE FROM
SEMPERVIRENS FUND, AS YOU JUST
HEARD, OUR ORGANIZATION HAS
PARTNERED WITH STATE PARKS SINCE
OUR FOUNDING 125 YEARS AGO, TO
PROTECT OUR CALIFORNIA'S ICONIC
REDWOOD FORESTS, INCLUDING
PERMANENTLY PROTECTING SIX
SQUARE MILES OF OLD GROWTH
REDWOODS IN 1900 THAT ARE NOW
BIG BASIN REDWOODS STATE PARK,
MOST MOST RECENTLY IN 2021. OUR
ORGANIZATION PROTECTED AND
TRANSFERRED SIX PROPERTIES
TOTALING 222 ACRES OF PARK LANDS
TO THE STATE TO ENHANCE AND
EXPAND CASTLE ROCK STATE PARK.
PROTECTING THESE PROPERTIES
ENSURES THAT THEY BOTH CONTINUE
TO BE WELL MANAGED FOR
CONSERVATION AND RESILIENCY,
AUGMENTING CALIFORNIA'S 30 BY 30
AND CLIMATE WILDFIRE AND
COMMUNITY RESILIENCY GOALS, AND
FORMALLY EXPAND THE PARK'S
INCREDIBLE RECREATIONAL
EXPERIENCES INTO NEW LANDS,
HABITATS, AND VISTAS. STATE
PARKS OWNS AND MANAGES OVER A
MILLION ACRES OF RICH HABITAT
AND ICONIC LANDSCAPES ACROSS THE
STATE, AND WELCOMES MILLIONS OF
VISITORS FROM ACROSS THE GLOBE
EACH YEAR. AS YOU KNOW, AB 2440
RECOGNIZES THIS IMPORTANT WORK
AND SUPPORTS THE KEY ROLE OF
CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS IN
FULFILLING THE STATE'S 30 BY 30
AND EQUITABLE OUTDOOR ACCESS
GOALS. THIS BILL ENSURES THAT
THE NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY
PROVIDES SUPPORT TO STATE AGENCY
PARTNERS TO RESPONSIBLY STEWARD
STATE MANAGED LANDS, AND
REQUIRES PROGRESS REPORTS ON OUR
PROGRESS, AND TO ENSURE THAT ALL
CALIFORNIANS HAVE ACCESS TO OUR
INCREDIBLE NATURAL AND OUTDOOR
SPACES. FOR THESE REASONS, WE
PROUDLY SUPPORT AB 2440 AND
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU SO MUCH TO
THE SECOND RACHEL, DO WE HAVE
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL? ME TWO TESTIMONY.
THANKS. GOOD AFTERNOON. ABIGAIL
SCHMIDT, ON BEHALF OF
MIDPENINSULA REGIONAL OPEN SPACE
DISTRICT, EAST BAY REGIONAL PARK
DISTRICT AND SAVE THE REDWOODS
LEAGUE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU,
ALEX, ON BEHALF OF MOJAVE DESERT
LAND TRUST AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU, GABRIELA FAZIO WITH SIERRA
CLUB CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU, NATALIE BROWN WITH
THE PLANNING AND CONSERVATION
LEAGUE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
SEEING NO OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. OH WAIT, WE HAVE ONE
MORE COMING THROUGH, MAYBE TWO
MORE. OKAY ME, TWO TESTIMONY
VIÆT MICHAEL ZUBIATE WITH
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL VOTERS
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU, SEEING NO
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT,
WE'LL MOVE TO ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION? ALL
RIGHT. WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE. ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE?
NO, WE HAVE A MOTION FROM
SENATOR LEMON, I JUST WANT TO
SAY I APPLAUD YOUR INTENT TO
STRENGTHEN THE GOAL OF 30 BY 30.
OBVIOUSLY, THIS IS CRUCIAL FOR
BIODIVERSITY AND PREVENTING
EXTINCTION. AND WE ALL EVEN, ALL
OF US HERE UP ON THE DAIS, LOVE
OUR STATE PARKS AND WOULD LIKE
TO SEE MORE OPPORTUNITIES TO
INCREASE THEIR DIVERSE LAND
HOLDINGS, ESPECIALLY GIVEN THE
NEED TO PROVIDE MORE EQUITABLE
ACCESS IN THE STATE, BUT AS
ANALYSIS POINTS OUT, STATE PARKS
CURRENTLY FACES A $1 BILLION
MAINTENANCE BACKLOG FOR ITS
EXISTING PARKS, SO THIS WILL BE
A CHALLENGE. AND AS THIS BILL
MOVES FORWARD, I WOULD URGE YOU
TO CONSIDER INCLUDING
ALTERNATIVES TO PRIORITIZE IN
ACHIEVING THE 30 BY 30 GOAL. BUT
WITH THAT, WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE THE ANALYSIS DOES PROVIDE
TWO VERY GOOD. ALTERNATIVES. AND
I THINK CLEARLY NEITHER ONE OF
THOSE IS EXCLUDED IN THE
PROGRAM. BUT I THINK HAVING
FURTHER DISCUSSION REGARDING
REGARDING BOTH OF THOSE, I THINK
WOULD BE IMPORTANT. AND WITH
THAT, I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ASSEMBLYWOMAN, WE
HAVE A MOTION FROM SENATOR LEMON
. THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED.
APPROPRIATIONS ASSISTANT, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR. MIN MIN.
AYE. SATO NOT VOTING. ALAN DELI.
EGGMAN GROVE. HURTADO LAIRD.
LEMON A LEMON. AYE. PADILLA
PADILLA. AYE. STERN OKAY. THREE.
THREE. THAT VOTE COUNT IS THREE
ZERO. WE'LL LEAVE IT ON CALL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ALL RIGHT. OUR NEXT
BILL, WE HAVE FILE ITEM NUMBER
11, ASSEMBLYWOMAN FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN AB 2875. YOU CAN
PRESENT WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. MEMBERS
WETLANDS PROVIDE CRITICAL
HABITAT FOR ENDANGERED SPECIES
AND MANY OTHER RESIDENT WILDLIFE
AND FISH POPULATIONS. THEY'RE
ALSO IMPORTANT TO LOCAL
COMMUNITIES AS THEY SERVE AS
NATURAL WATER PURIFIERS THAT
ABSORB POLLUTANTS TO KEEP THE
WATER, AND INLAND LAKES AND
STREAMS CLEAR BY STORING WATER.
WETLANDS ALSO OPERATE AS NATURAL
FLOOD CONTROL TO PROTECT OUR
COMMUNITIES FROM FLOODING AND
DROUGHT, AND THEY HELP BUFFER
COMMUNITIES FROM CLIMATE CHANGE.
HISTORICAL FILING AND
DEVELOPMENT PROJECTS, HOWEVER,
HAVE REDUCED CALIFORNIA WETLANDS
TO A MERE 10% OF THEIR ORIGINAL
EXTENT, LEAVING MANY COMMUNITIES
VULNERABLE. THE LOSS OF COASTAL
WETLANDS IS EVEN MORE ALARMING.
95% OF FORMERLY ABUNDANT LAGOONS
AND MARSHES ALONG CALIFORNIA'S
1100 MILE COASTLINE HAVE BEEN
DESTROYED. IN 1993, GOVERNOR
PETE WILSON ISSUED EXECUTIVE
ORDER W 5993, ESTABLISHING A
STATE POLICY OF NO NET LOSS AND
LONG TERM GAIN OF WETLANDS.
SINCE THEN, HOWEVER, CALIFORNIA
HAS CONTINUED TO LOSE MORE
WETLAND ACREAGE THAN IT PROVIDES
THROUGH RESTORATION AND
MITIGATION. THE FEDERAL CLEAN
WATER ACT IS CONSIDERED THE MOST
POWERFUL TOOL FOR SAFEGUARDING
WATER QUALITY. WETLANDS AND
RIPARIAN HABITAT. HOWEVER,
STARTING IN 2001, IN A SERIES OF
DECISIONS, FEDERAL COURTS HAVE
LIMITED THE TYPE OF WATER BODIES
AND WETLANDS THAT RECEIVE
FEDERAL PROTECTIONS. IN 2023,
THE US SUPREME COURT ISSUED A
RULING IN SACKETT VERSUS
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION.
PROTECTION AGENCY THAT HAS HAD
ENORMOUS RAMIFICATIONS FOR THE
HEALTH OF THE NATION'S AND
CALIFORNIA'S WETLANDS AND
WATERWAYS. BECAUSE IT EXCLUDED
MANY TYPES OF STATE WATERS,
INCLUDING CERTAIN WETLANDS FROM
THE CLEAN WATER ACT. THE SACKETT
DECISION ALSO UPHELD STATES
AUTHORITIES TO ADDRESS WATER
POLLUTION VIA REGULATION OF LAND
AND WATER USE. CALIFORNIA HAS
LAW, THE PORTER-COLOGNE WATER
QUALITY CONTROL ACT, TO PROTECT
THE WETLANDS THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT CAN NO LONGER
PROTECT. GOVERNOR NEWSOM'S 2024
PROPOSED BUDGET INCLUDES FUNDING
AIMED TO HAVE THE STATE TAKE ON
THE ROLE THAT HAD BEEN CONDUCTED
BY THE US ARMY CORPS OF
ENGINEERS AND THE US EPA, BUT
WILL NO LONGER DUE TO THE
SACKETT DECISION. TO BE CLEAR,
AB 2875 IS NOT CREATING ANY NEW
PROTECTIONS OR PROGRAMS OR
PROVIDING ANY MORE ENFORCEMENT
AUTHORITY. IT'S NOT MEANT TO
STOP NEW HOUSING OR DEVELOPMENT
FROM HAPPENING. THE BILL WILL
MERELY PUT INTO STATUTE THAT IT
IS THE POLICY OF THE STATE TO
PROTECT, CONSERVE AND RESTORE
WETLANDS. BY ENSHRINING THIS
REQUIREMENT INTO STATUTE, WE'RE
MAKING IT CLEAR THAT THE STATE
MUST TAKE ACTIONS AND ADVANCE
POLICIES TO BENEFIT WETLANDS,
WHICH HAS NOT ALWAYS BEEN THE
CASE. I AM VERY PROUD THAT AB
2875 HAS HAD BIPARTISAN
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT IN THE
ASSEMBLY. TESTIFYING TODAY ON
BEHALF OF OUR SPONSOR, AUDUBON
CALIFORNIA, IS KEVIN HUNTING.
AND I WOULD REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE ON THIS IMPORTANT BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON, MR. CHAIR,
COMMITTEE MEMBERS, AS YOUR MY
NAME IS KEVIN HUNTING. I'M HERE
REPRESENTING AUDUBON CALIFORNIA,
AS A SPONSOR OF AB 2875. AUDUBON
CALIFORNIA HAS ABOUT 118,000
MEMBERS STATEWIDE ACROSS 48
AFFILIATED CHAPTERS, ALL OF WHOM
LOVE BIRDS AND ARE PASSIONATE
ABOUT BIRD CONSERVATION. AUDUBON
CALIFORNIA. CALIFORNIA'S MISSION
IS TO RESTORE AND CONSERVE
NATURAL ECOSYSTEMS, FOCUSING ON
BIRDS, OTHER WILDLIFE, AND THEIR
HABITATS FOR THE BENEFIT OF
HUMANITY AND THE EARTH'S
BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY. AUDUBON IS
PROUD TO SPONSOR 275 BECAUSE IT
WOULD PUT INTO LAW THE STATE'S
LONG STANDING POLICY THAT YOU
JUST HEARD ABOUT TO ENSURE NO
NET LOSS AND LONG TERM GAME OF
WETLAND GAIN OF WETLANDS AT A
TIME WHEN CALIFORNIA WETLANDS
ARE AT SERIOUS RISK THAT WHILE
THE CALIFORNIA HAS A NO NET LOSS
POLICY FOR WETLANDS, ENSURING
THAT NET LOSS MUCH LESS LONG
TERM GAIN REMAINS AN ELUSIVE
GOAL. ACCORDING TO A RECENT
REPORT BY THE US FISH AND
WILDLIFE SERVICE, CALIF
CONTINUES TO LOSE WETLANDS IN
MANY PARTS OF THE STATE BETWEEN
2009 AND 2019. DESPITE THIS
POLICY ESTABLISHING NO NET LOSS
AND LONG TERM GAIN IN LAW WOULD
BE AN IMPORTANT STEP TOWARDS
REVERSING THIS TREND.
HISTORICALLY CALIFORNIA'S
CENTRAL VALLEY HAD MORE THAN 4
MILLION ACRES OF WETLANDS, AND
AS YOU HEARD, ABOUT 95% OF THOSE
HAVE BEEN LOST. THERE'S ABOUT
200,000 ACRES REMAINING TODAY.
THE LOSS OF WETLANDS IS A
PROFOUND IMPACT ON WILDLIFE
POPULATIONS AND ESPECIALLY
MIGRATORY BIRDS. EXPERTS
ESTIMATE THAT HISTORICALLY,
ABOUT 60 MILLION BIRDS WERE
MIGRATING TO CALIFORNIA'S
WETLANDS EACH WINTER, INCLUDING
ABOUT 35 TO 40 MILLION DUCKS AND
GEESE. NGUYEN. THE EMINENT
ORNITHOLOGIST FRANK CHAPMAN
VISITED LOS BANOS IN 1903. HE
WROTE. I'VE NEVER SEEN MORE
ABUNDANT TODAY'S WATERFOWL
POPULATIONS IN CALIFORNIA HAVE
DECLINED TO APPROXIMATELY 5 TO 6
MILLION DUCKS AND GEESE THAT
RELY ON THESE WETLANDS FOR
RESTING AND FEEDING DURING
MIGRATION. EVEN THOUGH
DIMINISHED, THESE CALIFORNIA
POPULATIONS COMPRISE ABOUT 60%
OF THE PACIFIC FLYWAYS,
WATERFOWL AND ABOUT 20% OF THE
CONTINENTAL POPULATIONS.
SIMILARLY MOST SHOREBIRDS AND
SONGBIRD POPULATIONS THAT DEPEND
ON WETLANDS HAVE EXPERIENCED
SIGNIFICANT POPULATION DECLINES,
AND TODAY MANY OF THESE WETLAND
DEPENDENT SPECIES ARE IMPERILED
BECAUSE OF THESE WETLAND LOSSES.
OVERALL WETLANDS PROVIDE VALUES
THAT NO OTHER ECOSYSTEM CAN.
VALUES ARE EVEN MORE CRITICAL AS
CALIFORNIA EXPERIENCES THE
INTENSIFYING EFFECTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE. WETLANDS ARE AMONG THE
MOST PRODUCTIVE ECOSYSTEMS IN
THE WORLD. IN MANY PLACES
COMPARABLE TO RAINFORESTS AND
CORAL REEFS, AND IN THE CONTEXT
OF ONE OF THE MOST DIVERSE BIRD
AND WILDLIFE REGIONS ON OUR
PLANET. THEY ARE PARTICULARLY
IMPORTANT HERE. IT IS IN THE
SENATE'S BEST INTEREST TO
CONSERVE THESE WETLAND HABITATS.
WE'VE HEARD ABOUT THE 30 BY 30
GOALS TODAY, AND AS CALIFORNIA
STRIVES TO ACHIEVE THESE ADOPTED
GOALS, ONE OF THE MOST EFFECTIVE
ACTIONS WILL BE TO ENSURE THAT
NO NET LOSS OF THESE WETLANDS
WHEN IT COMES TO WETLAND
CONSERVATION, THE MOST COST,
COST EFFECTIVE METHOD TO
CONSERVE THEM IS TO PROTECT THE
REMAINING WETLANDS THAT WE
ALREADY HAVE. MAYBE 2875
PROVIDES IMPORTANT LEADERSHIP
FOR OTHER STATES AND PROVIDES A
MODEL USING STATE LAW TO SHIELD
WETLAND RESOURCES FROM EFFORTS
TO ERODE FEDERAL PROTECTIONS. BY
CODIFYING THIS POLICY, WE WOULD
DEMONSTRATE OUR COMMITMENT TO
SCIENCE BASED WETLAND
CONSERVATION THAT BENEFIT OUR
PUBLIC HEALTH, BIODIVERSITY, AND
SUPPORT OUR EFFORTS TO COMBAT
THE EFFECTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, AT THIS
TIME, WE WILL TAKE ALL THE
METOOS IN FAVOR OF THIS BILL.
COME ON UP. STATE YOUR NAME. THE
ORGANIZATION YOU REPRESENT, YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THE BILL. GOOD
AFTERNOON, ALEX LOOMER. ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA NATIVE
PLANT SOCIETY, DEFENDERS OF
WILDLIFE, SONOMA LAND TRUST AND
PACIFIC FOREST TRUST, AND STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON, TASHA NEWMAN, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL
OF LAND TRUSTS, BOLSA CHICA LAND
TRUST AND PENINSULA OPEN SPACE
TRUST IN SUPPORT. GOOD
AFTERNOON, NATALIE BROWN, ON
BEHALF OF THE PLANNING AND
CONSERVATION LEAGUE AND SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON, MEGAN CLEVELAND
WITH THE NATURE CONSERVANCY AND
SUPPORT. GOOD AFTERNOON,
CHRISTINA SCARINGE WITH THE
CENTER FOR BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY
AND SUPPORT. KATIE MCCAMMON 350
SACRAMENTO. IN SUPPORT. OF THE
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL LAWYERS
IN SUPPORT. GOOD AFTERNOON,
DARRYL LIDDLE WITH NRDC IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GABRIELA
FAZIO WITH SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. ABIGAIL
SMITH, ON BEHALF OF MIDPENINSULA
REGIONAL OPEN SPACE DISTRICT AND
THE CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS
FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT. CANDACE
MENEGON WITH FRIENDS OF THE
SANTA CLARA RIVER AND COASTAL
CONSERVANCY. IN SUPPORT, BART
BROOME, SANTA CLARA VALLEY WATER
DISTRICT, ALSO KNOWN AS VALLEY
WATER, OUR BOARD HAS TAKEN A
SUPPORT, IF AMENDED, POSITION ON
THIS BILL. WE'RE WORKING WITH
THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE ON SOME
LANGUAGE IN FINDINGS THAT WOULD
JUST CLARIFY THAT THERE'S SOME
NEED FOR FLEXIBILITY IN ORDER TO
PREVENT INUNDATION OF WETLANDS
DUE TO SEA LEVEL RISE. AND I
THINK THAT WE'RE VERY CLOSE, AND
WE VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR'S STAFF. OKAY. IS THERE
ANYBODY THAT IS GOING TO SPEAK
AS A LEAD WITNESS IN OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL? I DON'T SEE
ANYBODY SCRAMBLING OUT OF THEIR
SEATS. SO DOES ANYBODY WANT TO
COME UP AND DO A ME TOO, IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL? IF NOT,
WE WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
DAIS FOR ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS, COMMENTS, CONCERNS.
WE HAVE A MOTION TO MOVE THE
BILL. I DID HAVE A COUPLE OF
CONCERNS ABOUT THE BILL, ONE OF
THEM IS, YOU KNOW, WE DO THESE
WHAT SOUND LIKE VERY SIMPLE
THINGS TO TRY TO CONSERVE, YOU
KNOW, WETLANDS, WHETHER IT'S
WETLANDS, BLUE LINE STREAMS. AND
THAT'S A FEDERAL THING, BUT THEN
WE START DISCOVERING THAT WAY
UP, YOU KNOW, WAY UPSTREAM FROM
SOME OF THESE WETLAND AREAS,
THEY BECOME IMPACTED BECAUSE
SOMEBODY DECIDES THAT SOMEHOW
THAT'S IMPACTING THE WETLANDS,
AND YOU KNOW, IN THIS
ENVIRONMENT THAT WE'RE HAVING,
WE ALREADY CAN DO WE ALREADY
HAVE THE ABILITY TO PROTECT
THESE WETLANDS, AND OTHER THINGS
THAT ARE IN THE ENVIRONMENT.
THAT'S WHAT OUR CEQA PROCESS IS
ALL ABOUT AND ALL. AND ALSO THE
NEPA PROCESS AND, YOU KNOW, MY
CONCERN IS THAT WE'RE KIND OF
PILING ON MORE THAT EVENTUALLY,
STARTS TO CLASH WITH OUR GOALS
TO BUILD HOUSING IN AREAS LIKE
IN MY AREA, WE DON'T HAVE A
WHOLE LOT OF WETLANDS IN MY
AREA, WE HAVE A COUPLE, FUELED
BY RAIN AND THAT'S IT, BUT I'VE
ALSO SEEN A LOT OF PROJECTS,
GET, TORPEDOED BECAUSE THERE'S
AN INTERPRETATION BY SOMEBODY
THAT SOMEHOW THIS IS GOING TO
WIND UP AFFECTING A WETLAND, AND
THEN THAT TURNS INTO A LAWSUIT,
AND IT AND IT KIND OF AND IT
KIND OF MAKES THE, THE ISSUE OF
HOW WE'RE GOING TO BUILD THE
HOUSING WE NEED FOR ALL THE
PEOPLE THAT NEED HOUSING, MORE
AND MORE DIFFICULT TO ACHIEVE.
AND SO, YOU KNOW THIS, I DON'T
KNOW THAT IT'S AS NEEDED, WE
ALREADY ARE TAKING CARE OF SOME
OF THIS STUFF. I'LL PROBABLY LAY
OFF YOUR BILL. AND WITH THAT, I
WILL LET YOU CLOSE. THANK YOU. I
APPRECIATE THE CONCERNS. I'M A
VERY PRO HOUSING LEGISLATOR, SO
I TYPICALLY DON'T DO LEGISLATION
THAT I THINK IS GOING TO STOP
NEEDED HOUSING. AT THE SAME
TIME, WETLANDS PLAY A REALLY
IMPORTANT ROLE TO KEEP HOUSING
SAFE. AND THIS BILL IS IN
RESPONSE TO THIS DECISION TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE DON'T GO
BACKWARDS. IT'S NOT GOING TO,
LIKE YOU SAID, CHANGE WHAT THE
STATE'S DOING, BUT IT WILL BE
PROTECTIVE IN THE FUTURE TO PUT
THIS INTO STATUTE. AND THOSE
WETLANDS ARE DESPERATELY NEEDED.
A LOT OF US CARE ABOUT, YOU
KNOW, THE BIRDS. WE CARE ABOUT
PRESERVING WHAT WE HAVE LEFT AND
I WOULD HOPE THAT OUR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS DON'T MAKE UP
REASONS TO NOT DO HOUSING. AND
THAT CAN HAPPEN WITH ALL MANNER
OF ISSUES. THIS IS NOT ADDING
NEW ENFORCEMENT. IT'S NOT
CHANGING ANY CURRENT POLICY.
IT'S REALLY ENSHRINING WHAT WE
HAVE. BUT I CERTAINLY HEAR YOUR
CONCERNS. AND, YOU KNOW, IF FOR
WHOEVER'S LISTENING OUT THERE,
DON'T MAKE UP AN EXCUSE THAT
INVOLVES A WETLAND BECAUSE IT
HURTS OUR EFFORTS AT
CONSERVATION. OKAY. THANK YOU,
ASSEMBLYWOMAN, WE HAVE A MOTION
ON THE BILL. A MOTION FROM
SENATOR PADILLA IS Dð PASS,
ASSISTANT, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR MINH. AYE MINH. AYE.
CELADO ALLEN. DALLI EGGMAN.
EGGMAN. AYE. GROVE. GROVE. AYE
HURTADO. LAIRD. LIMÓN HI. LEMON.
AYE. PADILLA. PADILLA. AYE
STERN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU, THE VOTE ON THAT IS
FIVE ZERO. WE'LL LEAVE IT ON
CALL FOR NOW. AND WE'LL MOVE
BACK IN THE FILE ITEM FOR FILE
ORDER TO FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX,
AB 2320 BY ASSEMBLYWOMAN IRWIN,
ASSEMBLYWOMAN. YOU CAN PROCEED
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. LONG TIME
NO SEE. DID YOU PRESENT YOUR
BILL THAT QUICKLY? OH, I'M VERY
EFFICIENT. WOW. OKAY WELL, I'M
PLEASED TO PRESENT AB 2320
TODAY. I WOULD LIKE TO START BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE'S
AMENDMENTS AND THANKING THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR HARD
WORK ON THIS BILL. IN 2020,
GOVERNOR NEWSOM ISSUED EXECUTIVE
ORDER N 8220, CREATING THE 30 BY
30 INITIATIVE TO CONSERVE 30% OF
OUR LANDS AND COASTAL WATERS BY
2030, A KEY PART OF THE 30 BY 30
INITIATIVE IS THE USE OF NATURE
BASED SOLUTIONS TO ADDRESS
CLIMATE CHANGE. AB 2320 WOULD
REQUIRE THE CALIFORNIA NATURAL
RESOURCES AGENCY TO IDENTIFY
WILDLIFE CORRIDORS AND FISH
PASSAGE, RESTORATION PROJECTS,
AND INCLUDE THEM IN ITS ANNUAL
REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE. THIS
BILL WOULD FURTHER REQUIRE THE
WILDLIFE CONSERVATION BOARD TO
PRIORITIZE PROJECTS THAT PROTECT
AND CREATE NEW WILDLIFE
CORRIDORS. WILDLIFE CONNECTIVITY
IS A CRITICAL STEP IN PROTECTING
CALIFORNIA'S RICH BIODIVERSITY.
LAST YEAR, B 12, THE FIRST BIRD
KNOWN TO LIVE IN SANTA MONICA
MOUNTAINS IN NEARLY A DECADE,
WAS FATALLY STRUCK BY A VEHICLE
CROSSING HIGHWAY 101. HE HAD
SUCCESSFULLY CROSSED CALIFORNIA
FREEWAYS AT LEAST FIVE TIMES AND
WAS KILLED 16 MILES FROM THE
ONGOING CONSTRUCTION OF THE
LARGEST WILDLIFE CROSSING IN THE
COUNTRY, THE WALLIS ANNENBERG
WILDLIFE CROSSING, WHICH IS IN
MY DISTRICT SIMILARLY.
SIMILARLY, THIS WEEKEND ON
SATURDAY, A MOUNTAIN LION WAS
FOUND DEAD AFTER A VEHICLE
STRUCK CLOSE TO THE SITE OF THE
SAME WILDLIFE CROSSING. STORIES
SUCH AS THOSE OF BB 12 AND THE
BELOVED MOUNTAIN LION P 22, ARE
A TESTAMENT TO THE FACT THAT WE
MUST INCREASE HABITAT
CONNECTIVITY FOR CALIFORNIA'S
WILDLIFE. WITH ME HERE TODAY TO
TESTIFY ARE THE BILL SPONSOR,
MS. CANDICE MENEGON FROM. I'M
THE COASTAL RANCHES CONSERVANCY
AND ABIGAIL SCHMIDT ON BEHALF OF
THE FRIENDS OF THE SANTA CLARA
RIVER. THANK YOU. YOU EACH HAVE
TWO MINUTES. GOOD AFTERNOON,
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS. MY NAME IS
CANDICE MENEGON. I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF COASTAL
WATERS CONSERVANCY, WE ARE A
PROUD CO-SPONSOR OF THE BILL.
AND FOR THE LAST 20 YEARS, WE
HAVE BEEN A FIERCE ADVOCATE FOR
THE GAVIOTA COAST IN SANTA
BARBARA COUNTY. AND THAT
INCLUDES REDUCING WILDLIFE
COLLISIONS ALONG THE GAVIOTA
PASS, WE ARE GRATEFUL FOR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IRWIN'S
LEADERSHIP ON CONNECTIVITY NEEDS
STATEWIDE BECAUSE FRAGMENTATION
OF NATURAL AREAS IS THE NUMBER
ONE CAUSE OF SPECIES DECLINE IN
CALIFORNIA WILDLIFE CORRIDORS
AND HABITAT CONNECTIVITY ARE
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT FOR
MOVEMENT AND SPECIES ADAPTATION
DURING TIMES OF CLIMATE CHANGE.
CONSERVATION EXPERTS AGREE THAT
THE TOP PRIORITY FOR
BIODIVERSITY CONSERVATION IS TO
PROTECT HABITAT AND TO PROVIDE
CONNECTIVITY BETWEEN THAT
HABITAT. AND AB 2320 IS A PUSH
TO IMPLEMENT KNOWN PRIORITIES
THAT WERE IDENTIFIED IN THE 2010
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE,
CALTRANS STATE ESSENTIAL HABITAT
CONNECTIVITY REPORT. BUT, AND AS
WAS MENTIONED AND AS WE HAVE
WITNESSED WHILE WE'VE BEEN
MOVING THIS BILL THROUGH THE
LEGISLATURE, BLACKBERRIES HAVE
HAD THE I-5 AT A STANDSTILL.
BEING IN TRAFFIC, WE'VE LOST A
MOUNTAIN LION THIS PAST WEEKEND
AND WE PICKING UP WILD, MOUNTAIN
LIONS IN ARROYO HONDO PRESERVE
IN SANTA BARBARA COUNTY. I'VE
SEEN FRESH SPUR ALONG GAVIOTA
CREEK AND OUR SPECIES CERTAINLY
NEED ALL THE HELP WITH REGARDS
TO TERRESTRIAL CONNECTIVITY, BUT
WE ALSO HAVE MULTIPLE, FISH
PASSAGE BARRIERS, IN OUR
LANDSCAPES TO GAVIOTA CREEK AS
14 FISH PASSAGE BARRIERS
ASSOCIATED WITH CALTRANS
INFRASTRUCTURE ON THE HIGHWAY
SYSTEM. AND SO CONNECTIVITY IS
ESSENTIAL TO BIODIVERSITY
RESILIENCE AND BOLSTERING 30 BY
30 OBJECTIVES, AS WELL AS THE
SALMON SALMON STRATEGY FOR
HOTTER, DRIER FUTURE. AND SO,
USING THESE KEYSTONE SPECIES,
SUCH AS THE FEDERAL ENDANGERED
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA STEELHEAD
AND SOUTH COAST AND CENTRAL
COAST MOUNTAIN LION POPULATIONS,
YOU COULD WRAP UP. I AM HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS AND
RESPECTFULLY, REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE TODAY. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON, ABIGAIL SCHMIDT, ON
BEHALF OF THE FRIENDS OF THE
SANTA CLARA RIVER, I WANT TO
ECHO A LOT OF THE COMMENTS OF
THE PREVIOUS TESTIMONY AND ALSO
JUST POINT OUT THAT THIS BILL
WOULD TAKE ALREADY IDENTIFIED
WILDLIFE CONNECTIVITY BARRIERS
AND JUST MAKE SURE THAT THOSE
ARE BEING ADDRESSED THROUGH THE
STATE'S 30 BY 30 PROGRESS
TRACKING, OBVIOUSLY, THIS IS A
PRESSING ISSUE STATEWIDE, AND
THIS IS A REALLY KEY PIECE OF
THE 30 BY 30 GOAL AND EFFORT,
THAT THAT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
IS NOT OVERLOOKED. SO I WANT TO
ECHO THE PREVIOUS COMMENTS AND
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH. DO WE
HAVE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL? ME TWO
TESTIMONY, NAME, AFFILIATION,
SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE. ALEX
LOOMER ON BEHALF OF AUDUBON
CALIFORNIA DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE
AND SONOMA LAND TRUST IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. TASHA
NEWMAN, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF LAND
TRUSTS AND THE PENINSULA OPEN
SPACE TRUST AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. ZACH SCHEFFLER WITH THE
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GABRIELA
FAZIO WITH SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
NATALIE BROWN WITH THE PLANNING
AND CONSERVATION LEAGUE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU, CHRISTINA
SCARINGE WITH THE CENTER FOR
BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. HI, KRISTEN
GORI, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS
FOUNDATION IN MIDPENINSULA
REGIONAL OPEN SPACE DISTRICT,
SEMPERVIRENS FUND AND THE LAND
TRUST OF SANTA CRUZ COUNTY IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON, SAM DAVIDSON FOR
TROUT UNLIMITED IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. RUTH MCDONALD, ON
BEHALF OF CLIMATE REALITY
PROJECT LOS ANGELES AND SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY CHAPTERS IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. SEEING NO
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT,
WE'LL MOVE ON TO ANY OPPOSITION
WITNESSES. DO WE HAVE ANY
OPPOSITION WITNESSES SEEING NONE
IN THE ROOM. WE'LL BRING IT BACK
TO THE MEMBERS. DO ANY MEMBERS
HAVE ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
ON THE BILL? SEEING NONE, DO WE
HAVE A MOTION ON THE BILL? SO
MOVED. WE HAVE A MOTION FROM
SENATOR LEMON, WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE ASSEMBLYMEMBERS
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, WE HAVE A
MOTION AND THE MOTION IS. I'M
SORRY. Dð PASSES AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. FILE ITEM SIX,
AB 2320. ASSISTANT, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. SENATOR. MIN. MIN.
AYE. SATO. NOT VOTING. ALAN DELI
. EGGMAN. EGGMAN. AYE. GROVE
HURTADO. LAIRD LAIRD. AYE. LEMON
A LEMON. AYE. PADILLA. PADILLA.
AYE. STERN. THE VOTE COUNT IS
FIVE ZERO. WE'LL LEAVE IT ON.
CALL THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT, SO I
SEE WE HAVE ASSEMBLYWOMAN PAPIN
IN THE ROOM. SO I THINK YOU'RE
NEXT UP ON FILE ITEM ORDER. THIS
IS FILE ITEM NUMBER 13. THANK
YOU FOR WAITING, ASSEMBLYWOMAN
ADDIS, YOUR NEXT, IT'S AB 3220.
ASSEMBLYWOMAN. YOU CAN PRESENT
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR. GOOD AFTERNOON,
MEMBERS. I'D LIKE TO START BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AND BY ALSO THANKING
THE CONSULTANT FOR THEIR WORK
WITH MY STAFF ON THIS BILL. AB
3220 IS A SIMPLE BILL THAT
REQUESTS THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF
FISH AND WILDLIFE, CONSIDER
SEEKING STATE VERIFICATION
AUTHORITY FROM THE ARMY CORPS OF
ENGINEERS TO BETTER STREAMLINE
THE MARICULTURE PERMITTING
PROCESS. MERRICK CAN
SIGNIFICANTLY BENEFIT THE OCEAN
ECOSYSTEMS IF DONE RIGHT, BY
IMPROVING WATER TEMPERATURE,
ACIDITY, CARBON SEQUESTRATION,
AND MORE. YET, THE DEMAND FOR
ENVIRONMENTALLY BENEFICIAL
SHELLFISH AND SEA SEAWEED
PROJECTS FAR OUTPACED THE
REGULATORY PERMITTING PROCESSES
THAT ARE CURRENTLY IN PLACE,
PERMITTING A MARICULTURE PROJECT
INVOLVES MULTIPLE STATE, FEDERAL
AND LOCAL AGENCIES FOR THOSE
REQUIRING THE USE OF STATE WATER
BOTTOM LEASES IN CALIFORNIA,
PERMITS MUST GO SEEK PERMITS
FROM ROUGHLY A DOZEN DIFFERENT
AGENCIES OVER THE LAST DECADE,
FEDERAL, STATE, AND LOCAL
AGENCIES HAVE BEEN LOOKING FOR
WAYS TO STREAMLINE THE
PERMITTING PROCESS FOR
MARICULTURE, A FEDERAL REPORT
FROM 2014 RECOMMENDED THE
PERMITTING AUTHORITY BE
DELEGATED TO THE STATES THROUGH
AGREEMENT. SINCE THE REPORT WAS
ISSUED, NEW HAMPSHIRE, VIRGINIA,
AND FLORIDA HAVE BEEN GRANTED
STATE VERIFICATION AUTHORITY,
WHICH HAS LED TO GREATER
PERMITTING EFFICIENCY IN ALL
THREE STATES. IN AN EFFORT TO
INCREASE PERMITTING EFFICIENCY.
IN CALIFORNIA, AB 3220 SIMPLY
REQUESTS THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF
FISH AND WILDLIFE INVESTIGATE
MEANS BY WHICH IT CAN STREAMLINE
THE FEDERAL PERMIT PROCESS OF
THE UNITED STATES ARMY CORPS OF
ENGINEERS AND OTHER FEDERAL
AGENCIES WHOSE APPROVAL IS
NECESSARY TO OPERATE A
RESTAURANT. RESTORATIVE OCEAN
FARMING PROJECT IN CALIFORNIA.
THIS BILL HAS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
AND NO NO VOTES. AND WITH ME TO
TESTIFY TODAY IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL IS JADE CLEMONS FROM, BLUE
SEA. DIRECTOR, I DON'T COME ON
UP, JADE. AND AFTER THAT, I HAVE
MADELINE HARDY, PHD CANDIDATE
FROM USC. THANK YOU. YOU EACH
HAVE TWO MINUTES AND YOU CAN
PROCEED WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
GOOD AFTERNOON TO THE CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AND ASSEMBLYWOMAN THÀNH,
MY NAME IS JADE CLEMONS. I'M
DIRECTOR OF THE BLUE SUSTAINABLE
ECONOMY ALLIANCE AT ALTASEA. IT
IS A PRIVILEGE TO BE HERE TODAY
TO SPEAK ON BEHALF OF AND IN
SUPPORT OF REGENERATIVE OCEAN
FARMING AND SUSTAINABLE
AQUACULTURE PRACTITIONERS. I
WILL NOT REPEAT ALL OF THE
AMAZING BENEFITS THAT THE
ASSEMBLYWOMAN JUST MENTIONED,
AND THAT'S MY COLLEAGUE HERE.
WILL WILL ELABORATE ON AS WELL.
ONE BENEFIT, THOUGH, OF
MARICULTURE THAT I'D LIKE TO
DOUBLE TAP ON IS THE ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITY THAT THIS INDUSTRY
REPRESENTS FOR CALIFORNIA, WITH
THE VAST MAJORITY OF SEAFOOD
PRODUCTS, BOTH PLANTS AND
ANIMALS CONSUMED IN THE US BEING
IMPORTED, THAT'S ABOUT $25
BILLION WORTH OF INPUTS OF
IMPORTS, $100 MILLION WORTH OF
THAT. JUST BASED ON SEAWEED
ALONE. THERE IS AN EXTRAORDINARY
POTENTIAL TO BRING JOBS AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT IN THIS
SECTOR TO THIS STATE AND REDUCE
THOSE IMPORTS, REDUCING RELIANCE
ON IMPORTS BY BOLSTERING
DOMESTIC PRODUCTION THAT IS WELL
REGULATED AND DONE IN A
SUSTAINABLE FASHION, WOULD
CREATE A RESILIENT SUPPLY CHAIN
WITH THE ADDED BENEFIT OF ALL OF
THE ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFITS THAT
WERE MENTIONED. SEAWEED
AQUACULTURE IS THE FASTEST
GROWING SECTOR IN THIS INDUSTRY
AND THIS INDUSTRY CAN THRIVE
HERE IN CALIFORNIA. TO SEE THIS
SECTOR REACH ITS FULL POTENTIAL
IN CALIFORNIA WILL REQUIRE
POLICY SUPPORT. LENGTHY, COMPLEX
PERMITTING PROCESSES ARE
CONSISTENT, FLAGGED AS ONE OF
THE OBSTACLES TO RESEARCH AND
CONVENTIONAL COMMERCIAL
DEVELOPMENT IN THIS SPACE, AND
AB 3220 IS ONE PIECE OF THE
PUZZLE. TO ADDRESS THIS
CHALLENGE, INVESTIGATE THE
POSSIBLE EFFICIENCY GAINS
RESULTING FROM STATE
VERIFICATION AUTHORITY IS
WORTHWHILE. IT WILL REDUCE THE
BURDEN ON APPLICANTS, AND IT
WILL ALLOW THE STATE WITH MORE
CONTROL AND AUTHORITY OVER
PERMITTING ADMINISTRATIVE
PROCESSES. TWO OF THE THREE
STATED GOALS FOR THE FORTHCOMING
OCEAN PROTECTION COUNCIL STATE
AQUACULTURE ACTION PLAN RELATE
TO PERMITTING AND GOVERNMENTS
STATE SORRY PERMITTING AND
GOVERNANCE. STATE VERIFICATION
AUTHORITY WOULD BE ONE MORE TOOL
AT THE STATE'S DISPOSAL TO
IMPLEMENT THE AQUACULTURE ACTION
PLAN AND REAP THE BENEFITS OF A
THRIVING, SUSTAINABLE
AQUACULTURE INDUSTRY IN OUR
GREAT STATE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. NEXT WITNESS. WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY. HI. GOOD AFTERNOON
. THANK YOU, ASSEMBLYWOMAN. MR.
CHAIR AND ASSEMBLY MEMBERS, MY
NAME IS MADELINE HARDIN. I AM A
GRADUATE STUDENT AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. I HAVE ALSO WORKED
FOR OVER TEN YEARS IN THE
SUSTAINABLE KELP AND BIVALVE
MARICULTURE INDUSTRIES, AND I
HAVE SPENT THE LAST FIVE YEARS
DEDICATING MY DOCTORAL
DISSERTATION TO UNDERSTANDING
THE GENETIC UNDERPINNINGS OF
GIANT KELP, HEAT STRESS RESPONSE
IN CALIFORNIA. AND WITH THAT, I
WOULD LIKE TO STAND IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB 3220. AND I WOULD
LIKE TO ALSO HIGHLIGHT THE
IMMENSE ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFITS
OF BOTH KELP AND SEAWEED
AQUACULTURE AND MARICULTURE.
EXCUSE ME. IN CALIFORNIA, BOTH
KELP AND SEAWEED OFFER IMMENSE
ECOSYSTEM SERVICES. SEAWEED OR
KELP IN CALIFORNIA ACT AS CARBON
SINKS AND THEY ARE VERY, VERY
FAST GROWING. SO WHEN WE
ACTIVELY CULTIVATE KELP, WE TAKE
THAT OUT OF THE ENVIRONMENT AND
THEREBY ENGAGE IN A NATURE BASED
CARBON REMOVAL SYSTEM. FURTHER
BIVALVES LIKE MUSSELS AND
OYSTERS, THEY ACTUALLY UPTAKE A
HUGE AMOUNT OF WATER. AND IN
DOING SO, THEY FILTER POLLUTANTS
FROM THE ECOSYSTEM, NAMELY
PHOSPHORUS AND NITROGEN, AND
THERE IS A WONDERFUL CASE STUDY
IT, IN WHICH NOAA REPORTED, IN
THE CASE OF HOG ISLAND OYSTER
COMPANY IN THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY
, THE WATER QUALITY SURROUNDING
THE MARICULTURE LINES FOR THEIR
OYSTERS HAD ACTUALLY DRASTICALLY
IMPROVED FOLLOWING FARMING
EFFORTS. FINALLY, THERE IS A
METHOD OF SUSTAINABLE
MARICULTURE, AND IT'S CALLED
INTEGRATED MULTI-TROPHIC
APICULTURE. IT'S WHERE YOU TAKE
TWO SPECIES FROM DIFFERENT
TROPHIC LEVELS OR MULTIPLE
SPECIES, RATHER FROM DIFFERENT
TROPHIC LEVELS, AND YOU CAN GROW
THEM TOGETHER IN SUCH A WAY TO
CREATE A CLOSED LOOP WASTE
STREAM. YOU CAN DO THIS WITH
BOTH KELP AND BIVALVES, INSOMUCH
THAT THE BIVALVES CAN RELEASE
WASTE AND KELP CAN UPTAKE IT.
THIS CREATES A CLOSED LOOP WASTE
STREAM AS WELL AS A CARBON SINK,
AND DOES NOT NECESSITATE ANY
HERBICIDES, PESTICIDES OR
OTHERWISE FEED ADDITIVES INTO
THE SYSTEM. SO IN ESSENCE IT IS
VERY SUSTAINABLE. PERMACULTURE
FOR THE OPEN OCEAN IN CLOSING
START TO WRAP UP. YES,
ABSOLUTELY. THE ECOSYSTEM
SERVICES OF KELP AND SEAWEEDS
ARE IMMEASURABLE. AND I WOULD
JUST LIKE TO REALLY STRONGLY
SUPPORT AB 3220. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. OKAY. APPRECIATE
THAT. DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN THE ROOM IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL? ME TWO TESTIMONY
NAME SEEING NONE. OKAY WE'LL
MOVE ON TO ANY OPPOSITION
WITNESSES. DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER
ANY OPPOSITION WITNESSES IN THE
ROOM? ALL RIGHT. SEEING NONE,
WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO THE
MEMBERS. ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM THE MEMBERS? I
WOULD MOVE THE BILL. OKAY
FANTASTIC. WE HAVE A MOTION,
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THIS,
BILL. SEEMS LIKE AN IMPORTANT
STEP FORWARD FOR SUSTAINABILITY.
AND I THANK YOU FOR WORKING WITH
MY STAFF ON THIS. WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE? I GOT NOTHING TO SAY
OTHER THAN KELP. KELP AND KELP,
SO I REALLY APPRECIATE THE HELP
WITH KELP AND, AND THE
ENTHUSIASM OF MY WITNESSES IS
NOTHING SHORT OF CONTAGIOUS.
IT'S JUST DELIGHTFUL TO HEAR ALL
THE GOOD THAT CAN COME FROM IT.
SO RESPECTFULLY. REQUEST AND I
MOVE. I WAS GOING TO SAY NO, BUT
, I WANT TO SAY I NOT KNOW
EXACTLY. ALL RIGHT. WE HAVE A
MOTION FROM SENATOR EGGMAN ON
THE BILL. I'M SORRY FOR THE DAD
JOKE, MOTION IS Dð PASS IS
AMENDED TO, APPROPRIATIONS
ASSISTANT. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR. MIN A MIN. AYE. SALADO
HI. SALADO. AYE. ALLEN. DALLI.
DALLI AYE. EGGMAN. EGGMAN. AYE.
GROVE HI. GROVE. AYE. HURTADO.
LAIRD LAIRD. AYE. LIMÓN. LIMÓN.
AYE PADILLA. PADILLA AYE. STERN.
EIGHT ZERO, THE VOTE ON THAT IS
EIGHT ZERO. WILL LEAVE IT ON
CALL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
ASSEMBLYWOMAN. AND WE'LL MOVE ON
TO ASSEMBLYWOMAN, ADDIS. THANK
YOU FOR WAITING. THEY'RE FILE
ITEM NUMBER 15, AB 3233, AND YOU
CAN BEGIN WHENEVER YOU'RE READY
TO START BACK. WELL, THANK YOU
SO MUCH, CHAIR AND MEMBERS AND
OUR ADVOCATES THAT ARE HERE
TODAY, TODAY, I'M HERE TO
PRESENT AB 3233, THE LOCAL
ENVIRONMENTAL TRACE AND SAFETY
ACT. AND I DO WANT TO CONFIRM
THAT I'M ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AT FACE VALUE. I WILL
SAY THIS BILL IS A DIRECT
RESPONSE TO AN ISSUE THAT I HAVE
HEARD FROM MY CONSTITUENTS,
PARTICULARLY IN MONTEREY COUNTY.
BUT BEYOND THAT, IT IS A
PERSISTENT PROBLEM THAT APPLIES
TO ALL OF US HERE AND TO ALL
CALIFORNIANS. IN RECENT YEARS,
WE HAVE HEARD FROM MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS, EDUCATORS, LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS, PARENTS, AND
COUNTLESS OTHERS ABOUT THE
IMPACTS OF OIL AND GAS
OPERATIONS ON COMMUNITIES. WE
HAVE READ RESEARCH ON THE
IMPACTS TO PUBLIC HEALTH,
INCLUDING INCREASED RISK OF
ASTHMA AND CARDIAC DISEASE, MOST
ESPECIALLY IN LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES AND COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR. WE HAVE WITNESSED THE
INCREASED RISK OF EARTHQUAKES
FROM DRILLING AND OIL SPILLS AND
AIR POLLUTION, AND WE HAVE HEARD
CONCERNS ABOUT DEPRECIATING
PROPERTY VALUES AS WELL AS
DECREASED INVESTMENT IN
RESIDENTIAL AREAS NEAR OIL AND
GAS. AS A RESULT, MANY CITIES
AND COUNTIES HAVE TAKEN STEPS TO
REEVALUATE WHETHER TO MAINTAIN
THESE OPERATIONS, ESPECIALLY AS
CALIFORNIA REDUCES ITS
DEPENDANCE ON FOSSIL FUELS AND
CREATES A CARBON NEUTRAL FUTURE.
MONTEREY COUNTY SAN BENITO
COUNTY, LOS ANGELES COUNTY,
ALAMEDA CITY, AND CULVER CITY
HAVE ALL INTRODUCED ORDINANCES
AND PASSED LOCAL MEASURES TO
REDUCE OR ELIMINATE OIL AND GAS.
IN DOING SO, THEY HAVE MADE IT
THEIR RESPONSIBILITY TO DO THEIR
OWN COST BENEFIT ANALYSIS OF
WHETHER TO KEEP SUCH ACTIVITIES
IN THEIR COMMUNITIES, AND TO
DETERMINE IF ANY ECONOMIC
BENEFIT IS WORTH THE NEGATIVE
CONSEQUENCES TO HEALTH, SAFETY,
TOURISM, THE ENVIRONMENT AND
MUCH MORE. DESPITE THE POPULAR
AND OVERWHELMING POPULAR SUPPORT
FOR THESE LOCAL MEASURES, THE
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT RULED
LAST FALL THAT THE LOCAL MEASURE
IN MONTEREY COUNTY WOULD NOT
HOLD DUE TO HOW WE HAVE WRITTEN
STATE LAW, AND THIS INVALIDATES
THE ACTIONS OF OUR COMMUNITIES.
DISENFRANCHIZES VOTERS WHO HAVE
VOICED THEIR CONCERNS AND
ULTIMATELY LIMITS THE ABILITY OF
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO PROTECT
THEIR COMMUNITIES. WE DO BELIEVE
THIS IS A DANGEROUS PRECEDENT
THAT WE CAN'T IGNORE. IGNORE. SO
AB 3233, WOULD ENABLE LOCAL
COMMUNITIES TO MAKE THEIR OWN
DECISIONS ABOUT THEIR WELFARE,
HEALTH AND ECONOMY. AND
SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL CLARIFIES
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AUTHORITY TO
LIMIT OR PROHIBIT OIL AND GAS
OPERATIONS METHODS AND LOCATIONS
IN THEIR JURISDICTIONS, I WILL
SAY AB 3233 DOES NOT BAN NEW OIL
OR GAS OPERATIONS AND DOES NOT
MANDATE THAT LOCAL ENTITIES STOP
ACTIVITIES. IT SIMPLY CLARIFIES
THAT THEY DO HAVE THE POWER TO
DO SO. JOINING ME TODAY TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS, HOLLAND
KRETZMANN FROM THE CENTER OF
BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY, AS WELL AS
ADA WADLER FROM THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES.
THANK YOU. ASSEMBLYWOMAN, YOU
HAVE EACH TWO MINUTES TO
TESTIFY. YOU CAN PROCEED WHEN
READY. GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIRMAN
MIN AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS,
HOLLAND KRETZMANN FOR THE CENTER
FOR BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY. I'M AN
ATTORNEY WITH MORE THAN A DECADE
OF EXPERIENCE IN CALIFORNIA OIL
AND GAS LAWS. THE CENTER PROUDLY
SPONSORS AB 3233, THE LOCAL
ENVIRONMENTAL CHOICE AND SAFETY
ACT, A BILL THAT WOULD PRESERVE
THE ABILITY OF CITIES AND
COUNTIES TO USE THEIR LOCAL
AUTHORITY TO PROTECT THEIR
RESIDENTS FROM OIL AND GAS
POLLUTION. IT'S COMMON SENSE
THAT CITIES AND COUNTIES OUGHT
TO BE ABLE TO DECIDE WHETHER AND
UNDER WHAT CONDITIONS ÓRDENES
POLLUTING ACTIVITIES CAN TAKE
PLACE IN THEIR JURISDICTION.
AFTER CAREFULLY WEIGHING THEIR
CONSTITUENTS VOICES AND
POTENTIAL HARMS TO HEALTH AND
SAFETY AND THE ENVIRONMENT,
THAT'S THE WAY IT'S ALWAYS BEEN
IN CALIFORNIA CITIES AND
COUNTIES HAVE LOCAL RULES APPLY,
APPLYING TO ALL KINDS OF
INDUSTRIES, INCLUDING OIL AND
GAS. THESE CAN RANGE FROM
STRAIGHT UP BANS TO SETBACK
MINIMUMS TO, IN THE CASE OF OIL
AND GAS. IN KERN COUNTY, LOCAL
ORDINANCES TO PROMOTE FURTHER
PRODUCTION OF OIL AND GAS. LAST
YEAR, THE CALIFORNIA SUPREME
COURT INVALIDATED PARTS OF
MONTEREY COUNTY'S OIL AND GAS
ORDINANCE ON NARROW GROUNDS
BASED ON AN OUTDATED 1961
PROVISION OF THE STATE OIL AND
GAS CODE. BUT THE OIL INDUSTRY
HAS DISTORTED THIS RULING AND
HAS USED IT TO SOW CONFUSION
ABOUT WHAT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS CAN
AND CAN'T DO. THE INDUSTRIES
THREATS AND INTIMIDATION HAVE
HAD A CHILLING EFFECT ON LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS, WHO WANT MORE
CLARITY IN THE STATE LAW ABOUT
THE SCOPE OF LOCAL AUTHORITY. AB
3233 WOULD PUT AN END TO THIS
CONFUSION BY UPDATING THE STATE
PUBLIC RESOURCES CODE TO MAKE IT
CRYSTAL CLEAR THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS CAN ENACT
PROTECTIONS FROM OIL AND GAS
DEVELOPMENT, AND SPECIFYING THAT
THEY MAY PROHIBIT ANY EXTRACTION
TECHNIQUES SUCH AS FRACKING,
WASTEWATER DISPOSAL, OR STEAM
INJECTION. IT WILL ALSO CONFIRM
THAT THE STATE OIL AND GAS
SUPERVISOR MUST PRIORITIZE
HEALTH AND SAFETY OF
CALIFORNIANS AND PROTECT THE
ENVIRONMENT AND CLIMATE AS
CALIFORNIA MOVES TOWARD A
CLEANER AND MORE SUSTAINABLE
FUTURE. WE URGE YOU TO SUPPORT
AB 3233. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. NEXT WITNESS.
GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. MY NAME IS ADA WELDER
AND I'M A LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE
WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES OR CSAC.
AND WE REPRESENT ALL 58
COUNTIES. WE ARE PLEASED TO
SUPPORT AB 3233, WHICH WOULD
ENHANCE LOCAL CONTROL OVER LAND
USE AND ZONING ISSUES WITH
REGARDS TO OIL AND GAS COMPANIES
IN CALIFORNIA, MOST LAND USE
DECISIONS ARE DELEGATED TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO ENSURE THE BEST
POSSIBLE DECISIONS ARE MADE FOR
EACH INDIVIDUAL COMMUNITY.
COUNTIES ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR
WEIGHING ESTHETIC,
ENVIRONMENTAL, ECONOMIC AND
SAFETY CONCERNS WITHIN THEIR
COMMUNITIES, AND AS SUCH WE HAVE
A VESTED INTEREST IN MAINTAINING
CLEAR AUTHORITY TO GOVERN OIL
AND GAS RELATED LAND USES
THROUGHOUT OUR JURISDICTIONS.
THAT IS WHY CSAC FILED AN AMICUS
BRIEF IN CHEVRON VERSUS COUNTY
OF MONTEREY, WHICH CHALLENGED
MEASURE Z, A LOCAL ORDINANCE
WHICH AIMED TO RESTRICT OIL AND
GAS DEVELOPMENT WITHIN THE
COUNTY. AB 3233 WOULD CLARIFY IN
STATUTE THAT THESE LOCAL POWERS
APPLY TO THE REGULATION OF OIL
AND GAS PRODUCTION FACILITIES.
TO BE CLEAR, WE'RE NOT HERE AS A
, YOU KNOW, TAKING A POSITION
AGAINST OIL AND GAS DEVELOPMENT,
BUT THIS BILL WOULD ENSURE THAT
COUNTIES HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO
BALANCE THEIR UNIQUE LOCAL NEEDS
AND TRADE OFFS THAT ARISE IN THE
CONTEXT OF THESE PROJECTS. AND
IT IS FOR THESE REASONS WE ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. ALL RIGHT. DO WE
HAVE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN THE
ROOM IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL? ME
TWO TESTIMONY. NAME POSITION,
AFFILIATION AND SUPPORT OF THE
MEASURE. MICHELLE RUBALCAVA WITH
NIELSEN MERKSAMER ON BEHALF OF
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. REBECCA MARCUS, ON
BEHALF OF THE CENTER FOR FOOD
SAFETY AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
KIM STONE. STONE ADVOCACY FOR
CONSUMER WATCHDOG IN
ENTHUSIASTIC SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
JOSH, ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTIES
OF LOS ANGELES AND SANTA CRUZ IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. TASHA
NEWMAN, ON BEHALF OF
EARTHJUSTICE AND SUPPORT, THANK
YOU. SIERRA CLUB, CALIFORNIA, IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. STRONG
PARTNER MICHAEL ZUBIATE WITH
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL ORDERS
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU NATALIE
BROWN WITH THE PLANNING AND
CONSERVATION LEAGUE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU, KATIE MCCALMAN IN
SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF 350
SACRAMENTO 350 BAY AREA ACTION.
350 HUMBOLDT SAN DIEGO 350
BANNED SINGLE USE PLASTICS AND A
THOUSAND GRANDMOTHERS FOR FUTURE
GENERATIONS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ENVIRONMENT CALIFORNIA
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. JUSTIN
BOWERS CLEAN AIR FOR KIDS. ORG
STRONGLY SUPPORTS. IN ADDITION
NORTH COUNTY EQUITY AND JUSTICE
FACTS CALIFORNIA NURSES FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH AND JUSTICE
ECOSYSTEM ABILITY PEEPS NCC, Ã
AND ACTIVIST SAN DIEGO STRONGLY
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. DARRYL
LIDDLE WITH NRDC IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU, RUTH MCDONALD FOR
CLIMATE ACTION CALIFORNIA
CLIMATE REALITY PROJECT
CALIFORNIA COALITION, AND
LOCALLY, SACRAMENTO AREA
CONGREGATIONS TOGETHER. THANK
YOU. HELLO, TYLER EARL, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ALLIANCE,
COMMUNITIES FOR A BETTER
ENVIRONMENT. PHYSICIANS FOR
SOCIAL RESPONSIBILITY, LOS
ANGELES, AND STANDING TOGETHER
AGAINST NEIGHBORHOOD DRILLING,
LOS ANGELES IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON, CHRISTINA
SCARINGE. I'VE BEEN ASKED TO
NOTE SUPPORT FOR CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
NETWORK. CLIMATE FIRST REPLACING
OIL AND GAS FOSSIL FREE
CALIFORNIA SUNFLOWER ALLIANCE
PROTECT MONTEREY COUNTY ELECTED
OFFICIALS TO PROTECT AMERICA.
CODE BLUE, SANTA CRUZ CLIMATE
ACTION NETWORK AND NEXT GEN
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. SEEING NO OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT, DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION? LEAD
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. JUST
YOU, I GUESS SO. OKAY. YOU HAVE
UP TO FOUR MINUTES, MR. CHAIR,
AND MEMBERS, PAUL DE NIRO, ON
BEHALF OF THE WESTERN STATES
PETROLEUM ASSOCIATION, WE
BELIEVE THIS THIS WOULD
FUNDAMENTALLY CHANGE THE
REGULATION OF OIL AND GAS
EXTRACTION IN CALIFORNIA. IT
WILL RESULT IN A PATCHWORK OF
LOCAL ORDINANCES PROHIBITING
REGULATING, BANNING, BANNING
CERTAIN TYPES OF EXTRACTION. THE
STATE FOR CENTURY REYES HAS
VIEWED OIL AS A STATE RESOURCE,
AS A VALUABLE STATE RESOURCE.
CURRENT PERCENTAGES THAT WE,
PRODUCE IN CALIFORNIA TO MEET
THE DEMAND OF DRIVERS, IS, 25.
WE DO IT IN STATE OIL
PRODUCTION. CALIFORNIA WORKERS.
THE SAFEST, METHODS IN THE
WORLD, THIS WOULD EXACERBATE
THAT PROBLEM. AND WE WOULD BE
IMPORTING MORE FROM FOREIGN
COUNTRIES, PRIMARILY THE MIDDLE
EAST AND SOUTH AMERICA, THAT
COME HERE THROUGH VESSELS. WE
HAVE NO PIPELINES DELIVERING
CRUDE TO OUR REFINERIES FOR ALL
OF THOSE REASONS, WE OPPOSE THE
BILL. THANK YOU. DO WE HAVE ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION IN
THE ROOM? ALL RIGHT. SEEING
NONE, WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO THE
MEMBERS. DO WE HAVE ANY MEMBERS
WHO HAVE ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS? SENATOR GROVE, THANK
YOU, I KNOW I SOUND LIKE A
BROKEN RECORD BECAUSE MY COUNTY
USED TO PRODUCE 70% OF THE
STATE'S OIL AND GAS. AND, YOU
KNOW, IT'S REALLY SAD. I WENT
OUT TO A CHEVRON TOUR WITH AN
INDIVIDUAL, AND I DIDN'T PASS
ONE WORK TRUCK LIKE NOT ONE, IT
WAS REALLY SAD BECAUSE WE USED
TO EMPLOY THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
AND 55% PEOPLE OF SECOND
CHANCERS, 42% PEOPLE OF COLOR,
WOMEN VETERANS, AND IT'S JUST A
SAD THING. WHAT'S HAPPENING WITH
OUR OIL AND GAS INDUSTRY,
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU HAVE ALL THE
INDIVIDUALS THAT COME UP AND GO,
CLIMATE, CLIMATE, CLIMATE,
CLIMATE, CLIMATE AND IMPORTING
THIS PRODUCT THAT WE USE EVERY
DAY, LIKE 1.4 MILLION TO 1.6
MILLION BARRELS EVERY SINGLE
DAY. CALIFORNIANS USE. AND WE
IMPORT IT HERE ON SHIPS. AND IF
YOU LOOK AT THE CLOSEST ROUTE
FROM KERN COUNTY IN A PIPELINE
TO, I DON'T KNOW, A REFINERY, IS
PBF, IT'S LIKE A DOLLAR PER
BARREL FOR TRANSFER. WHEN YOU
SHIP IT OVER, IT'S LIKE 6 TO $8
PER BARREL OR $6 PER BARREL FOR
A TRANSFER. SO WE WOULD REDUCE
THE COST OF FUEL IF WE PRODUCED
CALIFORNIA OIL BY CALIFORNIANS.
FOR CALIFORNIANS HERE, WE'RE
ALREADY USING IT. THIS WHOLE
NONSENSE OF TRANSITION OFF OF,
OIL AND GAS TO, WHAT THEY CALL
GREEN ENERGY, IT'S NOT
HAPPENING. IT'S WE'RE
TRANSITIONING FROM DOMESTICALLY,
SAFELY, YOU KNOW, PRODUCE OIL
AND GAS BY CALIFORNIANS, FOR
CALIFORNIANS, FROM COMPANIES
LIKE RUSSIA. AND THEY SAY WE
DON'T BUY IT FROM RUSSIA. BUT IF
YOU TRACK VESSEL FINDER.COM LIKE
WE DO, YOU'LL SEE THAT THAT SHIP
LEAVES A RUSSIAN PORT, GOES OUT
IN THE MIDDLE OF THE OCEAN,
TRANSFERS TO ANOTHER SHIP THAT
COMES RIGHT TO NEWPORT BEACH, SO
, YOU KNOW, AND OUR POLICIES
HAVE A GLOBAL CONSEQUENCES. AND
WHEN YOU LOOK AT CARBON
EMISSIONS AND CLIMATE CHANGE,
IT'S ROUGHLY BASED 126 MILLION
METRIC TONS OF CARBON EMISSIONS
TO BRING A SHIP HERE, TO LET US
USE THE OIL THAT WE PRODUCE
EVERY SINGLE DAY, YOU KNOW, I
WAS LISTENING TO THE COMMENTS
AND THE BILL SAYS ABOUT COUNTIES
AND CITIES AND YOU SHOULD BE
ABLE TO HAVE A VOICE AND SAY
WHAT YOU WANT. YOU KNOW, KERN
COUNTY DID AN EIR, THE ONLY ONE
THAT IS EVER MITIGATED ANY TYPE
OF CARBON EMISSIONS WAS LORELEI.
OVER AT IN OUR PLANNING
DEPARTMENT. AND WE STILL CAN'T
ISSUE PERMITS. WE WERE FOR A
WHILE, AND THEN IT GOT TAKEN
AWAY BECAUSE OF A COURT CASE. SO
NOW WE'RE WORKING THROUGH THAT
PROCESS AGAIN TO MITIGATE
GRAZING, BECAUSE IF WE MITIGATED
THE GRAZING PIECE FOR CATTLE,
THEN WE WOULD THE EIR PROBABLY
WOULDN'T HAVE BEEN CHALLENGED, I
JUST AM SAYING THAT ALL THIS IS
CIRCUMVENTS WHAT THE COURTS ARE.
A SEPARATE BRANCH OF GOVERNMENT
HAS SAID ALSO THE ISSUE THAT YOU
HAVE WITH PATCHWORK, YOU KNOW,
PRODUCTION GOING ON DIFFERENT,
YOU KNOW, RULES. IT'S A
STATEWIDE RESOURCE. IT'S NOT
BEING USED LIKE IT SHOULD BE. WE
PRODUCE THE SAFEST, CLEANEST
OIL. THEY STILL DO OPEN AIR
FLAMING IN IRAQ, WHERE WE GET A
LOT OF OUR OIL. THEY STILL, THEY
HANG LGBTQ PEOPLE. THE
GOVERNMENT OF IRAQ HAS SAID THAT
THEY ARE DEGENERATES. THAT'S
PUBLIC. THAT JUST HAPPENED A FEW
WEEKS AGO OR A MONTH AGO, AND WE
BUY OIL FROM THEM. SO TO SAY
THAT WE CARE ABOUT POLICY AND TO
SAY THAT WE WANT GOOD
ENVIRONMENTAL POLICY DOESN'T
SHOW UP BY THE POLICY THAT
LEAVES THIS BUILDING, BECAUSE,
LIKE I SAID, 126 MILLION TRANS
VERSUS 12 METRIC TONS FROM A
PIPELINE. THAT'S WHAT, 12 MILES
LONG VERSUS BRINGING A SHIP HERE
FROM FOREIGN COUNTRIES. AND THEN
THE GLOBAL THE GLOBAL IMPACT
THAT OUR POLICIES HAVE ON, YOU
KNOW, WARS AND OTHER THINGS, YOU
KNOW, LAST I CHECKED, ANY OF OUR
OIL COMPANIES THAT WERE
PRODUCING OIL HERE UNDER THE
STRICTEST, MOST ENVIRONMENTALLY
REGULATED PROCESSES THAT WE
CONTROL ARE NOT INVADING OTHER
COUNTRIES. THEY'RE NOT BOMBING
OTHER COUNTRIES. AND WE'RE
SUPPORTING THOSE THINGS. NOW, I
WOULD THINK THAT, I DON'T KNOW,
MAYBE SOME PEOPLE IN THIS
BUILDING BELIEVE THAT THE $5
BILLION THAT WE SENT TO, YOU
KNOW, RUSSIA A FEW TWO YEARS AGO
AND IN THE, BLACK FLAG SHIP THAT
WE DO NOW, MAYBE THEY THINK
THEY'RE UPDATING THEIR PARKS.
WHO KNOWS? BUT THIS IS NOT GOOD
POLICY. NOT FOR THE STATE, NOT
FOR THE CONSTITUENTS, NOT FOR
THE CLIMATE. IT'S NOT. IT'S NOT
FOR THE CLIMATE. THOSE SHIPS
THAT BRING YOU THAT OIL, THEY
CIRCLE. IF YOU AGAIN GO TO
VESSEL FIRE FINDER.COM THEY
CIRCLE OUT THERE RIGHT OFF OUR
COASTLINE, SOMETIMES FOR DAYS
SPEWING, BUNKER FUEL. THAT IS
BURNED ON THESE SHIPS. AND WE
DON'T COUNT THOSE CARBON
EMISSIONS BECAUSE WE ONLY COUNT
12 MILES OFF OUR COASTLINE.
THAT'S THE SMELL THAT COMES FROM
OUR. WHEN THE WIND COMES ACROSS
TO OUR LANDS. AND, IT IT DOESN'T
MAKE ANY SENSE THAT THAT THAT WE
SAY WE CARE ABOUT CLIMATE. WE
SAY WE CARE ABOUT OUR
CONSTITUENTS, THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF THE GLOBAL, THE PLANET
AND THE WORLD AND OTHER
CONSTITUENTS. CGRTS. BUT THE
POLICY THAT COMES OUT OF THIS
BUILDING DOESN'T, SUPPORT IT.
THAT'S MY COMMENT. I DO HAVE A
QUESTION. SO KERN COUNTY CAN SET
ITS OWN RULES AS WELL ON
DRILLING AND PERMITTING. I MEAN,
IS IT RECIPROCAL OR IS IT JUST
ONE WAY? THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENT, SENATOR. AND I DO WANT
TO APPRECIATE, HOW PASSIONATE
THIS ISSUE IS. AND I KNOW YOU'VE
BEEN A HUGE CHAMPION FOR YOUR
COMMUNITIES, AND I HAVE DEEP,
DEEP RESPECT FOR YOUR PASSION
FOR YOUR COMMUNITY. AND I THINK
WE ALIGN IN SOME OTHER WAYS ON
SOME OTHER ISSUES. THIS BILL IN
PARTICULAR WOULD GIVE CITIES AND
COUNTIES JURISDICTION TO
PROHIBIT, OIL AND GAS. I DO
BELIEVE THERE'S A DIFFERENT CASE
THAT KERN COUNTY IS BRINGING
WHERE THEY Tê WANT LOCAL CONTROL
TO BE ABLE TO PERMIT MORE OIL
AND GAS. SO THIS BILL DOESN'T
ADDRESS THAT PARTICULAR CASE. IT
DOES GO THE OTHER WAY. BUT I DO
THINK THERE'S SOME COMMON GROUND
IN TERMS OF WANTING LOCAL
CONTROL AND LOCAL COMMUNITIES
WANTING TO BE ABLE TO HAVE A SAY
OF WHAT'S HAPPENING IN THEIR OWN
ECONOMIES, HOW THIS IS AFFECTING
PROPERTY RIGHTS, HOW THIS MIGHT
BE AFFECTING JOBS, AND HOW THIS
IS AFFECTING THE HEALTH OF THE
PEOPLE THAT LOCAL COMMUNITIES
ARE IN CHARGE OF PROVIDING
HEALTH AND WELFARE FOR. SO, I
HOPE THAT ANSWERS YOUR QUESTION.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
SENATOR GROVE, DO WE HAVE ANY
OTHER SENATOR SATO? HI. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR BILL, YOU KNOW, MY
PROBLEM WITH THE BILL IS THAT IT
FLIES IN THE FACE OF COMMON
SENSE, A LOT OF THE OIL FIELDS
DOWN IN THE SOUTH BAY AREA OF IN
CALIFORNIA. TORRANCE AND ALL
THOSE AREAS, HAVE BEEN THERE A
LONG TIME. AND IF THERE IS A
PROBLEM WITH PEOPLE BUILDING TOO
CLOSE TO OIL FIELDS, THEN THE
CITIES AND COUNTIES SHOULD HAVE
BEEN VERY CONCERNED WITH THAT
WHEN THEY APPROVED BUILDING NEXT
TO ALL OF THE OIL FIELDS, WHAT
THIS SUGGESTS IS THAT WE GO BACK
AND WE SHUT DOWN OIL FIELDS OR
DON'T ALLOW THEM TO REPLACE A
WELL, IF ONE'S NOT AS PRODUCTIVE
IN ONE AREA TO ANOTHER AREA,
LIKE IN BALDWIN HILLS, NONE OF
THOSE AREAS HAD HOUSING. THOSE
WERE OUT IN THE MIDDLE OF
NOWHERE. THE HOUSING GOT BUILT
AFTERWARDS. SO NOW YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT A PROPERTY RIGHTS
TAKING. SO ARE THE ARE THE,
CITIES AND COUNTIES IN QUESTION
GOING TO COMPENSATE, NOT ONLY
COMPENSATE THESE COMPANIES FOR,
FOR TAKING BASICALLY TAKING
THEIR LAND, MAKING IT USELESS TO
THEM, BUT BUT WHAT ARE THEY
GOING TO REPLACE IT WITH?
THEY'RE GOING TO REPLACE IT WITH
WHAT MY COLLEAGUE WAS TALKING
ABOUT, OFFSHORE OIL. AND THOSE
SHIPS THAT SIT OUT THERE. AND IF
THE WIND SHIFTS TO AN ONSHORE
WIND, GUESS WHAT? ALL THAT COMES
ON TO THE LOCAL COMMUNITIES, THE
AREAS THAT, YOU KNOW, WE TALK
ABOUT THE IMPACT TO JUST
MINORITY COMMUNITIES, MINORITY
AND POOR COMMUNITIES, THE
MINORITY AND POOR COMMUNITIES
ARE SO FAR AWAY FROM THESE
AREAS. THEY'RE THEY'RE 5 TO 10
MILES INLAND FROM THESE. THE
PLACES THAT ARE AROUND THAT ARE
CLOSEST TO ALL THESE OIL WELLS,
THOSE ARE SOME OF THE MOST
EXPENSIVE REAL ESTATE IN
CALIFORNIA. SO THOSE ARGUMENTS
DON'T MAKE SENSE. IF WE WANT TO
SHUT OFF OIL, GO TELL THEM TO
SHUT THE SWITCH OFF AND SEE WHAT
SEE WHAT HAPPENS. THAT WOULD BE
A FINANCIAL AND ECONOMIC
DISASTER FOR CALIFORNIA. THERE
IS A BETTER WAY TO DO THIS. IT'S
CALLED THE MARKET. ALLOW PEOPLE
TO TRANSITION THEMSELVES INTO
CLEANER OPPORTUNITIES. IF THEY
FEEL LIKE THAT FITS THEIR
LIFESTYLE. BUT THIS TRYING TO
SHUT OFF ALL THE SPIGOTS FOR OIL
THAT WE USE EVERY DAY AND THEN
BUY IT FROM SOMEWHERE ELSE AND
THEN SHIP IT IN ON DIRTY SHIPS,
FLIES IN THE FACE OF COMMON
SENSE. IT'S NOT GOING TO WORK.
IT'S NOT WORKING. IT SOUNDS
LIKE, OH, YES, WE'RE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT YOUR HEALTH.
WELL, WHERE WERE THEIR WHERE WAS
THEIR CONCERN WHEN THEY BUILT
THESE NEIGHBORHOODS? SOME OF
THEM IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD OF $5
MILLION A HOUSE, RIGHT AROUND
THESE OIL FIELDS. AND YET THOSE
FOLKS ARE NOT CONCERNED ABOUT
THEIR HEALTH EFFECTS. SO, YOU
KNOW, A LOT OF THESE HAVE
EMOTIONAL ARGUMENTS THAT
ABSOLUTELY DON'T MAKE SENSE. AND
WE NEED A BETTER ENERGY POLICY
FOR THIS STATE. OTHERWISE WE ARE
GOING TO HAVE AN ECONOMIC
DISASTER THAT IS GOING TO HAVE
TO BE FELT BY EVERY SINGLE
PERSON IN THE STATE, AND THEY
WON'T BE ABLE TO GO BACKWARDS
AND FIX IT. SO THAT'S WHY BILLS
LIKE THIS RANKLE ME A LITTLE
BIT, BECAUSE IT USES ALL THE
GREAT BUZZWORDS. BUT AT THE END
OF THE DAY, IT DOESN'T MAKE
SENSE. THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE ON THE COMMITTEE?
ALL RIGHT, I WILL JUST CLOSE
BEFORE YOU CLOSE, WE'LL JUST SAY
THAT THIS BILL IS PERMISSIVE AND
ENSURES THAT LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
HAVE AUTHORITY VÆ, BUT ARE NOT
REQUIRED TO USE THAT AUTHORITY.
BUT AUTHORITY TO LIMIT OIL AND
GAS DEVELOPMENT SHOULD THEY
CHOOSE TO DO SO. THERE'S BEEN A
LOT OF DISCUSSION AROUND HOW
THIS MIGHT PLAY OUT, BUT WE JUST
NOTE THAT EACH CIRCUMSTANCE HERE
WOULD BE PARTICULAR TO THE
FACTS, INCLUDING WHETHER THERE
WAS ANY PROPERTY RIGHTS
INFRINGED UPON, AND I KNOW
THERE'S A LOT OF DISCUSSION
TODAY ABOUT MARKETS AND
CAPITALISM, AS SOMEONE WHO WENT
TO PRETTY FANCY BUSINESS SCHOOL,
I'LL JUST SAY THERE'S A WHOLE
SECTION OF ECON 101 AROUND
MARKET FAILURES, TOO, AND ONE
COULD MAKE THE CASE THAT THE
OVER BURNING OF FOSSIL FUELS IS
ONE OF THE BIGGEST MARKET
FAILURES OF OUR, CIVILIZATION,
ONE THAT WE'RE NOW RACING TO TRY
TO CORRECT. AND WE DO HAVE TO
FIND THE RIGHT BALANCE BETWEEN,
FINDING THE RIGHT STANDARDS AND,
YOU KNOW, MAINTAINING OUR
STANDARDS OF LIFE WHILE TRYING
TO HEAD OFF THIS LOOMING
CATASTROPHE, I KNOW BECAUSE MY
OWN, SHORELINES IN ORANGE COUNTY
WERE BADLY DAMAGED BY A OIL
PIPELINE SPILL THAT JUST
HAPPENED ABOUT THREE YEARS AGO.
SO FOR ALL THOSE REASONS, I
THINK THIS IS A COMMONSENSICAL
BILL, PERMISSIVE BILL. I SUPPORT
THIS MEASURE TODAY. AND WITH
THAT, WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE?
WELL, THANK YOU, CHAIR, FOR
THOSE COMMENTS. I APPRECIATE
YOUR EXPERTISE IN ECONOMICS AND
APPRECIATE YOU SHARING THAT WITH
ALL OF US. AND WITH THAT, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. ASSEMBLYWOMAN,
DO WE HAVE A MOTION ON THIS BILL
ANY? OKAY. WE HAVE A MOTION FROM
SENATOR STERN, THE MOTION IS Dð
PASS AS AMENDED. THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT ON AB 3233, ASSISTANT
, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR.
MIN MIN. AYE. SATO. NO. SATO.
NO. ALLEN. AYE ALLEN. AYE.
DALLI. NO. DALLI. NO EGGMAN.
EGGMAN. AYE. GROVE GROVE. NO.
HURTADO NO. HURTADO. NO. LAIRD.
LAIRD AYE. LIMÓN. LIMÓN. AYE.
PADILLA PADILLA. AYE. STERN.
STERN. AYE. SEVEN FOUR. THE
COUNT ON THAT IS SEVEN FOUR. AND
I THINK THE BILL IS OUT. YES.
THANK YOU. FIRST BILL. OUT OF
THE DAY. ALL RIGHT, WITH THAT,
WE'LL GO TO OUR LAST FILE ITEM
OF THE DAY, FILE ITEM NUMBER 16,
SGR 17 BY SENATOR ALLEN,
SENATOR, YOU CAN PROCEED
WHENEVER YOU ARE READY. IT'S NOT
A LOCAL CONTROL ISSUE. TO READ.
WELL, THANK YOU. VERY GOOD
AFTERNOON, MR. CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS. I'M HERE TO PRESENT SDR
717. SORRY A RESOLUTION URGING
OUR PARTNERS IN THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO ESTABLISH NATIONAL
MONUMENTS TO PERMANENTLY PROTECT
THE LÀ AND SAN L®NG, WHICH
REPRESENT HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF ACRES OF ADDITIONAL
CONSERVATION LANDS THAT ARE
CRITICAL TO MEETING OUR 30 BY 30
GOALS AND PROTECT OUR ENDANGERED
BIODIVERSITY. THESE PROPOSED
MONUMENTS INCLUDE THE PIT RIVER
TRIBES ANCESTRAL HOMELANDS OF
SANTEETLAH AND THE MEDICINE LAKE
HIGHLANDS, AS WELL AS THE
CULTURAL HOMELANDS OF FORT YUMA.
INDIAN TRIBE WERE PRIVILEGED
TODAY TO HAVE BAMFORD, WHO'S
HERE, THE PIT RIVER TRIBAL
CHAIRMAN AND ALSO COUNCIL
MEMBER, DONALD MEDART JR, ON
BEHALF OF THE FORT YUMA INDIAN
TRIBE, WHO'S HERE TO TESTIFY ON.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING
HERE. YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES EACH
AND YOU CAN PROCEED WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU.
GREETINGS. I AM JOSH BAMFORD,
CHAIRMAN OF THE PIT RIVER TRIBE
OF THE PIT RIVER NATION, HAS
ASKED PRESIDENT BIDEN AND
CALIFORNIA FEDERAL DELEGATION TO
PUT IN PLACE NATIONAL MONUMENT
PROTECTIONS FOR A LITTLE MORE
THAN 200,000 ACRES IN AN AREA
KNOWN AS SANTEETLAH. THIS
IMPORTANT AREA INCLUDES WHAT IS
COMMONLY KNOWN AS THE MEDICINE
LAKE HIGHLANDS, LOCATED ABOUT 30
MILES FROM MOUNT SHASTA. BEING
ONE OF OUR MOST SACRED PLACES
AND THE LOCATION OF OUR CREATION
NARRATIVE OF OUR PEOPLE, WE HAVE
MAINTAINED OUR DEEP CONNECTIONS
WITH THIS TRIBAL CULTURAL
LANDSCAPE SINCE TIME IMMEMORIAL.
OUR PEOPLE HAVE WORKED
TIRELESSLY TO PROTECT AND DEFEND
SANTEETLAH FROM ONGOING THREATS
WHICH AIM TO DESTROY AND CAUSE
DEGRADATION TO NUMEROUS,
NUMEROUS IMPORTANT RESOURCES
THAT WE AND MILLIONS OF OTHERS
RELY ON DAILY. THESE VITAL
RESOURCES INCLUDE, BUT ARE NOT
LIMITED TO PIER WATER RESOURCES
FOR DRINKING AND AGRICULTURE,
HABITATS, ECOSYSTEMS AND
FISHERIES THAT ARE ALL DEPENDENT
ON SANTEETLAH. SANTEETLAH IS
CULTURALLY, HISTORICALLY, AND
SPIRITUALLY AND ENVIRONMENTALLY
IMPORTANT. DESIGNATING
SANTEETLAH AS A NATIONAL
MONUMENT ENABLES FEDERAL
AGENCIES TO COLLABORATE WITH
TRIBAL NATIONS TO STEWARD AND
PRESERVE CULTURAL RESOURCES AND
LANDS IN A RESPONSIBLE MANNER.
THE PIT RIVER NATION THANKS
SENATOR ALLEN FOR HIS AUTHORSHIP
AND URGES YOU TO SUPPORT THIS
NATIONAL MONUMENT PROPOSAL. WE
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO THANK THE
SENATE NATURAL RESOURCES
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU GUYS FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU. NEXT
WITNESS. YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES.
HELLO, JERRY. AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS DONALD
DART JR. AND I HAVE THE HONOR OF
SERVING AS A COUNCILMAN FOR THE
FORT YUMA INDIAN TRIBE. WE'RE
LOCATED AT THE VERY BOTTOM OF
CALIFORNIA AND IMPERIAL COUNTY.
AND WE SET TO PROTECT 390,000
ACRES OF CURRENTLY OF LAND THAT
IS CURRENTLY MANAGED BY THE
BUREAU OF LAND MANAGEMENT. THIS
LAND IS DIRECTLY ADJACENT TO OUR
RESERVATION, AND IT IS PART OF
OUR ABORIGINAL TERRITORY THAT IS
OF THE UTMOST IMPORTANCE FOR US
TO PROTECT, AS IT HAS MANY
CULTURAL RESOURCES THAT WE STILL
RELY ON TODAY, AS WELL AS THEIR
PETROGLYPHS, GEOGLYPHS, LITHICS,
ARTIFACTS THAT ARE ALL CONTAINED
WITHIN THIS DESERT. AND ALL OF
THESE THINGS PUT TOGETHER
REALLY, THEY TELL THE HISTORY OF
THE SAN PEOPLE AND HOW WE
MIGRATED TO OUR CURRENT LANDS
TODAY. THEY TELL WHO WE ARE
TODAY, AND IT ALSO GIVES A
BRIGHT A BRIGHT INSIGHT TO OUR
FUTURE. THIS IS A PLACE WHERE WE
CAN TAKE OUR CHILDREN OUT. WE
CAN TAKE THE YOUNG PEOPLE OF THE
TRIBE, AND WE CAN LOOK AT OUR
PAST. WE CAN SEE OUR EVIDENCE OF
OUR CREATION AND HOW WE CAME
DOWN TO WHERE WE ARE TODAY. WE
CAN SEE OUR FINGERPRINTS IN THIS
DESERT AND THIS REALLY IS WHAT
DIFFERENTIATES US FROM THE REST
OF THE PEOPLE OF THIS WORLD.
THIS IS WHAT MAKES US, SAN. IT'S
OUR DNA THAT'S WRITTEN OUT IN
THE DESERT. AND THIS IS OF THE
UTMOST IMPORTANCE FOR US TO
PROTECT OUR TRAIL SYSTEMS THAT
WERE COMMUNAL TRAILS FOR ALL OF
THE TRIBES OF THE DESERT
SOUTHWEST ARE CONTAINED WITHIN
THIS AREA. AND EVERY TIME
THERE'S A DESECRATION OF ONE OF
THESE SITES, IT TEARS A PAGE OUT
OF OUR HISTORY BOOK. AS A PEOPLE
. AND WE LOOK TO BE ABLE TO
PROTECT THOSE THINGS FOR THE
REST OF TIME. WE'VE BEEN THE
STEWARDS OF THESE LANDS SINCE
TIME IMMEMORIAL. AND THIS
DESIGNATION OF A NATIONAL
MONUMENT WOULD ALLOW US C
STEWARDSHIP OPPORTUNITIES TO
CONTINUE TO BE STEWARDS OF THESE
LANDS AND REALLY HAVE A SEAT AT
THE TABLE. BUT ULTIMATELY WE'RE
LOOKING FOR CO-MANAGEMENT, AS
THAT WOULD REALLY GIVE US A SEAT
AT THE TABLE AND REALLY ALLOW US
TO HAVE THE LEGAL JURISDICTION
TO BE ABLE TO EFFICIENTLY MANAGE
THESE LANDS, AS WE'VE DONE SINCE
TIME IMMEMORIAL. SO I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN THE ROOM IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL? NAME, AFFILIATION
AND SUPPORT. POSITION ON THE
MEASURE? NICK JENSEN, CALIFORNIA
NATIVE PLANT SOCIETY IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON. I'M ZION WHITE,
COUNCILMAN FOR THE FORT YUMA
INDIAN TRIBE, AND WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT SR 17. THANK YOU. SAM
DAVIDSON FOR TROUT UNLIMITED IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE NATIONAL
MONUMENT PROPOSAL AND THIS
RESOLUTION. THANK YOU, THANK
YOU. THANKS, ALEX. ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA TROUT AND DEFENDERS
OF WILDLIFE AND STRONG SUPPORT,
THANK YOU. SEEING NO OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT, DO WE HAVE
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION? ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION? SEEING
NONE. WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO THE
DAIS. YES. SENATOR DALLI, SO,
JUST A QUESTION AFTER THIS, THE
MEDICINE LAKE IS IN MY DISTRICT
AND IT'S, SO THERE ARE THIS IS
NOTHING THE TRIBE HAS DONE A
VERY GOOD JOB OF ARTICULATING
WHAT THE PIT RIVER TRIBE, WHAT
THEY WHAT THEY NEED. BUT THERE
ARE SOME, INHOLDINGS. OR THERE'S
PRIVATE PROPERTY INSIDE OF THIS
AREA THAT PEOPLE HAVE CABINS,
AND THE MEDICINE LAKE AREA, AND
THERE'S, I KNOW THERE'S A
GEOTHERMAL TEST. WELL, THERE,
WHICH I THINK THAT'S BEEN
DECIDED BY THE COMPANY, I
UNDERSTAND, I THINK THAT THEY'RE
NOT PURSUING THAT, BUT WHAT WHAT
, ARE THOSE WHAT HAPPENS TO
THOSE INHOLDINGS, IF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT MAKES A DECISION,
LOCALLY? YEAH I KNOW, I MEAN,
FIRST OF ALL, THERE'S A MAP IN
THE ANALYSIS, AND I KNOW THERE'S
IT'S NOT, CONTIGUOUS LAND. SO
THERE'S SOME LAND THAT'S BEEN
KIND OF CUT OUT FOR VARIOUS
REASONS THAT MAY HAVE TO DO WITH
PRIVATE INTERESTS, YOU KNOW, THE
THING ABOUT NATIONAL MONUMENT,
THE PRESIDENT CAN DECLARE
DIFFERENT TYPES OF NATIONAL
MONUMENTS, RIGHT? THERE'S SOME
THAT GO INTO THE NATIONAL PARK
SERVICE THAT HAVE A MUCH MORE
RESTRICTED LAND USE, AND THEN,
OF COURSE, THERE ARE SOME THAT
ARE UNDER THE MANAGEMENT OF THE
BLM, SO THERE'S HEIGHTENED,
THERE'S THE OTHER BLM, THE
BUREAU OF LAND MANAGEMENT, YOU
KNOW, SO THERE'S HEIGHTENED
PROTECTIONS ASSOCIATED WITH THE
NATIONAL MONUMENT STATUS, BUT
THERE'S STILL SOME, KIND OF
ADDITIONAL USES THAT ARE ALLOWED
FOR PRIVATE PROPERTY SO THAT
THAT DECISION WOULD ULTIMATELY
BE MADE, MADE BY THE, BY THE
WHITE HOUSE UNDER THE
ANTIQUITIES ACT, BUT THERE ARE
LOTS OF EXAMPLES OF NATIONAL
MONUMENTS HAVING BEEN CREATED
THAT, THAT DO CONTINUE TO
PRESERVE PRIVATE LAND RIGHTS
WITHIN NÓ. I KNOW THAT MY
IN-LAWS ACTUALLY HAVE, IN LASSEN
NATIONAL PARK HAVE A INHOLDING
THAT WAS THERE BEFORE THE PARK
WAS EVER ESTABLISHED. SO IT'S
THE SAME SITUATION AS AS WE'RE
HAVING IN. IF I COULD INTERJECT,
MY STAFF AND I WERE DISCUSSING,
BUT, MONUMENTS DON'T IMPACT
EXISTING AGREEMENTS, SO THEY
HONOR THOSE AGREEMENTS JUST AS A
MATTER OF POLICY. THAT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING AS WELL. YEAH.
OKAY. THANK YOU. I SHOULD HAVE
BEEN MORE SUCCINCT. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS IN THE IN
THE ROOM? OKAY. WE HAVE A MOTION
FROM SENATOR STERN. SENATOR
ALLEN, WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE?
NO, I APPRECIATE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE FOLKS COMING UP
TO BE A PART OF THIS. AND THIS
IS ALL ABOUT MEETING OUR GOALS
AND DOING SO IN A WAY THAT'S
THAT'S RESPECTFUL OF OUR THE
NATIVE PEOPLES OF OUR STATE. AND
WITH THAT, I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE BILL
FROM SENATOR ALLEN. THE MOTION
IS, I'M SORRY, FROM SENATOR
STERN. THE MOTION IS Dð. OR TO
BE ADOPTED ASSISTANT, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR MINH.
AYE. I MINH. AYE SERA SERA I
ALLEN. AYE ALLEN I DALAI.
EGGMAN. EGGMAN I GROVE I GROVE I
HURTADO HURTADO I LAIRD. LAIRD.
AYE. LEMON I LEMON. AYE.
PADILLA. PADILLA AYE. STERN.
STERN. AYE. OKAY THANK YOU.
MAMBO ZERO. OUT THE BILL. THE
VOTE IS TEN ZERO. THE BILL IS
OUT. THANK YOU. MEMBERS. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT. WE WILL, GO TO
THE CONSENT CALENDAR AT THIS
POINT. AND LET'S SEE HERE THE
CONSENT CALENDAR CONSISTS OF
FOUR BILLS. FILE ITEM NUMBER
ONE, SCR 15 BY SENATOR BRADFORD,
FILE ITEM NUMBER NINE, AB 2610
BY ASSEMBLYMAN MEMBER GARCIA.
FILE ITEM NUMBER TEN, AB 2643 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOOD AND FILE
ITEM NUMBER 12, AB 3023 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PAPAN.
ASSISTANT, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
SENATOR ALLEN. ALLEN. AYE
HURTADO. HURTADO. AYE. LAIRD.
LAIRD AYE. LIMÓN. LIMÓN. AYE.
PADILLA PADILLA. AYE. THAT BILL
PASSES 11 ZERO. THE BILL IS OUT.
I'M SORRY. THE CONSENT CALENDAR
IS 11 ZERO. IT IS OUT, WITH THAT
, WE'LL MOVE ON THROUGH FILE
ITEM EACH BILL, WE'LL LIFT THE
CALL ON EACH BILL, ONE TIME. SO,
IF YOU ALL COULD STAY IN THE
ROOM UNTIL WE'RE DONE, THAT'D BE
GREAT. FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO, AB,
1992 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONNER.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS THE
APPROPRIATION ASSISTANT. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL AND CURRENT VOTE
IS THREE AND THREE, WITH, VICE
CHAIR VOTING NO. SENATOR MINH, I
MEAN, I, ALLEN I ALLEN I
HURTADO. HURTADO I LAIRD LAIRD I
LEMON I LEMON I. 567823. YEAH.
OKAY. THREE THE VOTE IS EIGHT
THREE. THAT BILL IS OUT. WE'LL
MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM NUMBER,
THREE, BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
QUIRK-SILVA AB 2038. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS APPROPRIATION SYSTEM,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. AND
CURRENT VOTE IS SEVEN ZERO.
SENATOR MINH, I MEAN, I ALLEN,
ALLEN I HURTADO I HURTADO I
LEMON. THIS IS 28 2038 RIGHT?
YEAH. 2030 88I SARAH LEMON I
THAT'S 11 ZERO OKAY. THAT BILL
IS 11 ZERO. THE BILL IS OUT. I
WILL MOVE ON TO FILE NUMBER FOUR
AB 3150 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
QUIRK-SILVA. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS, AS AMENDED. THE
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION, AN
ASSISTANT, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CURRENT VOTE IS SEVEN ZERO WITH
BOTH CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR VOTING
AYE. SENATOR ALLEN, SENATOR
ALLEN NÓ. HURTADO. HURTADO. AYE.
LEMON STERN. NO STERN. NO. OKAY.
45678. 821 1982. THE VOTE IS 8
TO 2. THAT BILL IS OUT, WE'LL
MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
FIVE, AB 2103 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PELLERIN. THE MOTION IS TO PASS,
AS AMENDED. APPROPRIATIONS
ASSISTANT, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CURRENT VOTE IS SEVEN ZERO WITH
CHAIR VOTING AYE. VICE CHAIR NOT
VOTING. SENATOR ALLEN I ALLEN
AYE. EGGMAN. EGGMAN. SHE'S GONE.
HURTADO HURTADO I. 45678990. THE
VOTE IS NINE ZERO. THAT BILL IS
OUT. WE'LL MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER SIX. AB 2320 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ERWIN. ACTUALLY IS THAT
BILL? NO. I'M SORRY 20. AND THE
MOTION IS Dð PASSES AMENDED
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE ON
THAT ONE IS FIVE ZERO WITH CHAIR
VOTING AYE AND VICE CHAIR NOT
VOTING SENATOR ALLEN I ALAN I
DALI. EGGMAN. OH, I'M SORRY,
EGGMAN ALREADY VOTED GROVE. SHE
WAS ALREADY A NON VOTE. HURTADO
HURTADO I, SENATOR GROVE AB 2320
SUMMER IRWIN I THINK YOU WERE
NOT VOTING ABSTAINED ON THAT.
YES. OKAY. MAKING SURE I WAS A
NO. I'M SORRY. NO, YOU WERE NOT.
YOU WERE NOT VOTING. BUT I
THOUGHT YOU SAID NO. NO. ALL
RIGHT. SO IT'S A NON VOTE,
SENATOR STERN, I. SENATOR STERN,
I12345678 OKAY. THANKS, EVERYONE
, THE VOTE IS EIGHT ZERO. THAT
BILL IS OUT. FILELIGHT WILL MOVE
TO FILE ITEM NUMBER 7AB 2440 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER REYES. THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED.
APPROPRIATIONS ASSISTANT, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. CURRENT VOTE IS
THREE ZERO WITH CHAIR VOTING AYE
AND VICE CHAIR NOT VOTING, ALLEN
Ã ALLEN. AYE. EGGMAN GROVE I'M
SORRY. GROVE ALREADY VOTED.
HURTADO NOT VOTING. LAIRD.
LAIRD. AYE. STERN A STERN. AYE
THREE. FOUR. FIVE. SIX. OKAY.
SIX. ZERO. WELL THAT VOTE IS SIX
ZERO. THE BILL IS OUT, WE'LL
MOVE TO FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHT,
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER GIBSON, AB
2465. THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS ASSISTANT. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. CURRENT VOTE IS 3
TO 2 WITH CHAIR VOTING AYE. VICE
CHAIR VOTING NO. SENATOR ALLEN
ALLEN. AYE. HURTADO Ó. HURTADO.
AYE. LAIRD. LAIRD AYE. LIMÓN.
HI. LIMÓN AYE. PADILLA. STERN.
STERN ALREADY VOTED. ALL RIGHT.
THREE. FOUR FIVE. SIX. SEVEN. 7
TO 2, THE VOTE IS SEVEN TWO.
THAT BILL IS OUT. OKAY, WE'LL
MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM NUMBER 11,
AB 2875 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN, THE MOTION IS DUE.
PASS ASSISTANT, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. CURRENT VOTE IS FIVE ZERO
WITH CHAIR VOTING AYE. VICE
CHAIR NOT VOTING SENATOR ALLEN.
ALLEN. AYE. HURTADO HURTADO.
AYE. LAIRD. LAIRD. AYE STERN A
STERN I. 34578990, THE VOTE IS
NINE ZERO. THAT BILL IS OUT. DO
WE FINISH THOSE THREE? NO. OKAY,
OKAY. OUR NEXT OUR NEXT ITEM IS
FILE ITEM NUMBER 13, AB 3220 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PAPAN, THE
MOTION IS TO PASS, AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS ASSISTANT, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. CURRENT VOTE IS
EIGHT ZERO, WITH BOTH CHAIR AND
VICE CHAIR VOTING AYE. SENATOR
ALLEN ALLEN. AYE. HURTADO
HURTADO. AYE. STERN A STERN AYE
11 ZERO OUT. OKAY. THE VOTE IS
11 ZERO. THAT BILL IS OUT, AND
WITH THAT, I'M SORRY, WE NEED
3182. I'M SORRY, FILE NUMBER 14,
AB 3182 IS OUR LAST BILL OF THE
DAY BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEY.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS ASSISTANT. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. CURRENT VOTE IS
SIX ZERO WITH BOTH CHAIR AND
VICE CHAIR VOTING AYE. SENATOR
ALLEN. ALLEN. AYE. HURTADO.
HURTADO AYE. LAIRD. LAIRD. AYE.
LEMON A LEMON. AYE. PADILLA.
OKAY ALL RIGHT. THAT'S TEN. THE
VOTE IS TEN ZERO. THAT BILL IS
OUT. AND WITH THAT, I WANT TO
THANK EVERYONE FOR YOUR PATIENCE
AND COOPERATION, COOPERATION.
SORRY. WE HAVE CONCLUDED THE
AGENDA. SENATE NATURAL RESOURCES
AND WATER COMMITTEE IS ADJOURNED
. ALL RIGHT.